Allegiance representative Manion the
us okay we will get right to it at uh
09 and our first item our first measure
today is hr24 reaffirming support for
the child labor Amendment to the United
States Constitution the prime sponsor is
the representative Gallagher who is here
he just fill out a pink card welcome
representative
Gallagher
so hi I'm representative Eric
gallager uh of March District March
County District 20 which is conquered
Ward 6 and I'm here today to introduce
hr24 reaffirming support for the child
labor Amendment to the United States
Constitution um so yeah a lot of the
um a lot of the
context necess oh sorry that's my alarm
going off let me I forgot to turn it off
um a lot of the contexts necessary or um
around
um around this resolution is in the
where asses so do you do you mind if I
just read the resolution itself or
you're the prime go to so whereas
whereas child widespread child labor was
common in the 1800s and into the early
1900s whereas the United States Supreme
Court ruled in 1918 in Hammer V
dagenhart that Congress did not possess
authority to regulate child labor
prompting the writing of the child labor
Amendment whereas the child labor
amendment authorizes congress to limit
regulate and prohibit the labor of
persons under 18 years of age recognizes
State legislatur sharing that Authority
with
Congress whereas the child labor
amendment was passed by Congress in 1924
and sent to the states
for ratification and the New Hampshire
legislature ratified it in
1933 whereas no state has
ratified the child labor Amendment since
1937 and in in 1941 the United States
Supreme Court overturned Hammer V
dagenhart in United States versus Darby
lber company and whereas well United
States versus Derby Lumber Company
remains president there since 2018 there
has been renewed interest in the
ratification of the child labor
Amendment closing passage by the Hawaii
sen Senate in 2021 and 2022 and
introduction in several other State
Legislative CH Chambers now therefore
let it be resolved by the House of
Representatives that the New Hampshire
legislature reaffirms its ratification
of the child labor Amendment to the
United States Constitution um so yeah
among the um other state legislature
Chambers legislative Chambers mentioned
um the one that this resolution is act
is based off of is Minnesota since um
Minnesota Minnesota passed a uh similar
resolution um so yeah um the this
amendment to the
Constitution has already been uh
ratified by the majority of States but
um not quite the number
necessary to actually be adopted since
you know there's that um there's that
requirement that I I forget um the exact
number but it it's like 2/3 or 3/4s
or something um that so we haven't quite
reached the threshold for full
ratification yet um and
um the thing is the amendment didn't
come with any sort of expiration date on
it and neither do our
ratifications so our previous
ratification is still valid um and there
is still time for additional
ratifications you'll you you'll see the
same thing happened with the most recent
Amendment to the Constitution the um
27th Amendment which had been around
since the
1700s and um people's old ra States old
ratifications were found to still be
valid and um then led to a renewed
interest in it
um
and ratification
um yeah
so um if if you look at
the if you look at the map of states
that have ratified the child labor
Amendment um
so you know here in the New Hampshire
legislature we often like to say oh
we're not like our neighboring states um
so yeah that's true in this case too um
um the the majority of uh other New
England
states have actually um not ratified it
yet um it it's just New Hampshire and
Maine are the only two New England
states that have ratified it but Vermont
Massachusetts Rhode Island Connecticut
and New York have not ratified it yet
though which is kind
of the opposite um from what you'd
expect based on um modern
political uh Coalition breakdowns but um
yeah it just kind of goes to show you
how political coalitions change over
time and so I think um I think the fact
that we did this in the past is um a
Good Thing Worth recognizing um
especially since yeah we the reason it
says um in the resolution that there's
been renewed interest in ratification of
it is because more states have been
trying to legalize child labor and I
think that's bad and that um we should
allow we should allow Congress to pass
legislation about it um so yeah this
resolution uh
basically signal support for it and
hopefully some of our neighboring states
will notice and
um will
then get around
to signing their own ratifications to it
so we can um finally get this amendment
to the Constitution
pass uh so thanks and I'll take
questions uh I have uh one question uh
representative Gallagher you your
resolution states that the last state to
ratify this amendment was in 1937 is
correctly sorry let um let me just find
what that was that was that was can
1937 and this amendment is still short
of the 38 necessary yeah
um do do you 28 states have ratified it
so far so so my question is my
understanding of amendment ratification
is that there's a seven-year window uh
where for example the Equal Rights
Amendment in the 70s got to 35 and then
after seven years they didn't get to 38
but they there was an extension granted
uh so my my my question is it's long
it's been uh so many years uh it
can can a state still we and we've
already uh according to your resolution
New Hampshire was already ratified the
child labor
Amendment um so yeah the Equal Rights
Amendment was unique in that it included
a deadline for ratification which is
something something that most other
Constitutional Amendments have not
included so yeah an amendment has to
specify explicitly whether or not it's
going to have a deadline attached to it
and the child labor Amendment did not
have such um a a deadline attached to it
so yeah again I'd point you to the 27th
Amendment um the one saying that no
variation and Congressional pay shall
take effect until after there's been um
a new election of Representatives the
first ratification for that was in
1789 and then the last ratification for
that was in
1992 so yeah again that's a period of
over 200 years so this sort of I I think
um a 90-year gap is a lot less than that
and um so yeah it wouldn't be quite as
extreme of a case as with the 27th
Amendment okay thank you thank you for
that any other questions uh
representative thank you for taking my
question this is a genuine legal
question that I don't know the answer to
and perhaps either another member of the
committee somebody here may know if we
were to reject this as an itl would that
serve as a recision of the state's
previous
uh ratifica or ratification of the
amendment no um yeah I I was my my
understanding is that it would would not
um and that
um yeah cuz there are there are other
states that
have um since um failed to pass
resolutions like this one um but are
still listed as having ratified it um so
yeah I think
um so yeah we're still going to have
ratified it either way the main point um
in passing this resolution now is just
to show that we're still interested in
it and yeah basically to reaffirm our
previous support of it as it says to
um try to inspire other states to uh
it thank you representative Philo this
interesting question as representative
shortliffe shook his head and this is a
resolution and this would whatever
happens here would not impact our that's
was my understanding to interesting
question any other
questions San thank you representative
Gallagher Prime
sponsor okay and I think my uh
co-sponsor representative Reed uh will
now be presenting next you say hopefully
but without a pink card there is no she
now
have I been recognized Mr chair uh not
yet uh there is a pink card on the way
it's not we're very strict about such
things in filled out I should have done
it for her I just I planned on finishing
it after I I don't I only have like one
minute which is uh yes okay I see a pink
card in the way uh welcome
representative uh representative Reed
co-sponsor co-sponsor yes thank you Mr
chair and thank you honorable members um
so I just uh am not here so much on a
technical side but I'm happy to try to
answer technical questions except to say
that uh my general support and I I feel
like I shouldn't have to say in the year
2024 that child labor is bad that
children are human beings beings and
child children's rights are human rights
and um I really hope that we continue to
support what we have supported in the
distant past getting rid of child labor
um because it would be a shame to
recognize fewer human rights as we
evolve through our um our overall Arc of
society than we've recognized in the
past I hope that we we aren't going
backwards so I am fully in support um it
is true that it does not um resend our
previous uh ratification if this sort to
fail it's just a resolution that
reaffirms our support and that's really
all I
questions uh seeing none uh thank you
for that seeing no other pink cards at
this time uh we will close this hearing
a minute early that gives us a minute to
prep for uh the next measure which uh
for
probably
okay being uh of time like to open up
the hearing on
hr19 first person I like to call would
Moffett thank you Mr chair hr19 Jones
act uh I'm going to repre some of the
arguments put forth several years ago by
uh gentleman named Brian Riley uh who
worked at the KO Institute and spent a
lot of time on the Jones act so the
Jones act uh is Shand for the Merchant
Marine Act of 1920 passed over a century
ago uh and Mr Riley thought that this
provides a lesson on how economic
controls can can
backfire so the Jones Act is described
by the US Department of Homeland
Security as a protectionist policy
intended to intended to protect and
develop the American Merchant Marine and
US ship building now protectionist
elements of the Jones act include
requirements that ships transporting
goods within the United States must be
us crewed us owned and US built that's
in the
law and
Mr Riley and others think that these
Provisions are not only un unnecessary
but
counterproductive so the Jones act
Defenders and and you'll hear from some
of these folks later uh they alleged
that requiring the use of us Crews for
demestic shipping protects Americans
against foreign terrorists and spies
freely traversing the Mississippi River
for example disguised as ship
operators uh and I think that's largely
a scare tactic because with or without
the Jones act it's illegal for someone
to work in the US without a permanent
resident card or a work permit uh or an
employment related visa and this is true
whether they're transporting merchandise
between us ports or or doing any other
job so the Jones act requirement that
ships transporting goods between
domestic ports must be us-owned
deprives the industry of beneficial
foreign
investment areas of the economy that are
open to foreign investment account for
over 7 million us jobs and other
analysts have pointed out uh that
removing ownership limits would provide
more opportunities for Americans
involved in domestic waterborne
transportation to also benefit from uh
job creating foreign
investment and as with foreign
investment in other Industries besides
shipping ownership of vessels providing
waterborne Transportation would be
screened by the committee on foreign
investment uh which is cfius to mitigate
any national security risk so the so the
National Security argument I think is is
minimal if if it exists at all it's also
been argued that the modern ownership
Arrangements render the Jones act
ownership requirement being American to
be
obsolete but the the most criticized
element of the Jones act has been its
ban on the use of foreign built ships
for domestic shipping now this is unique
in terms of
regulation for example no similar
restrictions apply to domestic
transportation of merchandise by air
rail or truck so you can have uh trucks
that are built in other countries and we
do move stuff around you can have
aircraft to a lesser extent from other
countries moving stuff around but we
can't have ships that are built in other
countries moving stuff around in this
country uh in according to a 2017
Congressional research service report
Coastal siiz container ships built in
the United States cost six to eight
times more than comparable foreign built
ships so we're having a real tough time
building ships in this country the ships
the few ships that we now build build
cost way more than ships that are out
there from other countries but we can't
we have to use these expensive ships
that we're not building
anymore and this is something that needs
attention that's why this this measure
we're hearing this measure today so the
the argument made by proponents of the
Jones act back in 1920 and and you'll
hear some today I'm sure the argument
for the Jones Act is simple the United
States needs a strong ship building
industry and the way to real Iz this
goal is by freeing it of the obligation
to
compete it's it's it's a it's like a
tariff but High tariffs don't
necessarily make Industries stronger
they actually can make them weaker by
reducing competition the Jones act
reduces the incentive for US ship
Builders to
innovate take cars for example foreign
car competition for example has prompted
I believe many of us believe that this
competition is has been good for
American car manufacturers the fact that
somebody could buy a Toyota years ago or
or today um makes Ford or GM uh it
pressures them to to do better if if you
couldn't buy a foreign
car like you can't use a foreign ship
then the the uh the the car makers
wouldn't have the same pressures to to
perform or or for
excellence so I think I think you get my
point there so according to the US
Maritime Administration the United
States non-defense oceangoing vessel
fleet has declined from 193 ships in
2000 to 96 as of 2018 it's probably less
than that now in our Navy and again this
is veterans committee our Navy is down
to about 280 ships China is pushing 500
ships our ship building industry is in
in crisis I think many of us think and
the Jones act this protectionist Jones
Act is is impacting uh ship building not
only in the on the civilian side but you
know the the places that are involved in
ship building uh on the military side uh
are also
impacted uh some of the strongest
Transportation manufacturing Industries
in the United States operate in a low
tariff environment free trade Freer
trade uh us production of aircraft
Railroad stock automobiles big trucks
has been increasing because there's
competition and we can have foreign
trucks I already made that point
moreover the effective tariff rate for
imported recreational boats uh you know
if you ever been to Winn or lake
the boats are everywhere some of these
boats are built uh in other countries
and they're not these recreational boats
are not covered by the Jones act so we
have all kinds of uh boats uh
recreational boats that this does that
aren't that we're fine so clearly
American manufacturers don't require
High tariffs to be successful in fact
this success is contingent on low
tariffs free
trade um you know we don't we don't need
barriers that that prevent Innovation
and competition and quality so to head
down the home stretch here here's a
specific example there were many of them
here's one of how the Jones act hurts
America uh a Washington State fishing
company called Fisherman's finest uh
they commission a new ship as I said
it's it's unfortunately it's hard to
build ships now but we still build a few
and so uh Fisherman's finest commission
a new ship from uh a ship Builder Dakota
Creek Industries however because 7% of
that ship Steel
was from
Holland the ship was not allowed to fish
in coastal
Waters um I'm a George wool fan George
Will wrote quote fomenting spous
National Security anxieties is the first
Refuge of rent seeking rent seeking
Scoundrels who tired up protectionism is
patriotism when they inv vagal
government into lining their pockets
with their fellow citizens money unquote
so trade barriers undermine US security
by weakening the economy and creating uh
conflict with our allies by diminishing
free trade so to make this relevant to
New Hampshire New England here in New
England we need fuel oil natural gas it
was 5 degrees this morning I know it's
been warm lately uh it was 5 degrees in
Lowden I'm sure it was colder than that
in Littleton I'm going to guess up North
so it gets cold excuse me it gets cold
here and we need fuel oil we need
natural gas pipelines are great but some
of you may know they're largely tapped
out and regulations make it harder to
build new ones we'd love many people
love to have a pipeline but New York
won't let the pipeline come to us so
because New York won't let the pipeline
come to us with for natural gas or
whatever we need uh fuel oil or natural
gas or whatever to come by
ship
so
a recent Wall Street Journal
article stated that the Jones act
limitations add
costs
um the these added costs encourage fuel
to be exported overseas and here's the a
problem a good
example there's a lot of O oil for
example is comes out of Louisiana or
that part of the country the the the
southeast uh and because of the Jones
act ships could take this oil to Holland
to the
Netherlands and they couldn't take it to
New England so this this oil American
Oil had to go to Europe and then uh
ships in the Netherlands uh would take
the soil to to New England so if you're
tracking me uh they you go because of
the Jones act this oil couldn't come to
us from Louisiana it had to go to Europe
and then come to us to meet the
requirements of the Jones act I just
don't think that increases costs
increases uh expenses the expenses make
fuel more expensive how much more
expensive you know people debate that so
anyway to finish up the Jones Z is over
100 years old instead of receiving
unending protection from International
competition ship Builders should operate
in the same low tariff policy under
which manufacturers of trucks
automobiles aircraft and other
Industries are thriving the Jones act
should not be allowed to inflict another
100 years or another 10 years or another
one year of of damage in the United
States economy so I hope in this gets to
exec session you'll support this
resolution I know you'll hear more about
it today and you'll have plenty of time
to uh review all the testimony and I'll
be happy to take any questions if there
are any do I have any questions
represent Char thank you thank you for
question um the Jones act requires uh
cargo being transported between us ports
to go on US flag
carriers we have uh several islands
Virgin Islands Squam Hawaii American
Samoa um Puerto Rico uh that don't have
the capability of producing food enough
food in those islands for their own
people Everything Must Go On American
flag carrier to those islands do you
have any idea what that may cost the
increasing cost for those people and
many of them are lowincome to have food
shipped to those islands on American
flag caras thank you for the question I
hadn't thought of that it's a great
question now now that you mentioned it I
don't have a an immediate answer to that
but that's something I want to look into
I had mentioned the the problems with
fuel um but you you bring up the
problems with some places with food I
hadn't thought of that but that's
something I'm going to find out more
about because that's a great question
and um
I think food is important to be able to
move freely in our country as well as
question another
question representative Manion
representative Manion excuse me I had my
hand
up I had my hand up first okay finny
he's Manion I'm
finny uh thanks I just wanted to know if
you know how many states have already
pushed this through through through the
legislators question I think I heard was
how many many other states are pushing
uh this type of resolution to pressure
Congress into repealing the Jones act uh
a good number of other states are
um the reason I brought this up was that
I was at a legislative conference where
there was a session on this that I just
happened to sit in on that much better
much better than I just did explained
the the concerns and problems with the
Jones act so I know that uh other states
are doing the same thing in terms of
trying to shine a light and raise
awareness about the problems of the
Jones act so I don't know how many other
states but I know uh this is also being
uh addressed elsewhere as well thank you
for the
question go ahead
representative thank you for taking my
question um the concerns that I'd seen
on on this particular Bill were um
around security um and on supplies being
delivered specifically to um us cargo
ships and I was curious if um um you
could address some of that and is there
any way that you have looked into this
to somehow divest that piece of it from
the piece that is the ship building um
which seems to be the higher cost sure
good question uh with regard to
separating the security concerns from
the the ship building piece there yeah
the different pieces
are involved with the Jones act uh the
security part I did touch on that and
this may come up later
uh concern that have come up are that if
you have foreign ships uh moving about
the the Mississippi River I I've heard
that
or in any Harbor you know could have
foreign ship with that increase the
likelihood of like terrorism uh so that
security concern has come up I I
mentioned it earlier and you asked a
good question about it but as I
mentioned earlier
uh there are all kind kinds of of uh U
protocols in place to ensure that anyone
who is working in any capacity legally
anyway working legally in any capacity
has to uh you know show who they are
they have to have uh visas or work
permits uh green cards and that type of
thing so th those security measures are
in place
for uh all kinds of jobs um and so this
the security concerns that the Jones act
supposedly helps to prevent uh I think
really aren't relevant you know if if
somebody can
work for a bus transport or Train
Transport or trucks uh and they're not
citizens you know or Americans you know
during co uh we experienced a situation
where we didn't have any microchips for
any of our Electronics because they were
all made out of the country can you see
a situation where because we are unable
to do ship building in our own country
and a reliant on outside of our country
to get our ships we might experience a
similar
situation yeah thank you for the
question um and you mentioned uh
computer chips uh many of which are made
in Taiwan uh which goes to a different
resolution that I had a week ago um but
yeah I touched on that that's a a great
point is there a security concern if if
uh if ships are if we depend on
foreign uh help with for whether it's
foreign steel or foreign pirats uh I
mentioned in my testimony just because
7% of the steel in a in a certain ship
came from non-american sources then that
uh ship uh was not qualified under the
Jones act so to your point to your
question uh that I think is a very valid
concern for SEC uh not only for economic
reasons but national security reasons if
if our ship building industry is is is
waned as much as it has uh you know as a
military person I I'm very concerned
about the our shrinking Navy and U you
know Portsmouth Naval Shipyard does do
some fitting of ships and they you'll
build a submarine there uh up in Maine
um at the Iron Works that they build
ships and it takes forever and and uh we
just don't build ships like we used to
and part of the reason the Jones act uh
thank you for that that great
question
representative thank you for taking my
question last year on Commerce Committee
we heard very similar testimony to a
bill concerning the Jones act uh and
commerce voted 18 18 to Zer to place
that on a consent calendar itl which was
adopted by the house in what Manner does
this bill uh differ from Senate Bill 102
and what has changed since last year
regarding the Jones act which would
prompt this action now sure thank you
for the question uh I think you're
referring to a bill and I'd have to look
at the language of the bill you're ahead
of me that this is not a bill this is a
resolution and the intent of this
resolution is to uh raise awareness
about the problems with the Jones act
and hopefully to prompt eventually
congressional action to repeal it uh and
so just the fact that we're having this
sharing we're talking about it and that
um people are watching and will watch on
YouTube and then there'll be more
testimony and we'll have an exec session
so that's the intent of the resolution
um I very interesting I and I want to
find out more about the what you
described because if there are
precedents in in terms of addressing the
Jones act in in this body uh um I'd be
interested to to go back and read
whatever went to Commerce Committee
which I I think that was a bill though
not a resolution correct uh correct it
was a it was a Senate bill which was
actually to create a a study committee
to send a similar resolution to Congress
regarding the Jones act so it prompted
very similar testimony to what we've
just heard which prompted the 18 itl so
that if I may may ask you a question uh
Mr chair may I ask him a question
absolutely um so so the measure you
described was a Senate bill that passed
the Senate came to the house Commerce
Committee where it didn't move forward
is that correct uh that that's correct I
don't know what the vote was in the
Senate but it did move to house Commerce
where it was uh ited and I actually
wrote the report on it which is why I to
remember uh this particular Bill okay
yeah I'm very interested I want to find
out more about that if it passed the
Senate it must have had some value but
uh not every Senate measure U makes it
through our our U our
body any further
questions seeing none thank you
chair next one up Dan Maguire
representative Dan
mgu
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
Maguire I represent the town of Epsom
I'm a co-sponsor of this bill and um I
also handed out to you a short article
um for more short C shipping get the
federal government out of the way um I
just want to add I I agree with uh
representative moffett's uh um testimony
but I I'll add you know a couple more
examples to to try to bring things um a
little bit more into our own lives um if
you're somebody like me who likes to
take cruises for example um you you know
you'll notice pretty e quickly that if
you want to take a cruise out of Boston
you have basically two choices you can
cruise up to Canada or you can go to ber
muda right um for some reason you can't
take a cruise from Boston down the East
Coast you know and stop in New York and
Charleston and Florida and stuff like
that well why is that that's the Jones
act right uh similar reason you can't
fly to Hawaii and just take a cruise
right around the Hawaiian islands and
fly home you have to cruise the Hawaiian
islands and then your cruise ship has to
take a short
you know go off to vanatu or some other
little island nation somewhere or you
have to start in Los Angeles go to
Hawaii come back to Mexico and then come
back to Los Angeles that's the Jones act
for you the Jones act because all cruise
ships and most Cruise crew are uh
foreign right because it's so much
cheaper um the Jones act requires that
such trips include foreign stop they
can't be 100% domestic and so um it
affects us I mean that's a simple one
but it but it does affect us the the
more serious example is the one
representative Moffett mentioned
fuel right so so an extremely important
fuel um for New England is natural gas
that's why we're in a nice warm room
today and right outside that window it's
um it's and and that's what's keeping
our lights on is natural gas and so the
the consequence of the Jones Act is we
pay twice as much for electricity as
they do down South for example because
we have to import all our fuel and it
has to come by very expensive means
right so we can't just a natural gas
ship can't go from Louisiana to Boston
and drop off its gas right we have to
all the ships that leave Louisiana with
with gas go to Europe and we import at
least we used to from Russia our natural
gas we can't use American natural gas I
mean it's just it's just really
ridiculous and and it causes our prices
to just be out of this world
um so that's the Jones act for you I
mean and and um if you're worried about
you know American industry Etc the the
thing is even with the Jones act we
don't have a ship building industry
natural gas ships for example um there
are a handful of natural gas ships made
in the United States but they're little
tiny ones that just move they refuel
other ships right they have little tiny
amounts of gas big big you know the
ships that are made in South Korea or
Germany or whatever
those ships hand have 50 or 40 times as
much natural gas those are the real
ships that that ship things in bulk and
and and those are simply not made in the
United States so so even the purpose of
the Jones act isn't working right so if
the purpose was to to boost American
industry well it's not doing it right so
um and if you want a a simple in another
uh field if you want a simple example of
the benefits of deregulation of of of
getting rid of protectionism in this way
just go read up on uh New Zealand and
the uh Farm um deregulation they did in
the in the 80s because it's been a
tremendous boost to to uh New Zealand
farming they used to have subsidies they
used to have protectionism they used to
have stuff that's equivalent to the
Jones act they got rid of it they had a
little hiccups for a while
but they're they currently um New
Zealand has 5 million people but they
make enough food for 40 million people
you know so uh their farming business is
is tremendous so um thank you very much
Mr chairman will you take any questions
uh sure I I listened to a few of the
others I'm not sure I can answer almost
any of them I'll I'll make a comment on
this um study committee thing uh part of
the reason the the house
the Senate loves study committees and
they they pass them like candy or
something but but uh the house doesn't
and so that could have been what
happened to to the bill that was talking
about over there so okay do you have any
questions seeing none thank thank you
representative I apologize I can't stay
for the rest of the
hearing and next one
up is it Kyle Burson I pronounce that
right you nailed it despite my poor
handwriting could you uh spell your name
n may I begin you may
begin uh thank you good morning
committee members my name is Kyle
burlson director of State advocacy for
the American waterways operators awo is
the national trade Association for the
tugboat towboat and Barge industry we
have 300 members throughout the United
States including those serving in
calling on the port of Portsmouth I'm
testifying today in opposition to
hr19 uh the Jones act known formerly as
the merchant Mariner Act of 1920 is the
United States law requiring cargo move
between us ports be transported on
vessels owned by us companies built in
US shipyards and crewed by us Mariners
the men and women of the US Towing
industry comprise the largest segment of
the 40,000 vessel strong Jones act Fleet
and they play a vital role in the
nation's supply chain the US Maritime
industry supports more than 650,000
people and contributes more than $150
billion in economic input in New
Hampshire alone the maritime industry
contributes over $230 million annually
the state economy provides good family
wage jobs for New Hampshire residents
the Jones act has broad support across
the political Spectrum as well as across
the United States uh to address your
question representative finny no state
has passed a resolution uh calling for
abolishing the Jones
act um ensuring that Americans serve
Americans helps both workers and
businesses but the Jones act also serves
the United States another important
respect being National Security
addressing the text of the resolution I
want to start with the first Clause that
states the Jones act has been a
detriment to National Security I agree
100% with with the bill sponsor that uh
a more comprehensive Maritime strategy
is needed to bolster US ship building
but there's no dispute that our military
leaders have spoken in full-throated
support of the Jones act just last year
General Jacqueline van oest commander of
us Transportation command testified in a
US House armed services Committee
hearing that the Jones act along with
other federal laws and policies ensure
that we have the necessary US flag
capability and US Mariners during peace
time and are ready to move sensitive
defense materials during a National
Emergency additionally in 2020 a
bipartisan group of national lawmakers
described the Jones act as an important
asset to our military noting that us
crude vessels around the world expand
our military's Horizon by serving as the
eyes and ears of our nation and in
keeping our mil milary well supplied
losing the Jones act They concluded
would hurt our ability to project power
during a time of war or National
Emergency this is no less true for New
Hampshire the port of Portsmouth is one
of the US Navy's most important
operational areas in the country and the
Jones act ensures that the Navy can
Charter American vessels with American
workers both of which are regulated by
the US Coast Guard to assist with its
operations it also Bears mentioning the
Jones act helps preserve a domestic ship
building industry and ensures skilled
workers in the industrial base needed to
ramp up ship building if needed for war
including at the poron Naval Shipyard
just across the border the importance of
the Jones Act of National Security is
further highlighted by recent stories
you may have seen in the Wall Street
Journal uh regarding the possible use of
Chinese manufactured Harbor cranes by
the Chinese Communist party to gather
information about American ports which
are some of our most critical pieces of
infrastructure weakening of the Jones
act would go beyond that allowing
foreign Nationals to move products
including Dangerous Ones such as
petroleum products and fertilizer
throughout our nation's extensive
Coastal and inland waterways this is
just one more reason the Jones act has
such strong support from our military I
also want to comment briefly um on the
protectionist nature of this um the US
House select committee on China as well
as the Hudson Institute have done a
tremendous amount of research on this uh
the Chinese government subsidizes ship
building to about hundred billion dollar
a year and they build ships they don't
need sell them at cut rates and uh
there's no telling what would happen if
our ship building industry dissolved
that we needed to move cargo over
um if if the Chinese government would
simply allow that um to speak to what
the resolution States about energy costs
I want to share the most recent study
done on the impact of the Jones act on
us petroleum markets which was completed
by the National Bureau for economic
research was released just this last
December with regard to the New England
Market the study found that the Jones
act adds
.003 to each gallon of gasoline and the
results for diesel natural gas and home
heating fuel would be comparable in
other words the Jones act adds 0.3 cents
to a gallon of gas and that study has a
fatal flaw that assumes that
International carriers would pass that
nominal savings on the consumers rather
than pocketed as profit which is what we
have seen repeatedly whenever A Jones
act waiver has been granted the study
also assumes that foreign tankers can
operate within us domestic Commerce
exempt from us laws including income tax
immigration wage hour employment laws
among others there's no industry that
can do
that that 0.3 cents per gallon I
mentioned was compared to the costs of
crude oil taxes distribution and
refining reflects an infimal cost and
refutes the resolution's assertion that
the Jones act pushes more carbon
intensive surface Transportation modes
and inflates the rates of those modes
for any bulk product Maritime shipping
is the greenest safest and most
cost-effective way to move that product
in fact trucks create a th% more
emissions in Maritime Freight to move
the same amount of cargo and trains
create 30% more emissions a marine
Vessel can move one ton of cargo 6 75
mil on one gallon of fuel compared to
472 Mi by Rail and just 151 Mi by truck
I would be remiss if I didn't share that
the United States domestic Maritime
Fleet International carries already work
in tandem to provide timely delivery of
fuel for New Hampshire in 2022 the port
of Portsmith saw 96 vessel deliveries of
home eating oil and other important fuel
products amounting to about two arrivals
per week totaling millions of barrels of
fuel for New Hampshire
residents however owing largely to New
Hampshire's proximity to Canada around
2third of your fuel comes from Canada
from uh Irving's refiner in St John's
New
Brunswick and that's brought in
international vessels so nonjon act
vessels um so for two-thirds of the fuel
you're getting the Jones Act is already
not a factor well us vessels have a
healthy presence in Portsmouth
delivering Fuel and conducting ship
Assist work and building more vessels in
New England shipyards to support the
market it is erroneous to direct
concerns over the cost of energy towards
the Jones act when two-thirds of New
Hampshire's fuel shipments are made at
International vessels
indeed hr19 references terminating the
Jones act as a way to decrease fuel
costs but the cost of shipping has
virtually no impact on the cost of fuel
to Consumers fuel prices around the
world are determined by oil companies
and any transportation savings are
pocketed by energy traders in short when
the Jones Act is waved it is oil Traders
not consumers and certainly not American
Mariners who benefit there's no reason
to believe that terminating the Jones
act would have a different result awo
members and partner companies are proud
to serve the people of New Hampshire as
a Frontline industry vital to its supply
chain and studies on the impact of the
Jones act have repeatedly affirmed its
importance to the nation for these
reasons we urge this committee to vote
against hr19 and remain committed to
working with all legislators in New
Hampshire on Maritime issues I uh I
thank you very much for your time and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
have do we have any
questions yes representative Manion
thank you for taking my question uh you
mentioned the two-thirds comes uh
internationally do you think that's a
chicken and egg thing like we wouldn't
be getting two-thirds if their Jones act
didn't exist we would have more domestic
trade uh I think in that case um you are
much closer to Canada than you are in
New York or Philadelphia where the major
energy ports are uh in north in in the
United States so I think it's it's a uh
it's a
geographic uh matter and I know uh Mr
Moffett mentioned something about
product going from Louisiana to Holland
back here I I would love to see evidence
of that because you know my my testimony
uh Bears out and the research Bears out
the transportation costs um the the
distance you're traveling vastly
outweighs the uh the the additional cost
that Jones act might might Levy I I have
not heard of that and I i' would love to
get more information about
it any further
questions seeing none thank you sir
everybody okay next person I like to
call up is Andrew St stala is it I'm
sure I mispronounced that go correct
me could you please uh spell your name
for the record yes good morning my name
is Andrew strel s r o s a l and I'm an
attorney and a former Merchant Mariner
from Dover New Hampshire um I'm here
today to speak in opposition to hr19 the
resolution to repeal the Jones act and
also to offer some testimony to previous
testimony delivered this morning um
listening to Kyle's test Tony he's taken
some of the wind out of my sales because
we shared many of the same facts and
figures um but uh the quote that um
fourar General uh van o alast of the
commander of United States
Transportation command delivered was the
Jones act and cargo preference laws work
to ensure that we have the necessary US
flag capability and US Mariners during
peace time and readiness to move
sensitive defense material during a
National
Emergency we rely on Commercial
capabilities that enable the Department
of Defense joint power projection and
highlight the Strategic nature of our
shipyards and sea ports as a reason why
investments in Grant programs like the
port infrastructure development program
are essential in expanding
Transportation nodes and
capacity as I mentioned I'm from dber
New Hampshire I'm a graduate of Maine
Maritime Academy and I'm the vice
president of the main Maritime Academy
alumni association I believe uh some
graduates from Main Maritime Academy
have written to members of the committee
and uh submitted um their opinion uh and
testimony for you I'm a former Mariner
uh I'm master of unlimited tonnage um in
rebuttal to some of the testimony today
I worked on real ships that ship things
that were built in the the United States
I'm a plank owner of a us-built ship uh
that was built in San Diego California
it was about 900 ft long it was an
underway replenishment ship I brought
food Fuel and ammunition uh to warships
at Sea as a US flag Mariner uh those
same Mariners are also Jones act
Mariners I I was a Jones act Mariner as
well uh the the graduates from the
maritime is in New England and
throughout the country serve as the
officers on board these vessels uh they
have credentials and education that
provide Safe
Transportation uh support for domestic
security and uh support for National
Security efforts as
well uh just to deliver some facts and
Hammer home uh what you've heard
previously uh the National Bureau of
economic research found that the Jones
act adds
.003 cents per gallon to the cost of
gasoline in New
England uh Maritime transportation is by
far the most environmentally friendly
way to move cargo trucks create 1,000
times more admissions than Freight than
Maritime Freight to move the same amount
of cargo trains create 30% more
emissions than Maritime
Freight a marine Vessel can move one ton
of cargo
675 miles on one gallon of fuel a truck
can do 151 miles and a rail car can do
miles importantly for New Hampshire
according to a price Waterhouse Cooper
study um put forward by the
transportation Institute there are 1210
domestic Maritime jobs throughout New
Hampshire that's Jones act related jobs
right here in our state the related
labor income from from those jobs is
approximately 775 million
annually the total economic impact from
domestic Maritime activity in New
Hampshire is nearly $237 million
annually further a study by the United
States Maritime Administration part of
the Department of Transportation
covering both Commercial and Military
ship construction identified
approximately $91 million in annual
Shipyard economic impact in New
Hampshire and more than $61 million in
worker income is attributable to the
shipyard industry in the
State uh of note Shipyard jobs pay
approximately 45% more above the
national average for private SE sector
employment and to put on a national
perspective the domestic Maritime
industry accounts for 650,000 Jobs 41.6
billion in labor compensation
$14.8 billion in economic input and
$16.8 billion in taxes there are more
than 40,000 vessels in America's
domestic Maritime Fleet which is one of
the largest in the
world uh in response to a question that
you raised representative shirtliff
earlier um I have personal knowledge
that uh regarding the Jones act in
Puerto Rico when hurricane Maria hit uh
Puerto Rico in
2017 uh a few of the American uh
carriers the Jones act carriers at
service PTO Rico regularly had
pre-staged um cargo containers on the
ground in Puerto Rico anchored them down
to weather the storm so that once the
storm had passed there was food and
water re readily available for the
people of Puerto
Rico because of the Jones Act those
carriers regularly service they have a
liner service between the mainland and
Puerto Rico so they had employees ready
to unpack unpack those containers and
distribute that uh food and water to the
people of Puerto Rico that were in need
when the power was out similarly uh the
Hawaiian Islands are uh supported by
Jones act carriers that provide regular
service and uh the leadership of Hawaii
recognizes the import
of the Jones act so that they have that
reliability of service so that their
grocery stores have food uh their um gas
stations have gasoline and they have
really uh available uh fresh water and
other food uh needed in case of natural
disaster uh it's the reliability of
those United States companies United
States ships United States Mariners that
is so important and why the Jones Act is
so important
domestically uh I have no nothing to add
questions thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my
question uh you mentioned um American
shipping taking care of uh the Hawaiian
islands and and other Islands uh just
curious on my part how did America
shipping how what did they do when the
Maui had those massive
fires I am unaware of what uh personally
the the shipping did uh during that I
know that um there is regular service to
Maui and there are is regular service by
Jon act vessels between the Hawaiian
Islands so um whether there was support
that came from aahu uh the big on over
to Maui or there was uh further support
from the mainland over to Hawaii and
then those um that cargo was distributed
between the islands there is regular
service in place there that is part of
the Jones act to support
Maui followup Mr
chairman followup Mr
chairman absolutely thank you um you
talked earlier about the pollution that
trains produced that vehicles produce uh
ships at Sea I'm a I was a Tin Can
Sailor back in the last century so ships
at Sea uh routinely pump
vges and that lends to the pollution uh
do you have any information on how much
pollution that would be so um thank you
for your service in the tinan fleet um
environmental regulations have become
much more stringent uh there's uh such
things as oily water separators on board
vessels and other things but you are not
permitted to uh dump Villages overboard
uh and so the the environmental
regulations both nationally and
internationally prevent the um
distribution of oil into our oceans and
garbage over the side uh so those
environmental regulations have been um
changed updated and our coasts and our
waterways are protected because of it
yeah I served in the 60s so I'm sure
things
changed yes representative Manion thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question the uh 0.03 cents that it keeps
mentioning is that gasoline and natural
gas or just
gasoline uh I have according to my facts
and figures that I have in front of me
it's gasoline okay thank
you any further questions yes
representative yeah I've had a question
all along I'm not sure who can really
answer it but it keeps coming up in my
mind is is um how much of this is
related to like the extra like you know
stops and everything are related to the
getting the oil to a Refinery than to
its destination if anyone knows that
possibly um so I'm not sure that that's
related to the Jones act the um
Logistics of between when the oil is
retrieve from the ground to refinement
to the gas pump okay all right thank
you any further questions seeing none
you that say right
there okay the next one uh
mlof thank you Mr chairman
representative Tim MCU from marac
co-sponsor of the bill I have written
testimony for the clerk I'll give you a
copy not going to spend too much time on
the written testimony because uh there's
been a few folks ahead of me so I'm here
to speak for the consumer the consumer
that benefits from increased
Supply the consumer that benefits from
lower cost of goods sold including those
shipping
costs so my nephew my oldest nephew was
a graduate of Sunni Maritime captain on
their football team and an unlimited T
Master running inline tugs up and down
the coast of San Diego to Alaska
Etc my uh one of my older brothers is 40
years in the natural gas and oil
business out of Houston Texas so as you
can imagine this is a topic that we've
discussed around an occasional dinner
table Gregory's now uh out of that out
of that
business he saw the issues in in the
industry and also saw an opportunity to
be a coder like like many folks have
done in in California so let me talk a
little bit about the simple economics of
this is there anyone here that doesn't
believe if you increase
Supply that that 03 cents which actually
is a little larger than that won't come
down and it'll be a net decrease to the
cost of goods who hasn't seen the
hundreds of ships backed up holding your
Amazon deliveries or whatever it might
be off the coast of pick a port my
parents lived in Savannah Georgia for
over 20 years busiest port in the
country you can see the impact in the
bottleneck of the supply chain and this
is one of the most basic economic
Concepts on the planet increased
supply cost will come down increase the
cost or decrease the cost of shipping
and operating those
ships it has nothing to do with our Port
security or our ability to enforce
National Security we have an incredibly
competent military coast guard etc etc
I've been on those ships as well by the
way I've sold medical devices into those
into many of those ships and supplied
them off their giant Manual of things
that they can order order from I
forgotten the name of that huge manual
I'm sure the gentleman behind me can
tell me tell me so that's really the
bottom line on this it's got a little
more detailed written testimony but it's
a hundredy old Act Right the Merchant
Marine Act of
1920 and it's
archaic we we didn't Envision the kinds
of bottlenecks and the need uh and the
disruption in the global supply chain
that this kind of protectionist act
would have a 100 years later at the time
it was right on point and probably a lot
of for many years since
then but now it's a different global
economy we have and by the way Senate
Bill 102 that came through Commerce
which is my primary committee now uh had
to do with studying the effects of
heating and energy costs and it was a
study committee in a budget year that
had $250,000 attached to it so three
strikes and you're out on that in a
budget year house hates well Commerce in
particular and the house in general
doesn't like study committees we had a
special commission to get rid of some of
them and the fact is that any chairman
as you know Mr chairman can make a study
committee without legislation
to study any issue so that's why that
bill died but it did pass the Senate
unanimously because they do happen to
like study committees especially when
there aren't any Senators on
them so that's their habit we send them
a study committee they take all the
Senate membership off and and I'm sure a
former speaker is well aware of
that so this is a simply an act or or or
an urging of repealing an act to support
free trade that ultimately benefits the
consumers consumers who I hear time and
time again and I say this on almost any
Bill like this the most common thing I
hear is how are we going to put food on
the table and gas in the tank
representative shirtliff asked about how
does this affect US Virgin Islands well
I was fortunate enough to escape to St
Thomas for a short time during the
height of covid and the biggest shock
was $49 a pound for
swordfish 70% of the fish in St Thomas
is imported I know that seems crazy
that's a whole different issue I'll tell
tell you about it sometime $14 a pound
for butter and I don't mean fancy butter
at the tourist Whole Foods I'm talking
about the public grocery that's where we
would shop we would go I mean it's
there's only about three grocery stores
major grocery stores uh on that island
but $4 a pound for a pound of
butter I mean un staggering price
staggering prices it's because of that
bottleneck and that Monopoly so if you
want to do something about that open up
free trade break up this Monopoly that
has it will have no effect on Port
security if you're confident in the
ability of our Coast Guard and our
homeland
security urge our Congress to repeal
this archaic piece of
legislation not sure I can answer any
technical questions but I'm happy to
answer questions related to my
testimony seeing no questions thank you
sir
representative got two cards left next
one up is all right this is kind of a
squiggly line JD and it stats with a be
last
name Bernat okay I see
you could you spell your name for the
record
please yes thank you b r n a r d y I'm
uh I represent Rockingham 36 which is
Hampton
Falls Kensington Southampton Newton and
plastow um I wasn't planning to testify
but after some of the things I heard I
had to step up here I sit on the Science
Tech and energy committee um so we deal
with those electric costs that uh keep
this building warm and uh those those
lights on
um and it is true as as rep Moffett said
that uh it is natural gas which is the
primary fuel that's uh providing uh all
the all the additional power beyond
which comes from uh that which comes
from seabook or from Hydro that we have
on the Connecticut
River uh and because New York and
Massachusetts have uh created pipeline
bands um we have to get uh the remainder
of our natural gas by
ship uh so the comments from some of the
previous speakers that oil fuel oil and
gas come from Canada very well two3
two-thirds of it very well may be true
that's not the relevant issue the
relevant issue is where do we get our
natural gas that keeps the electricity
on and the natural gas because of the
pipeline constraints and because in the
winter time uh
home heating gets
priority the the uh power companies are
last in line for what's in that pipeline
we have to get that peaking gas uh from
uh from Ships coming in and where are
they coming from Trinidad and Tobago
bringing Venezuelan oil oil Russia or
Iran those are the three highest uh
company or areas is where we get our oil
Mo our natural gas most of it's coming
from Trinidad and
Tobago it would be much better if we
didn't have the Jones act if we could
get natural gas from Texas and Louisiana
but we can't do that it has to go to
some foreign Port first and as rep mafa
said most likely it ends up in Europe
and then gets trans shipped back
here so uh you all experienced a
tremendous spike in electric rates uh in
July of
22 all because of uh what what had G on
with the administration shutting down
pipeline gas as well as the the war in
Ukraine the price of natural gas uh
being L having to be liquefied to be
carried on a ship which adds to the
expense as opposed to be in a pipeline
where it isn't liquid doesn't need that
uh that extra cost um went from $10 to
$72 uh a u mil million BT BTUs um in
Europe and we ended up then picking up
that Freight New
England area suffers because of the lack
of pipeline access to natural gas we
have to get it by ship and the Jones Act
is a real detriment in in that whole
process we need to uh move to to make
natural gas availability uh much greater
than it currently
is will you take any
questions if I can yes do we have any
representative okay down to to our last
please thank you Mr chair thank you
again members of the committee uh as it
happens and I had no inkling of this
bill whatsoever as it happens I am a
coast guard license 50 gross ton master
myself and um I am not taking a position
on this bill again didn't even know this
bill existed here for other things but I
am doing a favor for my brethren in the
room and answering a couple questions
that went
unanswered um the first is regarding the
Maui fires and I have a captain friend
who works out of lahina in Maui um who I
visited a couple of times uh towing
companies brought food water baby
formula generators and fuel from other
Islands to Maui on Jones act vessels uh
the other thing that went unanswered is
that the Virg uh the Virgin Islands are
exempt from the Jones act and there you
go that's all I got
thank you representative any question
vastly outranked in this question I
would take questions if but I wouldn't
be able to answer them probably do we
have any questions seeing none thank you
forgot
okay in just about a minute or so we
will uh we have two more measures this
morning they related to Article 5 uh in
hearing
okay
hcr8 house con resolution 8 applying to
Congress for a limited national
Convention for the exclusive purpose of
proposing an amendment to the United
States Constitution relative to
elections Prime sponsor is here I've
seen her uh just a few moments ago
representative Reed welcome back thank
you Mr chair and thank you again uh
members of the committee uh at risk of
making you sick of my face today um so I
not to begin my testimony in a kind of
uh bombastic way but uh the United
States has frequently been called the
great experiment and the reason that is
is because at the time that we broke
away from England through violence it's
worth noting um self-governance was
something that had only been done in the
distant past and had failed so starting
a whole new experiment on
self-governance was a pretty radical
idea at the time and something we
believed passionately in because we had
suffered um through a lack of
representation and we were willing at
after decades and Decades of that to
experiment so democracy I need to Define
this because sometimes you hear people
saying we're not a democracy we're a
republic which is a little bit like
saying that's not a dog it's a German
Shepherd um a republic is a
representative democracy as opposed to a
direct democracy so democracy is ruled
by the people in other words that
self-governance that our Founders were
striving for um and I have to tell you
and you may have already heard because
this study is 10 years old but it has
been studied in depth as to what level
we are a democracy as our Founders
wanted us to be and it has been
determined that we are actually
not functionally not a democracy anymore
um there was a famous study over 20
years by Northwestern and Princeton um
in 2014 that studied 1,800 pieces of
legislation on the Congressional level
the federal level um and they
measured according to what entity wanted
a bill to pass or a measure to pass
either um moneyed special interests
corporations or average citizens and
while there was a direct correlation
between the will of wealthy special
interests and corporations on whether or
not a bill passed it was determined and
this is a direct quote that the major
the majoritarian electorate had quote
only a minuscule near zero statistically
nonsignificant impact upon public policy
the people are not governing we're not
in charge of our
government and this actually doesn't
surprise most people it may surprise
people to say that we're not a democracy
but it it doesn't really the the effect
when you say that we don't impact public
policy even though we are the great
experiment of democracy in the world
people aren't surprised because the
people regardless of of party leaning
have a deep knowledge over decades
now that their government does not
respond to
them and this is left or right and I you
know it risk of you know naming parties
from the far right magot people to the
farle Bernie people Everyone agrees that
the government's not representing us you
may have heard of the term income
disparity but there's something else
called representational disparity and it
turns out if you're not one of the
Buddies of the powerful if you're not in
the very wealthy extremely wealthy
billionaire class you're really not
getting represented
and this has led to increasing levels of
civil unrest again both sides it doesn't
matter what you believe the solution is
on a policy level everyone agrees that
we aren't being represented and while
the government is not responding to us
right or left policies they are
responding to their wealthy lobbyists
they are responding to their campaign
donors they are responding to the
billionaires that run the super Pacs
that determine elections we all know
know
this so now Article 5 the Constitution
the framers of the Constitution and
their great wisdom gave us a couple ways
to amend the
Constitution the first is the one that's
we've only ever done successfully which
is
congressionally um New Hampshire in 2019
because of my bill uh became the 20th
State to call for Congressional
constitutional amendment to address this
issue the issue of money and
politics so we're out of options as a
state at this point we've done
everything we can do to influence
Congress to reform itself but the
framers knew that power corrupts the
framers knew that we can't trust
Congress to reform itself we can't trust
people in power to reform themselves in
general as a principle and so they gave
the states the ability to also call for
a Constitutional Amendment which you are
of so that's the last thing that we have
to do except for one and I'll get to
that but the arguments you frequently
hear against an article five which
you've heard many many times in this
committee The Runaway
convention well as you know it requires
a super majority of states to call for a
convention it requires a super majority
of states to ratify a constitutional
amendment that comes out of a convention
there's also the question of how can a
convention be controlled when
conventions set their own rules the
rules aren't given to us in the
Constitution um and that's why we have
delegate instruction bills and if the
majority of States followed the lead of
this committee last year in passing
delegate instruction bills there would
be no argument about a runaway
convention and so I find it really odd
that the same people who
will I'll say fearmonger around the idea
of a runaway convention are the same
people who oppose delicate instruction
threat there's also the Strategic
element because it's not just we will
take control away from Congress and do
the amendment ourselves but also we have
the power through calling for a
convention to force congress's hand to
act and that is how in fact we got the
17th Amendment which is the direct
election of senators it was also
influential in getting the Bill of
Rights and
finally the reason that this really
needs to happen when we talk about okay
this is scary we haven't done this
before we've never actually had uh an
amendment convention before why should
we do
this and it goes back to the civil
unrest that that we're experiencing in
increasing amounts because everyone
across the board knows that this
government isn't functioning the way it
was designed
anyway and the thing is is I look at it
like a sick patient we've tried all the
conventional medicines when you have a
sick patient you try the Tylenol or the
antibiotics or whatever you throw
whatever you have that's normal and
standard and safe and then if the
patient isn't responding and it looks
like the patient's getting worse and
potentially dying well it's time to
maybe try something a little bit more
experimental now there is an even more
dangerous medication and that's actually
provided for well in general but
specifically in the New Hampshire
Constitution Article 10 the right of
Revolution which is based on our
movement to become a nation to begin
with and I know you've all heard it
before but I'm going to read it
government being instituted for the
common benefit protection and security
of the whole community and not for the
private interest or ment that's
profit of any one man family or class of
men therefore whenever the ends of
government are perverted which we know
that they are now and the public Liberty
manifestly endangered and all other
means of redress are ineffectual this is
the last means of
redress the people may and of right
ought to reform the old or establish a
new government the doctrine of
non-resistance against arbit power and
oppression is absurd slavish and
destructive of the good and happiness of
mankind and the thing is that in order
to prevent that medicine this is the
last option we have whether it's to
force congress's hand to act would they
actually reform themselves I don't know
or we go ahead and hold a convention and
have those delegate instruction bills
but either way we're at that point when
we see civil unrest
increase um I have experts in the room
multiple experts in the room uh
recognized National experts on Article 5
conventions including experts who helped
this committee pass the delegate
instruction Bill last year so um I am
happy to answer questions but I might
defer to better Minds than
mine thank you representative for that
excellent uh presentation of your your
measure your
resolution ACR uh questions for the
prime
sponsor sweet seeing none I do have 10
cards here there's a lot of interest in
this um seven are in favor three are
opposed um I would and we're very glad
you're here especially on this cold day
and uh your testimony is being recorded
uh probably will be out there forever on
YouTube immortalized so to speak but I
would ask uh especially if if there are
seven people in support of the bill um
to try to give the committee new
information um so that we can keep
moving and uh and you don't need to
repeat uh unless you really need to uh
material has already been said all right
uh my next card here is uh JD Bernardi
representative Bernardi I recognize the
representative
thank you Mr chair and and committee
again JD Bernardi Rockingham 36 um so
just a little bit of of a
history in the initial
uh preparation of the Constitution James
Madison's Virginia Plan was the was the
language that was initially discussed
for how
uh the uh Constitution could be amended
which was Congress proposes and States
ratify Colonel George Mason made the
point and he's the author of the
Virginia Declaration of Rights that
Congress can abuse its power and refuse
to consent to amendments therefore we
needed to have the States involved so
Governor
Morris of of Pennsylvania and elge Jerry
of Massachusetts created a resolution or
an an amendment to that process that
proposed that any amendment can also be
offered by 2third of the states and then
James Wilson of Pennsylvania said uh or
added that it need should be ratified
not by the states but by three quarters
of the
states clearing up what kind of majority
might be
necessary when that amendment was
finally
uh created it passed
unanimously without any debate it's one
of the few issues in the Constitutional
Convention that the notes indicate that
this process was 100% accepted by the
delegates I think that's very important
to
consider secondly I'd like to add that I
had the uh wonderful opportunity along
with represent pres of mamea to
participate in a uh uh simulated
convention last year Convention of
states where we looked at three
different areas of potential amendments
that's term limits or for uh Congress as
well as uh members serving in in the uh
executive staff uh fiscal restraints
largely generally called the Balan
budget amendment uh idea and then
legislative and executive power
limitations so we divided into three
committees or three groups and we worked
on our amendments that we thought might
be appropriate in those
areas we didn't run away we didn't go
off scope we stayed on target we
presented a group of amendments that
were focused on the specific area that
we were tasked to deal with and
presented those to the uh to the
Congress as a whole and that group was
composed of people just like you and me
and representative mamila these were
representatives from the various States
that's exactly how a convention Article
5 convention would operate and work and
and to believe that it's going to be
some craz runaway event and and we're
going to throw out the Constitution
we're going to decide that we're we're
going to uh uh eliminate the Second
Amendment and whatnot is that is not the
kind of activity that was ever discussed
or ever even considered we stayed
entirely focused on the issues that were
in front of us now this bill asks us to
look at or this resolution asks us to
look at free and fair elections so some
of the major items that that the public
is concerned with are are issues like
voter IDE
should we have absentee ballots what are
the constraints on that should we have
voter
harvesting there it would be useful in
the United States to get some consensus
on this and drive to the ability to have
free and fair elections or elections
that our public believes are freeer and
fair so I support the process I support
this uh this resolution and willing to
take any
questions thank you representative
Bernardi seeing none thank you so much
for that uh
testimony uh another representative who
is here who opposes the bill is
representative Granger welcome
back thank you uh thanks for having me
back so I was planning to come here in
favor of uh hcr9 but I didn't know there
were two uh Article 5 convention bills
here today um I'll so I'll try to keep
it brief so I don't have to restate the
same thing twice in two different pieces
of
testimony the idea that there are
Article 5 convention experts is simply
false there is no such thing as an
article 5 convention expert because
there has never been an article 5
convention
what the Constitution says about Article
5 conventions is about amendments in
general and it says the Congress
whenever two-thirds of both houses shall
deem it necessary shall propose
amendments to this Constitution that
doesn't have to do with a con a
Convention of states or a constitutional
convention or on the application of the
legislatures of 2third of the several
States okay that's probably that's what
we're actually talking about so there's
a sentence about what we're talking
about shall call a convention for
proposing amendments which either case
shall be valid to all intents and
purposes as part of this constitution
when ratified by the legislatur of three
fours of the several States or by
conventions of three fours thereof okay
that does not tell you how the delegates
are selected that does not tell you what
their goals are and it doesn't tell you
how the actual process will work um
other parts of the Constitution sort of
take effect there Congress determines
how the delegates are elected they could
have special elections and every state
to select the delegates to this
Constitutional Convention they could
decide that the ranking Senator is the
Delegate for the constitutional
convention uh they could just say the
Speaker of the House of every state
house is the is the delegate they could
do whatever they want their Congress and
their job at this point is to facilitate
getting the Constitutional Convention
underway you may have heard this called
the convention of states and supporters
of the of uh con of Article 5
conventions will generally call it a
Convention of states it is not a
Convention of states the states have
zero ability to control what happens at
these conventions and the reason they
don't have any ability to control what
happens at these conventions is because
the authority of the delegates does not
come from the legislature the authority
of the delegates comes directly from the
people so what does that mean exactly so
this country was not founded by the
Constitution it existed before the
current US Constitution it was the
Declaration of Independence said what
this country feels is the right way
where government actually comes from we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the proce of
happiness you all learned that in school
that to secure these rights governments
are instituted among men deriving their
just powers from the consent of the
governor governed that whenever any form
of government becomes destructive to the
ends it's the right of the people the
people not the legislators to alter or
to abolish it and Institute a new
government okay so what does that mean
that means that the constitution we
currently have now is authorized by the
people all right and that and the
historical precedent for this is the
Articles of Confederation being replaced
by the Constitution so when this current
constitution was put into place it had
to go to the various States for
ratification all right and the
justification that and at the time Rhode
Island did not attend the convention
here's some information about the
Articles of Confederation you might find
interesting the Articles of
Confederation was much more more strict
on amendments than the current
constitution is in order to amend the
Articles of Confederation back when
there were 13 members you needed to have
a unanimous approval of all the states
all 13 states needed to be on board to
make amendments or to alter or abolish
the existing Constitution which was the
Articles of the Confederation Rhode
Island boycotted the Constitutional
Convention it was impossible for them to
have any unanimity unanimity on that so
what they did instead was they defined a
new ratification
process and that's what would happen if
we have another article 5 today the new
ratification process was defined in the
Constitution and they just needed three4
or 2/3 one of those they needed a
certain number it wasn't unanimous New
Hampshire was the last of the 13
colonies that triggered the ratification
um the old ratification process was
ignored entirely uh because it didn't
matter what does that mean well that
means that in our nation it is
precedented for a constitutional
convention to have the new constitution
Define the ratification process so this
means that if you come if they come out
with some new Constitution which is well
within their rights that ratification
process defined in the new constitution
takes precedent all right so they can
send that out to the states and they
could say well let's just have special
elections in every state and if 50 plus
one of the people decide to ratify the
Constitution then it's valid all right
so any claims that a certain number of
states need to ratify this Con stion not
not supported by history because uh
interesting T tidbit my district uh
which was at the time northern Rochester
um uh which is still northern Rochester
is in my district but Milton didn't
exist as a town back then uh they voted
against the new constitution now they on
their own are not capable of you know if
they were the only ones they wouldn't be
able to say nope Constitution doesn't
apply it would need to be the states the
state would have to uh a single state
would need to not ratify the
Constitution under the old scheme but uh
that's just interesting that uh they
didn't like it so the other claim is one
of the other popular claims is that I
have it written
[Music]
here all right so states can put in
legislation that limits what delegates
can do this is not possible at all
because the delegates outrank the
legislator because the delegates derive
their just power from the people the
legislator derive their power from the
Constitution so what does that mean that
means let's say we make a rule saying
you can only make this amendment this
amendment this amendment you are not
allowed to stray outside those
boundaries well they can just ignore
that you might as well have a peasant
telling a king a sovereign that they are
not allowed to do whatever they want the
king is not is is not something that is
going to listen to something that a
peasant says and we are as legislators
are mere peasants compared to a delegate
a delegate has Supreme Sovereign
authority to write what whatever they
want all right so the Constitution we
currently have just to make this point
clear in case there's any confusion the
Constitution that we currently have
authorizes legislator all right the
legislator get their power from the
Constitution all right the either the
state legislature or the federal
legislature all right we are bound by
that Constitution to follow certain
rules the delegates do not get their
just powers from the Constitution that
means that the Supreme court has no
bearing whatsoever on their actions
there is no way to limit their actions
at convention they could simply put in
the new constitution delegates cannot be
held responsible for the things they do
in convention and then bam whatever new
Supreme Court they come up with um
whether it's the uh modification of the
current Supreme Court or whatever else
the case may be uh suddenly is now uh
Banning States from enforcing their
actions there's basically no way you can
control the me convention the purpose of
article Article 5 uh or at least when it
comes to Article 5 conventions is to
allow us to totally abolish the
Constitution if such a need arises that
is the function and if you doubt this
then where in the current then you
should ask yourself where in the current
constitution does it allow the people to
totally abolish their form of government
because the founders knew that it was
very important that people the people
would be allowed to abolish their
government and Institute a new one they
put in an a mechanism to allow us to do
that because well they were
revolutionary sorts all right Article 5
is how they actually go about abolishing
the current Constitution and to assume
that we have any level of control it do
and to drive this point home it could be
anything it could be any bill you want I
dis you maybe you disagree with me on
this I really don't like the 16th
Amendment it authorizes an income tax if
there was a bill to or a house
resolution to authorize an Article 5
convention to get rid of the income tax
I would have to say no to that extremely
juicy
carrot anybody who knows me knows how
much I hate income taxes so it it
doesn't matter how good the juice is it
doesn't matter because the point isn't
to get that actual policy passed a lot
of times the policy is simply to get an
article 5 convention maybe we just
shouldn't get rid of the Constitution
maybe we should just keep it as is it is
the oldest document that oldest
constitution that's still around we
should probably keep it that way thank
you I am available for
questions are there any
questions at this time seeing none at
this time thank you represent
Granger representative finny is right
Bill thank you I was just joking with my
friend um for the record I'm Brandon fny
straford n which is uh
uh uh Rochester Ward 6 uh I am a
co-sponsor on this bill I've been before
uh our committee before um in favor of
an article 5 convention I want to point
out a couple things the language of the
bill I could direct your attention to
lines 23 through 28 the state of New
Hampshire uh desires that the delegates
to said convention shall be comprised
equally of individuals currently
currently elected a state and uh uh uh
local office or be selected by election
in each Congressional
uh
uh yes thank you for the purpose of
serving as a delegate though all
individuals elected or appointed to
federal office now or in the past be
prohibited from serving as a as a um a
delegate to the convention and intends
to retain the ability to restrict or
expand the power of delegates within uh
the limits expressed so
basically what we're talking about is is
a specific topic for Article 5
convention it's not to rewrite the
Constitution it's not to create uh a new
power structure in America it's simply
to to limit the scope of the convention
to the issue of our elections in this
country I want to point out a few things
to
you um unless you live under Iraq which
we don't because we're all serving in
the government we know that voters are
losing faith in the system
it doesn't make sense to me that we
don't do anything except continue to
complain about the problems in the
system we keep electing the same wrong
people to office who use their office
for um personal gain and increasingly
the political class in America is
turning into a plutocracy where we have
a separate elitist group of people who
decides what happens to the rest of the
country to the you know to the uh uh uh
the detriment of the rest of the states
and the people who elected people um to
to Congress we have a duty to protect
the Electoral Integrity not just in New
Hampshire but you know for the entire
country if we continue to allow
corporations and special interest groups
to retain power in America and have a
say over our public policy then uh we
don't have any power to protect anybody
you know we're we're simply just a stop
Gap in between um the increases in power
that we see in our federal
we're we're seeing more of a partisan
divide which is based on electoral
Monopoly I've only having a two-party
system that we we you know simply just
need to admit is not going to continue
to work for the future we're almost $40
trillion in debt is an unfathomable it's
an unfathomable amount of money that we
will never be able to pay off and as
long as that keeps increasing our
economy is going to fail we have to stop
electing people that continuously spend
our money with no regard for you know
for the future the reason I co-sponsored
this uh convention bill was that we have
too much influence of bad powerful money
in the um in the electoral process and
the only way to change that is to Force
congress's Hand by saying as a state we
no longer going to put up with this crap
we want to we want to do something about
it here's what we
propose um it's not to weapon
the the the convention against any other
partisan group it's not it's not to to
re you know to abolish or or to uh
create a new you know a new government
that is simply going to continue to do
the same things that's happening now
we're specifically talking
about uh the electoral process in
itself um I I've heard I've heard things
about if we were to allow a convention
to go through that they would change the
Second Amendment we would no longer have
our rights to you know to um to defend
ourselves or our property or our family
and friends which isn't true because
these uh this HCR and and other Article
5 um uh things that we've had in the
past are are are limited in scope
specifically to certain um issues so
we're only talking about an exclusive
topic um the point of a convention is to
propose uh reforms to force the federal
government to acques to the states based
on our 10th Amendment right which is the
the the foundation of why I personally
continue to sponsor Article 5 convention
bills because I believe in that power of
the 10th Amendment for us as a as a
sovereign state to say you know Congress
is not do you know doing their job uh
they keep spending our money you know
putting us in foreign conflicts without
um you know Congress uh saying that we
can you know uh legally excuse me
and uh we're we're not going to put up
with them sucking anymore so uh I guess
with that I will take any questions if
you have
questions and saying none uh I thank you
again and for allowing me to
speak we will move on uh Ken Quinn is in
the house Ken has been here before uh
want to welcome Ken back he's uh
indicated he submitted written
testimony uh in favor of the Bill of
course we remember Ken um it doesn't say
how long Ken needs to speak so I just
would um I just would say uh please
don't um feel a need to reate what's in
the written testimony because we do want
to get to the other folks here as well
uh so uh Mr Quinn welcome back thank you
chairman muffett Vice shair Rollins
committee members I will try not to take
much of your time today um I come from
Maine I'm with the US ter limits and I I
I bring some good news um on Friday we
had a article 5 resolution actually a
resolution passed the um veterans and
legal Affairs committee it's a unique
resolution it's an article 5 application
for congressional terms as well as a
separate Article 5 application for this
subject matter right here today and it
passed bipartisan supports it had eight
sponsors on the resolution four
Democrats four Republicans and it passed
pass the committee by an 8 to5 vote for
Republicans for Democrats so that is
nice to see people coming together to
try to solve some of these major
problems in our country and um I know I
don't tout myself as a expert I think I
know Article 5 fairly well um I do have
a document here from a true expert
Michael Ferris and um the information I
heard from the previous speaker and
against as you probably saw he didn't
offer one shred of evidence because
everything that he said against the
Article 5 convention he cannot back up
with any facts um what I will provide to
you in a
document is virtually every that has
been stated against an article 5
convention is the actual original Source
documents from the
framers refuting the Char charge that
they have no control over the
legislature in fact I have a document
from the main State Legislature
1861 it's a
commission it's the commission to send
delegates to the Washington peace
conference which was a true and official
Convention of the States called by the
state of
Virginia to address the issue of slavery
to propose amendments to the US
Constitution in that commission it
states that the Commissioners are under
control at all times by the state
legislature all times the state
legislators control their delegates or
their Commissioners in fact in 2020 the
US Supreme Court had a UNAM decision in
the shfo versus Washington case where
the state legislators control the
Electoral delegates to electoral
college that they are bound by their
pledge that pledge and that decision
obviously applies to any commissioner
appointed by the state legislatures so
this idea that they do not represent you
is completely unfounded it's not based
upon our history it's not a based upon
laws and it's not a based upon our
overwhelming precedent and of
conventions in the past in fact this
year right now your legislature your
Senate just passed a bill
um I have the number I I'm not going to
pull it up uh this year it was this bill
has to do with real estate law it came
from a an official Convention of the
States known as the uniform law
commission so you are already using this
process I know you've heard me say this
in the past but you're actually using
the process now that convention meets
once a
year the states in New Hampshire your
Governor appoints the Commissioners but
most of the states are appointed by the
state
legislatures it's a limited convention
on prub subjects um subjects that they
determine ahead of time it's one state
one vote just like an article 5
convention and then whatever they pass
if those Commissioners want to bring it
back to the state to adopt a state law
they find a sponsor like you did here in
the Senate so with that I am going to
leave all of the factual information
behind so you can read for yourself from
the framers about this process refuting
that the 1787 Convention was a runaway
that's complete nonsense let's not
dishonor our framers and let's not
listen to The Fear let's have faith and
not fear and I want to uh appreciate
your time and I'll take any questions
you thanks so much Mr
questions represent cber yeah um um so
it seems like I I guess my question is
why
not you know be more straightforward
instead of being kind of broad about
election processes why don't why
wouldn't we just you know ask for an
article 5 convention regarding ending
jury mandering or or to end jury
mandering and be like direct and
straightforward and P that and the
number of states that needs to be passed
and then you already have like that
closed subject matter that would be you
know that people would really stand
behind uh yes well I I believe that was
point state did include Jerry anding as
well as
money um as you know this process and I
can't see you um it's hard enough to get
states to agree on one subject let alone
more than one and so that's why this is
a this process is limited the framer's
intent was an article 5 convention was
for a single Amendment if you read
federals 85 uh Alexander Hamilton
specifically says that that it's if
2third of the states are united in a
particular Amendment that's the then
they need to apply for it and then three
quarters could ratify that particular
Amendment so that's why these
applications are limited and that's why
you introduce too many subject matter it
becomes very difficult for a legislature
to agree upon that thanks
other questions representative finny
repes representative finny you're a
co-sponsor
correct uh our tradition is to uh have
co-sponsors refrain from
engaging especially after having already
testified uh other
questions thank you Mr quinnn okay next
year uh we still have quite a few cards
to go through here so we'll uh ask folks
to be uh efficient and expeditious as we
move forward uh Al
brandano has been here before welcome
brandano may
I proceed yeah yes pass those uh right
my name is uh Al brandano I'm from
Kensington New Hampshire and I'm
representing myself today uh we heard
something earlier that there are no
experts in the room and I agree with
that so let me read from an expert this
is George Washington's Farewell Address
the bottom part
the basis of political systems is the
right of people to make and to alter
their constitutions their constitutions
of government but that the Constitution
which at at any any time exists till
Changed by an explicit and authentic Act
of the whole
people is sacredly obligatory upon all
the very idea of the power and the right
of the people to establish government
pre supposes the duty of every
individual to obey the established
government I think it's safe to say that
what we've learned about Article 5 uh
Colonel Mason before they signed the
Constitution 10 years after the
Declaration of
Independence they basically said they
knew that the federal government would
run away and they needed to put some God
reils up and what were those God reils
it's the only amendment
uh to the that they had brought forth
that they voted unanimously on Article 5
uh what I what I gave to you is an an
example of how hard the process is the
founding fathers did this for reason
they didn't want people amending the
Constitution without a very difficult
and very high bar the document in front
of you shows and outlines what the
Congress has to do compared to what the
people have to do and if you look at it
it's twice as hard right more difficult
um so with that I'm not going to go into
how many states as you well know the key
part of the this this uh Amendment uh
the Article 5 movement is the Congress
when 23ds of both houses shall deem it
necessary necessary shall propose
amendments and this is the key word to
this constitution it doesn't talk about
throwing the Constitution away or adding
a new constitution it's very specific if
we just read the words and I'm not going
to read the entire thing to you but one
of the most amazing parts for me in
studying this at length is you know you
need in this case 34 states 34s to start
2/3 rather 34 states 34 states call for
a a Convention of an article five they
meet they come together they propose
amendments that's it it's they don't
change the Constitution just propose it
then then they send it out to the state
legislator houses and senates so think
about it every there's about uh there's
one house I think Nebraska only has one
chamber so 99 state legislators have a
chance to take a look at this evaluate
it and then at the very end 38 states
have to vote to adopt it's pretty
amazing bar this fear that we're all
talking about my God if we believe that
38 States want to do something then by
God we should do it because we're not
doing it
now and let's be honest the federal
government is really run away right it's
run away from the people um I think
Article Five is to break the glass in
case of emergency that's where we're at
right now 34 trillion in debt that's 332
million is
$102,000 per person we are in debt uh if
you laid dollar bills from end to end it
would go around the earth 118,000 times
we're in trouble uh additionally
specifically related to this bill over
80% of the incumbents are reelected and
that data is from 1964 to 2020 and the
source of that is open Secrets in
closing from 1789 to 2019 the house and
the Senate have proposed
11,484 amendments to the Constitution
only 27 have passed so why fear the
state
if 38 States and 76 state legislatures
that are the closest to the people see
that the country is in trouble and want
to amend and we the people do not use
the peaceful enumerated powers these are
enumerated powers that we're talking
about that were given to us that are
ours under Article 5 Powers as a way to
address this then we'll simply just lose
the
Republic any
question thank you Mr br
questions uh yes I was to fill you up
thank you for your thoughtful testimony
we've heard a lot today about what an
article 5 convention could or could not
do or what various experts have said on
it what has the Supreme Court alined on
an article 5 convention what a
convention could or could not do um
there is no the Supreme Court I I'm not
an expert on the Supreme Court but I can
tell you about New Hampshire I can tell
you about New
Hampshire um in 2015 the house and the
Senate came together and passed a bill I
think it HP 146 which identified the
responsibilities of faithful delegates
or Commissioners we did that we passed
it and it ended up going to Maggie
hasson's desk and it wasn't signed and
it couldn't be overridden because it
didn't have enough votes since then we
have had five attempts uh and last last
year
hc4 was fateful delegate so for for you
your legislators to be able to put uh
guide rails or or direction to our
commissioners are faithful delegates but
unfortunately it hasn't passed here so I
think the strongest thing you could do
is uh I support this uh this bill and if
you believe like I do that if you need
to give people more Direction then do it
by legislation through through the um
Commissioners or fateful delegate and
allow this to to move forward because it
really does need we're in trouble I mean
every day you turn on the news it you
don't have to go very far I and I hope I
answered your question in a roundout way
thank you I think we're all dealing with
questions that we don't know necessarily
the answers to because it's Uncharted
Territory
yes other
questions seeing none thank you Mr
brandano thank you okay moving right
along uh Elizabeth from Nash Elizabeth
perhaps j e l i c did I get that
correct yes thank you okay
welcome Elizabeth is uh in support of
the
Bill thank you chairman uh members of
the committee for taking the time to
hear my testimony my name is Beth jelik
I'm a resident of NASA and I'm here
today in support of
hcr8 relative to Constitutional
Convention procedures for
delegates I'm a new volunteer with a
group called Wolfpack who shares my goal
of an Amendment to the US Constitution
to address corruption in our elections
and
governance if not for the Privileges I
had in my life good education that
guaranteed work that funds my retirement
I might be homeless or dead I'm neurod
Divergent but I had support from my
family and have been
spared the problems that others see
that don't have the the financial
support that I
had when I struggled in school my mother
was there to help
me but there are too many families now
that are two income families that have
to be two income
families they don't have the resources
to take the time off from work to spend
the time with their children that need
help
I am fortunate that my income and
medical coverage allows me to access to
the mental health care I need but those
who do not have the Privileges I enjoyed
the support that I received continue to
be left in the cold because they cannot
afford the cost of mental health care
whether due to medication prices or
covered
conditions corporate money going to
politicians leads these politicians to
voting against letting Medicare and
Medicaid negotiate for lower costs
voting against increasing the minimum
wage and Paid Family Leave against
single-payer Health Care all these
things that make make it difficult for
lower income families to afford the
medical services they
need in holding a constitutional
convention with a specific goal and
guidelines to limit the topics addressed
we can define a change that ensures our
Senators and representatives are working
for the people instead of for
corporations again I thank you for your
time and service to our
community and thank you for coming up
here from Nash would you take questions
questions and seeing that I thank you
again for taking the time and we will
move next to uh gentleman opposed to the
bill uh Hal schliff has been here before
is he is he he is still in the house I
saw early this morning welcome back Mr
Sheriff not to be confused with another
famous shirtliff yes thank you for the
opportunity to testify and uh yes we're
I think we're third cousins uh steveen
sherff here and we um yes so I'm a uh uh
US Army veteran uh member of the S
sunsay American Revolution like my uh my
cousin here and uh lived up here since
uh
2020 and I come before you of course to
oppose um or itl HCR um
hcr8 um it sounds very lofty free and
fair elections I think anybody any
reasonable person wants such free and
fair elections but generally I believe
this amendment may give more power to
the federal
government over
elections I am in sympathy with many
people Advocate an arle convention I
have a number of friends who are support
one I've have conven some of them to
change the position and some I have not
uh but I don't think adding amendments
to the Constitution will solve our
nation's problems I think we have a
pretty good Constitution as it is and
the problem is that it's largely ignored
at the federal level um and by by the
way both parties are involved not just
both major parties uh these are some of
the reasons why I oppose an article 5
convention it cannot be limited to one
Amendment or topic regardless of what
people may say because Article 5 doesn't
specify that you get you go to you go to
the Constitution and this is the powers
and the duties and it doesn't say one
Amendment or a topic it says
amendments um there are no laws or rules
concerning an article 5 convention a few
states have passed waywood delegate or
faithful delegate laws which actually
indicates that maybe some of them will
not be faithful to the instructions that
they might be given given at by the
state
legislatures um I think New Hampshire
has a bill that seeks to do the same it
is the job of Congress to make the rules
under Article 1 Section 8 the last
Clause is necessary and proper clause
and for proof of that I'm not going to
read this but this was uh 1979 there was
several bills that went to the Senate
Judiciary Committee uh concerning the
rules of laws of an article 5 nothing
was passed I have this in a PDF version
if you like I can send it to you just
just to say yes Congress does believe
although it hasn't passed any that it
does control an article 5
convention um we have no idea who the
delegates will be this resolution by the
way actually lists several ways that the
delegates will be chosen and then also
those that will be restricted but that
to me is null and void because it does
not have the power the states do not
have that power it's not in article
5 um state legislators may not have an
opportunity to vote on any proposed
amendments now we just heard one of the
gentlemen well-intentioned he said that
uh it has to go to the three four three4
of the state legislator but Congress has
another mode which is in Article 5 they
seem to fail to mention it's called
ratifying conventions so Congress can
say here are the amendments who are
going to choose a ratifying convention
so you won't have you may never get a
chance to to vote on any amendments
proposed at a convention and the
precedent is um the 18th amendment that
was concerning the prohibition that was
a ratifying convention it didn't go to
the legis
legislates
um uh will the vote at a convention be
one state or one state one vote or
baseed on electoral representation we
don't know that and nobody can say that
they that will be one state one vote so
New Hampshire will have four votes Cali
has something like 50
votes um New Hampshire voters rejected a
State Convention by a wide margin 66% in
the last election while State
constitutional conventions are different
from an article 5 convention it does
indicate a basic distrust of conventions
that concern a constitution since 2016
eight states have rescinded all of their
applications and I have I won't go I
just save the time I won't mention it
interesting in the resolution HCR um
hcr8 it says that New Jersey and
Illinois passed this resolution but it
also has since resend rescinded that
resolution now um I don't accept the
concept of a runaway convention because
that presupposes one can be limited to a
certain
topic but I was at an event at Harvey
University in 2011 it was called um the
uh uh conference on the Constitutional
Convention it was co-chaired by Mark
mecka who ended ended up co-founding
Convention of states and Larry leik a
Harvard law professor a gentleman by the
name of Chen yuger at the time I didn't
know who he was he was interviewing
Larry lesk outside of the uh and I got
it on video and I have a link there on
my testimony they were hoping for a
runaway they were laughing about it
hahaa we should have one it would be
great so the founder of of Wolfpack who
was the me this organization's pushing
this notes that there can be a runaway
there maybe there can be but again I
don't accept the concept of runaway
because that presupposes that one can be
limited so uh I want again thank you
that's all that's all I have I thank you
for your uh listening any questions I
answer thank thank you so much
questions thank you see uh before I go
to the next speaker um the the I made a
note to myself when you mentioned
ratifying convention I want to get a
little bit more informed on that so
before we exec this in a week or two um
maybe the
the the prime uh we don't have time no
you go ahead you can stand down I'm just
making I'm picking up on your comment
about a ratifying convention which um I
know I perhaps some of the other members
w't understand better by the time we EXA
this um Haley Shaw from Allenstown
supports the bill is
Haley here looks like that must be Haley
minutes hi everyone I'm Haley Shaw from
Allenstown New Hampshire uh and I
represent Convention of States um I'm
going to keep this really brief because
everybody has said a lot of the same
things that I want to say but um we
shouldn't be afraid of having an article
5 convention it's simply a conversation
amongst states and and to say that
states are going to have you know go
crazy or go Rogue just simply having a
conversation really just says that
people like yourselves are going to go
to a convention and and bring in chaos
which I just simply don't believe that
is true and this is the checkin balance
for the people through you to have you
know on the states to have on the
federal government and to simply not use
that uh that's not really utilizing the
Constitution to the full list so I
believe that you should start to see
more of these applications because we
should have more conventions among
states to have conversations for simple
subject of you know single subjects
conversations simply because the federal
government is not listening and not
taking into account what the states and
the people want so I think everybody
should get used to having a convention
and we should see more conventions and
so I think just simply making it more
common uh makes us less afraid and it's
going to take one to start this process
and let's stop being afraid of what it
could be and actually call one and see
what it's going to be and I think you
should have a lot more faith in
yourselves and faith in other members
like you in from other states to call
these conventions and that's simply just
all I'm going to say
thanks questions for
Haley question for the chair uh yes uh
representative uh thank you Mr chairman
uh you mentioned about getting more
information about what a ratifying
convention is I think that's an
excellent idea we going to go through
our committee researcher or office of
legislative services to get that sure
the question if you didn't hear was was
from representative shlif I raised a
point about uh understanding ratifying
convention concept better uh yeah I
think our researcher certainly could
help with that and I was going to invite
the prime sponsor as well to respond to
uh the
ratifying convention issue you decided
to mention I the prime earlier that's
why I raised this question with all due
respect to the prime sponsors and those
that have SP spoken support of this uh
uh piece of legislation I think it would
be better for us to get it from uh House
services just so we know that uh it's
from a disinterested third party that
information e excellent point uh if you
didn't hear that uh in getting
clarification on anything uh we have yes
to to go to neutral sources to to find
that information that's not to say
anyone certainly can can amplify uh to
any of us any anything that came up uh
to help us to understand anything better
thank you thank you for that um Matthew
rhods opposes the bill uh Matthew
welcome you were here early today asked
for 3 minutes Matthew came all the way
Maine hi everybody how you doing um can
you hear me great okay thank you I just
want to warn the committee that I'm a
little hard of hearing so if you ask me
a question I might not hear you so you
just have to shout it out really loud so
anyway I'm here to oppose HDR 8 because
um I believe that the convention of
State Lobby is uh is a very misleading
Lobby uh they tend to pre on people's uh
heartstrings with things like election
Integrity like today or uh balance
budget amendments or term limits and and
all the while talking to us about how
evil Congress is so the one thing that
we do know about a Convention of states
is that or an article 5 convention is
there's no mechanism or blueprint for
how that will take place so for me if
I'm going to engage in any kind of
activity I would imagine that I want
would want at least a rule book in place
before I get started you know that would
be like starting a game of football and
saying well you you know you only have
to get to the fifth yard line to get a
touchdown so I would think that in any
honest uh group of people before you
engage in any kind of activity at the
government level you would say this is
what we're going to do this is how the
rulebook is going to be played out and
so far that rule book really hasn't been
established that's a simple fact we can
talk about it all we want we could say
hey this is these reassurances over here
it's going to be limited to this it's
going to be limited to that but the
Constitution is silent on the mechanisms
and blueprints by which an article 5
convention will take place so um we know
that the uh the Articles of
Confederation were thrown out when there
was uh rules already attached to how
that convention would take place and the
delegates came in said nope we're not
going to play it that way um we also
know you know and we talk about uh
Congress all the time you know and it
always sounds Noble to people oh
congress is evil Congress is bad let's
reign in Congress but all the time these
state legislators and I I'm not pointing
any fingers and I'm not intending to
insult people but they're taking the
Congressional funds I mean look at the
dependency that the states have on
federal money I can't I can promise you
that most of it's probably not
constitutional however the state
legislators take the money or and
they're complicit in the same crimes as
Congress so here's the
thing um the States created the Federal
Government they didn't create us so for
us to go to them and ask for permission
as to how we can conduct ourselves and
where we get our freedom from is is a
bad precedent okay so the states do have
the uh the ability to push back on on
the federal government it's called
nullification article six so we should
start trying to do that um
so now when we talk about our delegates
and people that are uh coming to this
convention this whatever this limited
convention that they're imagining um are
they educated on the Constitution are
they moral are they good people we don't
know that we don't and and again once
you know we're not insulting anybody by
saying they're not educated on the
Constitution but the simple fact is I've
met many delegated partic delegates
particularly in state of Maine and they
don't know the Constitution at all to
send these people to Washington to start
talking about stuff that they don't know
anything about um the other thing that I
did notice too and um and initially I
will be honest like a few years ago I
was very interested in what cosos had to
say but I started looking at some of the
stuff that they were doing and in Maine
where I'm from for instance like they
literally try to pass like sp9 to change
the rules for how you know a a bill
could be passed so that they can push
through in Article 5 you know get the
Article 5 votes over there I mean so
when Convention of States doesn't want
get their way they'll sue the states
like the state constitution like they're
doing out in Kansas or they'll just
change the rules to suit themselves to
get what they want but here all the time
they're boning the immorality of
Congress Now isn't that something huh
Congress is immoral all the time but
somehow the states are not somehow
complicit in things that are bad so I
say I say to people you people here
today uh
and uh that maybe we could start looking
at some of the solutions uh from our
state level what we can do if we want to
be fiscally responsible let's figure out
ways to do that if we don't want the
state to be a burden on the taxpayers
let's figure out how we can do it at the
state level but opening up the entire
country to an article 5 convention is
completely irresponsible considering the
political climate that we're in today
and um I want to thank you for letting
me speak do you have any questions thank
you Mr roads
questions seeing none uh thank you for
traveling
here uh we still have uh four more cards
um asking for three minutes five minutes
uh two minutes and two minutes and uh
again as I said before uh you do not
need to we don't encourage repetition
we're looking for some new thoughts and
that said Anna Ben Ben aenas from
conquer or Guilford I'm sorry Anna well
welcome
AES um so I had something written down
but kind of everybody else said who's in
favor of this said what I wanted to say
um except that um I'm a mom of a
16-year-old I am a school librarian and
um regarding comments about experts um I
was just looking up the definition back
there and it doesn't mean that that they
are the Beall end all of everything and
perfect people who know exactly what
they are but they are very people who
are experts in something are very
um they've researched which is the whole
thing about being a librarian and you
know while going to grad school I
learned the critical importance of
careful and unbiased research and
um I wanted to say also that I feel this
is a big problem I don't know a lot
about the political system I'm a very
skeptical person and my husband and I um
he's part of an organization who
supports this this resolution as well
and we will have conversations where I
will constantly play The Devil's
Advocate because that's just how I am um
and he'll throw back data data data and
although I don't ConEd at the dinner
table I have to say now that he
definitely has researched and he is an
expert in this
um a big problem requires a big solution
I have never known where to turn um in
order to help with something like this
so I thank my husband as well as his
um I want to say colleagues but the
other people who volunteer and support
this resolution because um I trust in
what they have said because I've seen
the research what in the research that
they have done over many many years I
think 9 years is how long um some of the
people I know who have told me about
these things have been in it um I just
um I well I wrote I've I've listened to
experts on this resolution um I'm ready
to see it restore balance and integrity
to our elections so my kid who is close
to voting age at 16 um and other kids
they're my they're my people um grow up
in a system where they they know that
they are being represented with equality
and fairness
um and in addition I urge you when
hearing testimony or even just having
conversations with anybody in the
hallway um you ask questions like do you
have peer-reviewed articles do you have
supportive evidence for what you're
saying um I have a feeling that you
probably already do but I feel that that
a lot of times um
opinions get in the way and that no
matter where we are um we should rely on
facts and evidence thank you for um your
service thank you for being here and
thank you for hearing
me and thank you school librarians uh
Rock we need school librarians where
would we be without them um okay Eric
Ben Benitas is representing Wolfpack
he's for up to 5 minutes he Sports the
bill uh Eric welcome and I will try not
to thank you and I will try not to take
up that 5 minutes I'll try to go pretty
quick um I'd like to thank the chair and
the members of the committee for being
here today thank you for your time and
listening to my testimony um I support
hcr8 um applying to Congress for a
limited Article 5 Convention of States
um to address campaign Finance reform
I'm from Guilford resident of Guilford
um I think it was in 200 8 when I
finally realized how corrupt our
government really was um that our
federal politicians are charged with
representing us were representing a
specific population of people that could
uh spend billions in elections to buy
them um so I began searching for
organizations that were trying to fight
back um and after looking at many of
them I found Wolfpack uh this
organization stood out to me as having
the most effective and verified method
of getting the change to amend the
Constitution to uh address this
corrupting influence
um uh and they do it by using the
Article 5 convention process now being a
former librarian I did not take what
they said at face value I needed to do
the research myself I needed to back up
what they were saying by reading the
Articles um so I started doing my own
research and after going through many
many peer-reviewed articles and getting
crosseyed at all the reports that been
written on this subject that are peer-
reviewed that have been reviewed by uh
experts Congressional researchers um I
found out that there was a common theme
among all of them that although there
was opposition this is a safe process
and even though it's never been used it
will go exactly the way that we think it
will it will go it will propose an
amendment and it will be ratified and
that's how it was that was the
conclusion of every single one there is
I could could not find I searched I
could not find one peer-reviewed article
that said that this would go off the
rails that it would get out of control
that would rewrite the Constitution that
it would be able to ratify at the
convention there's not one that says
that um all those are books opinion
articles op-eds at which do not go to
peer-reviewed process and do not go
before researchers and as they said in
those peer-reviewed articles that is
because in order to make that argument
you have to ignore more history fact and
precedent in all those cases so um I
would just I would implore you to look
at some of that research um in doing so
furthermore it has been proven tool to
put pressure on Congress as our Prime
sponsor said during the 17th Amendment
it was used effectively almost every
movement in this country in the past has
used this method as part of putting
pressure on Congress the women's
suffrage movement the Civil Rights
Movement all of them used Article 5 five
convention calls to as an addition
strategy to make their point and to get
Congress to do what they wanted to
do
um as my wife you know she gives me too
much credit I'm not an expert in this
field at all I've done a lot of research
but I'm not an expert I don't propose to
be an expert I thank her though for for
her faith in me um and for the last nine
years I have um you know I've been
working on this issue I've been vol
ering with Wolfpack I first testified in
front of this committee uh when my child
was 7 years old and I had the naive hope
that some change would happen by the
time they reached voting
age um and unfortunately uh they are 16
now and this problem has only gotten
worse um I've you know we've received
empty promises of change symbolic
gestures that really make no difference
um
you know the illusion of change so you
might ask why am I still here why am I
why do I keep fighting and the truth is
it's for them um so I can look into my
child's eyes and tell them that I did
everything at my disposal to try to fix
this problem for them and I hope that
you can stay this say the same after
this I hope that you are using every
method at your disposal to get this
problem fixed for the people of New
Hampshire um so in closing um I'll leave
the committee with a final word urgency
every day we do not act our Democratic
Republic slips a little further away
from us every day we allow lobbyists to
roam these Halls uh or special interests
to drown out the voices of American
systems with buckets of money uh we
break our Oaths and pledges to The
Republic and to our democracy I
respectfully urge you to to pass this
important legislation out of committee
and again I thank the committee for its
time um and uh and the service to the
people of New Hampshire thank you I'll
take any questions you might have thank
you are there any
questions awesome say none I thank you
again we have two more cards one uh in
favor one opposed they've each asked for
two minutes uh supporting the bill uh is
uh I believe it's Hansen uh is it Rod
Hansen from Salem uh Bob Bob Hansen
Robert Bob Hansen from from Salem
welcome uh two minutes in support of the
Bill thank thank you for being here
thank you my name is Bob Hansen I'm a US
Navy veteran I've been a resident of
stem New Hampshire for over 50 years um
I hadn't plan on speaking today and I
just heard so many comments that I
thought maybe I could contribute to
simplify it a bit all all the fear about
what would happen would there be a
runaway convention or delegate it's not
going to follow the rules that they have
when you come down to it it really
doesn't
matter uh Article 5 gives the authority
to propose amendments it doesn't matter
how the delegates are chosen it doesn't
matter what they vote on and how they do
make their rules uh the House of
Representatives makes its own rules the
Senate makes its own rules it's not done
by the federal government Article 5 is
to bypass the government because the
government at this point to have an AR
Article 5 is shown that they're unable
to do the job but no matter what it's
proposed I can propose an amendment now
I can go to my legislature and propose
an amendment anybody can propose an
amendment all Article 5 convention does
is propos amendments the final decision
is made by the states you have to get 38
of the 50 states to agree to what was
done it doesn't matter how it was done
or who proposed it but these people at
invention going to come to some
agreement and there's two ways to make
an amendment Congress could do it and if
Congress doesn't do it then the
convention of states can do it there's a
movement of Convention of states and
hopefully Congress will turn around and
do something as a result of that some
bills have passed in that
manner if of the two ways of proposing a
bill Congress could write it or the
convention of States could write it if
Congress writes it it's probably going
to
have uh exceptions for them they'll have
this doesn't happen until some effective
date but they'll write it into to
maintain their own uh Powers if it's
done by a Convention of States you've
got a group of representatives from 50
people no matter how they were chosen
they don't have rules because they're
going to make their own rules they're
going to elect their offices that's the
way State conventions have done in the
past they're going to select their own
rules the simulation that was done in
August proved this and the people that
went to that had an opportunity to see
it so the convention of states is
powerless they cannot make a law they
cannot make an
amendment you don't need permission from
the government to throw out the
government you write a new Declaration
of Independence we're not controlled by
the Declaration that was our
justification for having the
Constitution we're controlled by the
Constitution that's all I have I'll
answer any questions thank you Mr Hansen
questions thank you say none thank you
right our final card here I'm sorry can
we have two we still have two cards uh
the uh person I mentioned before in
opposition to the measure who asked for
two minutes deshan Oliver did I say that
correctly desan Oliver welcome from um
English Drive is that English Village
Drive yes I used to live there not that
welcome well hello my name is deshun
Oliver and I'm a citizen here in New
Hampshire for two years now uh as you
may know I'm here to speak to you all on
house resolution 9 which is Article 5
con I'm
sorry oh sorry I misread I misspoke
sorry house resolution nine sorry okay
eight okay
you want to speak to eight cuz we're
going to do nine in just a bit okay
Carry On eight sorry I misspoke um
whatever you like to call it this is
this would allow delegates or otherwise
to amend the Constitution I truly
believe passing house resolution 8 is a
mistake especially since over the course
of the past Century all three branches
of the federal government executive
judicial and legislative branch has
vastly expanded their powers amending
the Constitution today will most
certainly result in our god-given
liberties being Stripped Away a most
recent example of this would be
political martyr Douglas Mackey Douglas
Mackey was a political prisoner for
seven months for simply posting memes
about Hillary Clinton in 2016 his speech
was meant to be protected under the
First Amendment this is merely one
example amongst many others Free Speech
religion privacy gun rights and many
more of our constitutional rights are
being violated because of big government
the entire purpose of the Constitution
is meant to keep the government small
enough to not violate our rights but big
enough to enforce them if Article 5
convention were to occur we would have a
gathering of delegates from all 50
states for the purpose of proposing
amendments to the Constitution who will
the delegates
be who are the delegates who will they
be and are they Constitution
constitutionally minded these are all
legitimate questions another danger and
probably the most dangerous is that we
could see a runaway convention consider
the constit tional convention in 1787
they did not stop revising the Articles
of Confederation they simply they
completely rewrote them a total rewrite
in
1787 may have been needed but under the
current political climate today could
spark a political collapse we do not
have the Statesmen of the past we have
politicians of the president of the
present that helped create the mess we
are in now ask yourself is the
Constitution truly the problem or is it
the outof control federal government
that ignores the Constitution as it
stands today thank
you thank you for coming up uh qu
work sorry yes I'm sorry can I ask who
you work for um I'm with the John bur
Society
thank you other
questions okay we have one more pink
card uh also from uh representing
Wolfpack asking for three minutes in
support of the bill is Sam Fel Felman
Sam has been here before uh Sam Sam up
to three minutes uh if you have
presumably you have something we haven't
heard yet uh so uh welcome uh thank you
very much and I appreciate your time uh
Mr chair and members of the committee
um I've been as I said I've been you
said I've been here before uh last year
talking about uh delegate uh bills and
and others as
well and the reason why I started
working with Wolfpack originally why I
originally got into this was for two
reasons their names are Hannah and Jenny
they're my twin daughters uh this was in
uh 2011 shortly before they were born um
and I started researching this process
trying to find a way to ensure that they
would grow up in a world where they
actually had some say in how their
government would work uh that they're
now 12 years old and that and I'm still
working on that in that time uh I've uh
spoken I've read an enormous amount of
research I've spoken to experts such as
uh John Kaminsky uh John FK whose
testimony you can read in Mr Sheriff's
uh giant PDF he testified before that uh
Committee in the Senate um uh Larry leig
Rob nen Michael Stern uh every one of
them also recognizes me as an expert and
the expert that I've become over that
time in Reading thousands and thousands
of pages about this process and the one
argument that I've never heard in all of
that time is that I don't exist um so
that was a new one but um the the
process of the convention that that we
see uh is not limited to just that one
brief line in uh in the US Constitution
the structure of the Constitution itself
um has baked into it a system of
federalism that I've testified about to
you before that ensures a safety net
with different parts of the process
being given to different branches of
government at different levels in the
state and federal uh level um and um
will happily send uh you can see a great
deal of uh of the research cited and
link to at wolfpack.com review which I
will send out and make available to the
committee um I will also send that to uh
to miss Dyer who uh is the committee um
researcher and I will also send her as
you requested uh there's a 1938 uh
primary source compendium on the uh
ratification conventions and I will send
her that and I've read extensively on
those as well and uh the concept of um
restricting delegates in fact the
delegate uh uh limitation bill that this
committee passed last year was based in
a large part on the language that came
out of the uh Article 5 uh uh proposing
Convent Article 5 ratification
conventions that we had in
1933 uh those were for the 21st
amendment not the 18th as was previously
stated um and that process showed used
limitations to make sure that the people
could vote on
resolution people could vote for uh for
or against different uh positions on
whether or not to repeal prohibition it
passed
ra rather easily um and the process
worked very well uh and that was a
process that people were scared of at
the time because we hadn't seen uh the
Article 5 convention process used for
either ratifications or for proposal we
used it for ratifications we know how
that worked it worked very well and we
can do the same for proposals right now
uh and I'm happy to take any and all
questions uh as I said I've I've spent a
long time researching
this thanks representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman
um I've heard your explanation and I've
heard from the opposition that seem some
of the who are opposed to hcr8 that
state now they use the phrase runaway
convention could you explain to me why
they might feel that way sure and
whether they're safeguards sure um the
uh a lot of it is based on the the
notion the the false notion that the
best precedent for this is the
1787 uh convention and it's also based
on some misconceptions about that that
Convention as well um first I want to
point out that um there are a great
number of different types of conventions
that we have precedent for uh the Trea
by Jameson in the mid 19th century and
then by in 1910 as a as a followup
to that
uh were the first really detailed
scholarly studies of different types of
convention processes and they compared
and contrasted different kinds of
conventions and we can see um based on
the way they laid out their
categorizations where where certain ones
have similarities and differences to the
Article 5 proposing convention and use
the precedent from each of those uh and
I gave a a talk specifically just about
that issue a couple years ago in
Colorado um the where we can use the
Precedence from each of those and
compare to establish what the
precedences are for control of the
article 5 uh proposing convention but
specifically the 1787 Convention um the
notion has been put forth that because
the Articles of Confederation required
unanimity to make a change that that
meant that the 1787 Convention um was a
runaway that it didn't do what its
mandate was in fact the 1787 Convention
uh was was proposed originally by the
Annapolis convention report um that
report was written by Alexander Hamilton
um because the Annapolis convention uh
was called for The Limited purpose of
dealing with economic issues um but at
the time there was the uh Shae Rebellion
going on and that scared everybody so
New Jersey asent their delegate with
much broader authority to um to address
the exigencies of the Union um but they
were the only delegate that did that
they were the only state that authorized
that the convention was not authorized
for that as a whole and no state had
authorized their delegates to to address
those issues so the instead Hamilton
took that language exigencies of the
Union put it in the report for the
Annapolis convention that same language
then ended up in the call from Congress
that uh that they used to suggest that
the states meet in convention um but
Congress was also particularly concerned
that this was not a convention under the
Articles of Confederation the articles
of confeder Federation had no convention
procedure this was an informal
convention called by the states that
Congress was simply suggesting that the
states uh attend through their language
and they were very concerned not to
appear that they were taking over the
process um the the states met uh all all
of them except for possibly New York had
that exigencies of the Union language uh
New York two of the three delegates
ended up leaving and the state did not
vote upon after that because they didn't
feel that it was within their purview um
okay okay I don't I don't I don't need
the whole history Sor about that follow
up M Mr chairman I just want to know
what are the safeguards that would be in
place today sure um so there are uh the
process is divided into what I refer to
as the safety net there are roles for
the courts to play in uh in ensuring uh
delegate limitation bills that different
states have those bills add to the
safety they are not required a lot of
this is baked in without them uh courts
also enforce um ratification procedures
we've seen precedent of Courts ruling on
Article 5 issues and we've also seen an
analogous uh State Court decision in
Florida on a very similar set of facts
where they did not allow something to go
on for ratification because it was
outside of the scope we've also seen um
Congress has an extensive role to play
Congress can only send things on for
ratification that have been properly
proposed that true whether it's proposed
by Congress they couldn't send something
on that was proposed by a simple
majority it would have to be proposed by
two-thirds of each house the same is
true for an article 5 convention they
could only send something on that's been
properly proposed by a convention and at
the state level whether it's through the
state legislatures or through State
conventions we've seen both processes
work extremely well to reflect the will
of the people um and then the delegate
selection itself the delegates are sent
there for the uh for a specific limited
purpose not with wedge ISS issues or all
kinds of other issues and when we see
people sent to someplace for a specific
purpose we tend to get people who are
serious about that issue and making sure
that it's handled properly and those
four separate is um parties I don't
trust any one of them on their own but I
trust the network built into the
framework of our constitution for all of
them working
together thank you uh any other pressing
questions uh representative
filio it was addressed somewhat in the
previous answer but I am concerned about
the justic ability of the article 5
issues and particularly whether the
courts are going to view this as a
political question while there's been
analogies drawn to the faith of selector
question which is certainly a justable
issue because it concerns election law
my concern is that if we were to give
for example limiting instructions the
court may actually throw their hands up
in the air because it's a political
question that is specifically delegated
to the political branches do you have
any case law or any opinion on to
whether or not this would actually be
justiciable if it came to that yes so um
and I believe hawy Smith which is
referenced in the material sent out by
the um uh by your uh researcher uh it it
references that um that certain things
that are especially things in Article 5
that may be assigned to a legislature
are not inherently
legislative uh that that is the case
here as well uh you can see in Article 5
of The Constitution uses the word
Congress must do this or that it is not
discretionary it is not their normal
legislative activity Article 5 is also
not article one um where their
legislative activity comes from um and
uh because of that I'm I'm very
confident that courts would see fit to
step in and they have stepped in before
and dealt with Article 5 related issues
uh not just limited to the list that's
um that's on the back of that case uh
but including that list um and uh we
we've seen that numerous times as well
as that Florida case that is on an
analogous set of issues where the court
Sam S no Hans thank you uh so much for
coming back thank you and with your
comprehensive answers at this
time uh we'll call a termination to this
sharing we have one more measure this
morning uh and this measure hcr9 is uh
very much kind of the flip side of hcr8
hcr8 was uh uh in favor uh supportive of
an article 5 situation uh hcr9 is is the
flip side of
that excuse me so I'm looking at the uh
prospective speakers and it's a lot of
the same folks who spoke the last time
now I'm going to ask uh uh the the prime
sponsor has all the time that she needs
to completely uh present the bill um the
folks who want to speak to it what the I
think I can speak for the committee uh
we do not need to hear you say the same
thing for or against uh Article 5
convention that we just heard uh over
the last couple of hours and so I'm
going to ask that you if you uh are just
going to repeat what you said before
only flipping it uh we already have that
and we get that so uh once we get to the
pink cards I'm going to ask you to keep
it to a minute or two and and and you're
welcome also to wave I also want to
respect anybody who who has not yet
spoken uh who's traveled here uh we want
to hear what you have to say and let it
be recorded so all that said here's
another pink card um let's get right to
it representative maarda the prime
sponsor you have as much time as you
would like and uh and again as I said I
hope that the uh the following speakers
will keep it to a minute uh or two uh
welcome R mcarter thank you Mr chair uh
Nicki mcarter from Belmont representing
belnap uh County District 8 um a lot of
uh the materials obviously have already
been covered as you indicated so I'm not
going to belabor the issue um I
submitted um the draft for hcr9 at the
um urging of several constituents one of
them is in this room uh to speak to this
today and um it was proposed to me in
such a fashion that I couldn't um I
couldn't say that it wasn't a good idea
to submit this legislation
um I don't know about any of you with
regards to what the federal government
is doing now has been doing historically
over several decades but I don't trust
them I don't trust that they have any of
our uh interests in uh our best
interests at heart when they make the
decisions um at the federal level so I
can um agree with several of the
previous speakers that I think what we
need to do is start here at home to make
some changes um let go of the federal uh
wallet that they keep handing to us to
grab I I just think that we need to
start here at home and opening up the
most uh beautiful historical document
that uh our country exists on today is
probably a very dangerous thing in this
political climate perhaps another time
in history it may have been uh a
workable thing where we can all trust
each other and Trust who's there and
Trust what they're going to do and the
issues are only going to be uh uh
specific to you know what this what what
this is going to resend the balance
budget um article and application but
right now there is a house concurrent
resolution in the US House of
Representatives that um is looking to
aggregate all of the open applications
together into one um one pile so that
they can get to the 34 states that they
need and that tells me this convention
will not be issue specific for each
application it tells me that they're
going to lump it all together and uh go
on a distruction spree I just I fear
that and I think it's pretty
well-founded uh fear at this point
I would uh just urge you to uh ought to
pass or vote a to pass um for hcr9 I
have some plenty of people here in the
room that I'm sure can back me up on
this or speak against I guess so thanks
for your time
today thank you refer mcarter uh
sponsor O Okay seeing none um let's get
right to our uh pink cards repres
Granger
uh represent Mardo was the Prime sponsor
and the sole sponsor uh R Granger uh you
asked for five minutes I'm going to give
you one to two to be I have to be
consistent I I understand so uh I'm just
going to go through a a list in that
case uh thank you for having me on here
uh I would like to reiterate that uh any
research that you can do on an article 5
convention is a research into conjecture
there is no existing case of an article
5 convention being used therefore any
claims that you can be an expert in it
or that you've done a lot of research or
anything like that it it doesn't matter
because you're talking about something
that's never happened before it's all
just mere
hypothesis uh one of the previous
speakers mentioned that they supported
Article 5 conventions in Maine on
multiple topics isn't that a little
interesting it's almost as though
perhaps uh there is an interest in many
people's minds to support Article 5
conventions generally not for the exact
claims that they're pushing this
specific one on all right um the
Constitutional Convention that brought
about our current
constitution was intended to only
provide amendments to the Articles of
Confederation that's why all the states
were on board with that except Rhode
Island Rhode Island had nothing to do
with it they were they didn't want
anything to do with that um they walked
out with a whole new constitution uh
this is I don't want to belabor that
point but I did want to bring that
up so here's a question do current are
the politicians and the Statesmen and
the people we have now morally
equivalent of the people that existed
back then are we of the same character
as the people in this late 1700s who
fought a revolution against the British
I don't think we are um I like myself
and I like most of the people on this
committee but we are not those people we
are good people we're not nearly as good
as they were and any Constitutional
Convention that takes place will not
result in a constitution that's nearly
as good as the one we got by mere fluke
the fact that our constitution is this
good is a weird it's a bizarre nature of
reality thing there's no there's
basically no chance of a constitution
ever coming out of anybody that's as
good as the one we have we should be
thanking our lucky stars that we have
one that's as good as it is and uh we
should not try to change it at all if
congression thank you representative I I
have to be consistent here I'm going to
be holding other people to one to two
minutes um and so I have to be uh that
way W with you uh uh thank you I won't
be able to stay for the rest of the
testimony though okay uh we'll carry on
here right Matthew uh please take a
minute or two to uh hopefully give us
something um something new something new
oh okay well I'll do that for you my
name is Matthew rhods and if I didn't
mention this before I am a proud member
of the John Birch Society the reason I
didn't mention it is because I'm not a
uh what do they call them lobbyist you
know like that make six figures a year
that come in to speak for special
interest groups I come as a private
citizen so I want to make sure that
because uh you guys are aware of that
there was no deception intended because
we have Ken Quinn with the uh term
limits USA doxing me on social media by
showing my picture that I'm JBS to the
audience here so let me say one thing
new for you
guys you don't want to be in bed with
these people they are
immoral okay they are bullies they'll
push you around and they will intimidate
you and they will put their hands on you
and if I had to get sworn testimony to
that fact I could do it very easily how
I've been shoved pushed and intimidated
so I think that what I'm going to say
you guys if you could we we're
interested in you speaking to to the
measure and not about the personal well
character was brought up by Ken Quinn
and that was that was intimated by him
pointing out that I was a member of JBS
so I figured that was an it was open uh
for for that so what I would say is that
I think we have to be very careful about
who we do business with in politics and
be very careful about their moral
compass that they're pushing Us in uh
hcr9 is a great way to restore the
states to their sovereign powers and to
begin pushing back on the federal
government and I thank you very much for
hearing me and thank you I have a
message that represent of kale is here
represent kale uh uh you did not speak
to the last measure correct and again
these are related measures so uh you're
welcome to take a couple of minutes um
and and speak uh I don't have I don't
see a card for you I turned in a card
okay so just uh if you could let if your
position for or against and uh and we'll
give you a couple minutes for sure thank
you Mr chair thank you uh honorable
committee members um I I'm opposed to
this
legislation um and and I won't go into
everything that you've already heard
over and over again in multiple hearings
over multiple years I'm just going to
bring up um this fact imagine just for a
second that we had never ratified the
19th Amendment to the US Constitution
and we never gave women the right to
vote what tool then could they be using
now to get the right to vote an article
5 convention would be a tool that they
could use to get the right to vote I
also believe that we can't just accept
one piece of the Constitution and cut it
apart we have to accept all pieces of
the Constitution and I don't think we
should silence the voice of the
legislative body that voted to adopt
this resolution in the past and I think
we should leave it as it is and I'll
take any questions thank you for that
questions seeing none uh thank you thank
you very
much okay Eric Benitas has spoken before
uh in support of the previous measure uh
opposed obviously to this measure uh
Eric uh take a minute or two yeah I I'll
be really quick um uh I Eric Ben is
Guilford uh opposed to this uh
resolution um I'm not opposed the the
resolution itself um mentions a previous
resolution that is trying to resend a
specific one and I do not have a problem
with that like if you have problem with
the subject matter of a resolution for
Article 5 that's totally fine like if if
you don't agree with the amendment that
it's proposing that's totally fine what
we need to do is separate the Article 5
process and the subject matter that is
brought up on the Article 5 process is
just a method if you don't like laws
that are being passed in New Hampshire
you don't go after the process of us
passing laws you don't say we should not
pass any laws because I don't agree with
this law right it's it's a process
that's in the Constitution given to us
as a state as a right for us to be able
to pass res uh amendments the same as
Congress does so uh I think that we just
need to separate these two methods and
if you don't agree with the subject
matter of something that's totally fine
you can push to resend that subject
matter but putting all this language in
fearmongering against the Article 5
process is what I disagree with because
that is just a process in the
Constitution that we are using utilizing
to get our state's rights so that's all
I have to
say thank you for that pressing question
we don't want to miss any pressing
question questions all right thank you
so much uh Hal schliff is still here is
Hal yes Hal was spoken earlier he said
he has uh written testimony and yes I'm
going to do it a little quick I'm not
going to address what I already did but
this uh particular resolution will
resend New Hampshire's only application
because in
2010 the uh you wisely rended all of
them and in 2012 this was added it's
calling for a balanced budget amendment
and most people in this room like the
that idea of a balanced budget me but
you have to examine it I have a copy of
the resolution and the resolution says
that um the balanced budget with certain
exceptions ah this the Escape Clause
that they don't mention in the
resolution well all of the proposed um
balanced budget Amendments have two
Escape Clauses war and National
Emergency we are right now there are 41
National emergencies that we are
currently in going back to Jimmy Carter
okay and um National National
emergencies are not in the Constitution
so if this is passed You' not only will
you give Congress no incentive or the
president to get out of a national
emergency you'll make that
constitutional okay the other thing too
is uh a balanced budget again we need a
constitutional budget not a balanced
budget a balanced budget May mean
massive tax hikes it may mean massive
cutting of federal funds at the state
level which in my opinion it wasn't such
a bad idea which then if you don't cut
the size of government you'll have to
raise state taxes so say sometimes
things sound good in fact in 1988 when I
first heard about this I thought what
would be against a balanced budget
amendment but then you got to read the
fine print and with that I thank
you thank you Mr Sheriff uh pressing
questions if you have one uh sound
off okay Haley Shaw is still is Haley
still there Haley spoke earlier um Haley
if you could take a minute or two to
measure hi Haley Shaw Allenstown New
Hampshire representing uh Convention of
States action um I'm going to keep it
really simple I think it's in the best
interest of New Hampshire moving
forward uh I'm against this by the way I
forgot to say that sorry
um well just have to make it clear um I
think it's probably the best interest of
New Hampshire moving forward with
discussions of runaway conventions or
Rogue Commissioners or anything like
that I think it's in the best interest
of your state to you know feel if you
need to protect yourself and pass what I
would call a model legislation uh for
selecting Commissioners so what is the
process for selecting a commissioner in
New Hampshire um I have something
similar to that right here but that
displays and walks through the entire
process for any delegate that would go
to a convention for New Hampshire uh it
also would identify what would happen if
they do go Rogue um and you could you
know have criminal penalties put on them
so I would say moving forward it's
probably in your best interest to pass
legislation that protects you and the
way to do that is with something like a
faithful delegate so that's that's all I
have to say
thanks thank you
Haley
okay uh Al B brandino has opposed to the
bill of course he supported the previous
measure uh Al's already spoken um on the
previous measure Al if you could take a
minute or two on on this
one thank you sir
um I am opposed uh to this bill and I'm
representing the convention of States uh
I'm the state director here in New
Hampshire on this um I want to just
start with the word courage and the noun
it's a noun the ability to do something
something that frightens
one so what is the solution I ask the
people in opposition to this what is the
solution hope is no longer an option uh
all of us are you swore an oath and if
you're in the military swear oath
forever I didn't realize that but you
swear an oath to the Constitution New
Hampshire and the US Constitution and
specifically for us you know our civic
duty puts us above
um a above party right we do this for
our country country we do it for the
Constitution so if you look specifically
New Hampshire part one article 18 and 38
gives you your direction and our
Direction so to the fair Merchants that
we heard today what else in the
Constitution shouldn't we follow think
about those young soldiers or men and
women in a foxhole in Afghanistan or
Iran when they were being overrun did
they sit there and say gez I want
everyone to know that I was only for the
first and third uh amendment I wasn't
for all the amendments of the
Constitution does that make any sense
doesn't make any sense at all it's all
or none you can't pick and
choose uh the most despicable fear of
all I heard today was that men and women
don't have the intestinal fortitude and
they aren't the people that they were in
1789 oh my gosh do I beg to disagree I
have to tell you do you think uh Abraham
Lincoln's father knew he was going to
have Abraham Lincoln a Mother Teresa's
mother knew she was going to have mother
traser or uh and and with the people we
don't know what we're going to be you
didn't know as Representatives that you
were going to be here but something
changed in your life that made you do it
it's courage right courage to do
something that we're afraid
of and the last bit that really troubles
me
is the nonsense of fearmongers the last
one a substitute of the Constitution is
that you're going to have George Soros
and Mark meckler and everyone else
appoint and create a constitution come
on this is really nonsense and shouldn't
even be considered I want to leave you
with this with courage with the ability
to do something that makes you afraid
and do what's right for the people
please thank you thank you Mr
brandano saying no hands up uh we'll go
to representative JD Bernardi who spoke
earlier uh in support of the previous
Bill and he's opposing this bill um
welcome representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee uh again JD Bernardi
Rockingham 36 uh I I just want to
reflect again on one of the statements I
made earlier I served in a simulated uh
convention this last summer with
representative massamillo we stayed on
target we didn't pass any resolution to
get rid of the Second Amendment we
stayed on target runaway was not the
problem the other point I want to make
is we've heard again and again that that
that because the article itself Article
5 doesn't have any mechanism of how the
convention is supposed to be conducted
it you know it's it's going to be a
crazed event that's going to go all over
the place well the Constitution's only
about 4,000 plus words and it has a lot
of things in it that are not highly
specified we pass laws to deal with
flushing those things out and we use
tradition and the tradition of
conventions has been one state one vote
delegates chosen by the state
legislators those those delegates are
faithful to the state
legislators so you have an example of
that in the 1861 peace conference which
was an article 5 convention to try to
thwart what was going on with the what
became the Civil War so there are
examples it works it worked in the
simulated convention it it's worked in
our history uh I urge you to reject this
resolution and continue to support the
need for a Balan budget amendment uh or
or and and I want to reflect on the
words that uh Mr shirtliff said that
because it it had uh some Escape clause
in there remember the resolution allows
the representative to go to the
convention and discuss with the
delegates from the other states and
craft the amendment that resolution is
not the amendment it's the operating
parameters which you use to generate
Amendment which then comes back to the
to at least 38 states to ratify thank
you very much thank you
representative and uh seeing No Hands we
will Press On uh Sam fieldman has asked
for one to two minutes to uh speak in
opposition to the bill Sam has spoken
earlier and there he is uh welcome back
thank you I promise it'll be nothing
that I've said before um the the groups
that you're seeing here um opposing this
resolution are groups like Wolfpack uh
Convention of States us term limits
these are all separate groups none of
whom have any particular interest in
this particular resolution they are all
as as Mr venidas pointed out uh pushing
back against the language in this
Precision if you were sined simply
because you no longer agree with the
balanced budget amendment uh effort I
have no problem with that I don't think
any of the other groups are um and it's
important to keep in mind that these
groups are also separate from each other
and things that apply to one do not
necessarily apply to another in terms of
their political activity I make it a
point to be an expert not only on the
convention process itself but also on
the political activity of the different
groups and how they operate and in
particular you'll notice one group that
you are not seeing here is any group
that is specifically working on the
effort to get a balanced budget
amendment and there's an important
reason for that uh they also don't
particularly care one way or the other
if you resend this uh 2012 call from uh
from New Hampshire and the reason is
after doing further research they've
come to the conclusion and frankly I
think they are correct uh that in as of
1983 there were already 34 calls for a
uh a convention Limited to the issue of
fiscal responsibility and once you hit
34 subsequent recisions no longer matter
you've got an agreement from the states
for a convention limited to that subject
matter and whatever happens after that
doesn't matter it's already enforcable
as of that point um that is many of
those convention calls that they are
relying on have since been rescinded and
are not available to be used by the
other uh groups which is why this has uh
their argument has no bearing on what
the other groups are working on um and
also why they don't care about this
particular recision and the ones who do
care about uh about it care only about
the language not the actual attempt to
resend um it's also very similar HCR 24
in Congress is uh doing something very
similar and that it's looking
specifically at these different calls
limited to the issue of fiscal
responsibility as well I think that
particular resolution is not worded
particularly well but it's also not
going to pass so it doesn't really
matter um so it's easy to misconstrue as
something that's intended to combine
different topics but that is not the
intent or what it actually
questions seeing none thanks again uh
Sam I have two more cards here on hcr9
um Ken Quinn has spoken earlier uh Mr
Quinn uh there he is you mentioned uh
you have written testimony which we
appreciate um was that the for the
previous measure or for this one or for
both the the written testimony that
you're cired mentions yeah I provided
one for
each testimony so there's there's a
separate written testimony for nine as
opposed to exactly for both yeah I I I
handed it in for nine as well okay I got
you speak um okay and uh we have a
couple minutes for you to speak to this
one as well thank you so much yes I uh
again Ken Quinn
um I will give you some new information
it's actually old information and I'm
like to just point out that this
resolution hcr9 was downloaded by the
John off of the John bir society's
website this is their model language for
resend
resolutions and I find it quite
interesting that even in their model
language they mention a limited
convention so I I find that very ironic
um something about the John bir society
and and this is what you really need to
understand the John bir Society from its
very beginning uses fear let me just
give you some examples the founder
Robert Welch okay um M Mr qu really want
to focus on the language of the proposed
resolution I will as opposed to uh
getting into uh the the motives and the
character of uh I understand so uh carry
on the resolution itself is very uh
convoluted because it refers to the
Declaration of Independence um the
Declaration of Independence is from
1776 Article 5 was not established at
that time so the law the current law
that we are under and that the states
are under is Article 5 under the
Constitution which was ratified by New
Hampshire the 9th state in
1788 so to try to use the language from
the Declaration of Independence as a
sovereign convention under Article 5
makes absolutely no sense it is just
what article 5 is is the principle of
allowing the people to alter their form
of government when they feel it's
necessary so they actually put that
principle in Article 5 and that's why we
have this ability Congress can propose
amendments if you notice the language of
Article 5 says amendments in the plural
but it's in plural for both when
Congress proposes and when the states
propose now the only time out of the
11,000 amendments Congress has ever
proposed more than one amendment was the
Bill of Rights so every other amendment
has been a single Amendment which means
since Article 5 is equal between the
state legislatures and Congress the
states have the authority and the right
to propose a single Amendment and that's
exactly what Federalist paper state
federal st85 if the unit if the states
are united in a particular Amendment so
it's very clear and I'm glad that the
John Birch society's model language
identifies a limited convention um this
idea of a runaway again is all based on
a misunderstanding or rewriting of
History where it's a dishonoring of the
framers they want you to believe that we
have an illegal Constitution the framers
did not violate their Commissions in
fact if you read the Virginia call it
does not require the state legislators
to confirm the uh the ratification or
the adoption of the uh Constitution the
ratification process was left in the if
you read the the language to the states
meaning either state legislators could
ratify the Constitution or the people in
convention so they even provided for
that so to claim that they violated the
very ratification process is absolutely
untrue so with that I will end my
testimony thank
you thanks again Mr Quinn uh
questions
uh we do have uh one more now two more
cards uh Jim Jim
loose 69 old Hancock road I don't know
what community that is but I'm sure
in Hancock New Hampshire all right uh M
loose uh you you did not speak to the
you haven't spoken yet today is that
correct no right so uh take at least a
couple minutes sure uh welcome I'll try
to be thank you very much Mr chairman
and thank you all uh I know I I don't
attend these and I'm very impressed with
the manner in which this is conducted
which I believe in effect would be the
manner in which uh Convention of States
would be conducted I happen to be
against this resolution uh to resend uh
simply because I think it's a bit of a
troan horse and I think it was designed
to uh probably undermine the capacity to
uh conduct uh similar types of uh uh
conventions uh and I think if it's if
it's accepted unfortunately it's going
to undermine that that opportunity in
the future and I'm all in favor I think
we are uh here in New Hampshire live
free die U and I've only lived here for
the past four years uh but I I love the
spirit of New Hampshire and I think uh
the convention of States uh carries that
very same kind of spirit which is uh
namely we have to have faith uh we can't
operate out of fear uh when I hear that
U the quality of uh of Americans has
dropped uh individually and that's a
cause for us not to uh to do this I I
I'm offended I know someone else
mentioned that I think uh we all have
the you know the capacity to rise to the
occasion uh and I just wanted to make
that clear uh I uh I have faith in the
manner which uh this could be carried
out um and I think it will be done in a
uh professional way and uh we should
have uh less concern about fear and we
should operate on the basis of faith and
courage going forward
so I just wanted to share that thank you
Mr loose thank you for coming to New
Hampshire thank you for coming to the uh
to conquer today and thank you for the
kind words uh questions for uh Mr
loose thanks again thank you the I have
in my hand the final pink card uh
individuals asked for 30 seconds and we
can approximately approximately and we
can round that up as necessary uh
represent Reed welcome welcome back
thank you once again I missed you all um
so I am not stating a support or against
for this uh particular piece of
legislation um if you want to resend a
call you should do so on policy my
position is um the mechanism here is
solid as you already know for all the
reasons that have been uh testified to
but I did want to challenge one argument
we've heard repeatedly whether it's from
members of the John Birch Society or
whatever opposition um whether or not
they properly identified themselves and
that is the idea that the federal
government the big government is bad The
Constitution's purpose the entire
purpose of the Constitution the function
it has is to limit and restrain the
government so they'll say that the big
government is bad but we don't want to
actually change the Constitution that is
actually empowering that government
because the Constitution is perfect but
if the Constitution is perfect then why
is the government bad and that is the
kind of Disconnect I wanted to call out
and finally I there's the question of
whether or not we have the power or you
know should we have the power and the
Constitution that perfect document that
they themselves think is perfect um does
operate on federalism it is one of our
checks and balances we frequently think
of the three branches of government as a
check and balance but also it is
federalism the tension between the small
and the large governments and it's
throughout the entire con Constitution
that we operate on that principle but I
just want to read one specific piece of
the Constitution that will reaffirm
because when the framers wrote the
Constitution they made sure to cover
their bases they basically said whatever
we didn't cover here is up to the states
that is the 10th amendment in the Bill
of Rights of the Constitution which says
the powers not delegated to the United
States by the Constitution nor
prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the states respectively or
to the people it means whatever we
didn't cover here is up to the states so
you thank you to the uh representative
from New Market at this time I will end
that hearing uh we have we have one more
measure this afternoon at 1 p.m. which
will start right at 1 p.m uh I want to
thank everybody who uh hung in there and
and uh we'll see everybody back at at 1
pm.
okay we will get started in about one
list yeah uh I get a email with the uh
so Ralph is sitting F
Phillis
uh
okay we do have pink cards represent
Simpson uh yes pink cards
man
okay folks stand by and we will um
commence just a couple minutes late we
time okay welcome this afternoon we have
one measure it's
hcr1 uh that is the house concurrent
resolution condemning medically
unnecessary restrictions on medication
abortion the prime sponsor is
representative Simpson and she is in
place welcome representative
Simpson thank you Mr chair good
afternoon honorable members of the
committee for the record I am
representative Alexis Simpson and I
represent exitor new Fields New Market
and stratum thank you for hearing house
concurrent resolution number
11 in 1991 New Hampshire was the first
state in the nation to adopt a state
resolution urging the US Food and Drug
Administration to allow clinical trials
of M mistone in medication abortions and
encouraging the United States to
introduce it due to its significant
medical
value this bipartisan resolution from
1991 also called
hcr1 passed over 30 years ago the New
Hampshire legislature in 1991 saw the
importance of these clinical trials and
took action by passing the resolution to
send a message both to the US FDA and
also to Granite Staters about their
priorities and their bipartisan support
for safe legal abortion now we find
ourselves in
2024 with the very real threat of this
Access to Health Care being taken away
as the US Supreme Court takes up a case
challenging the fda's approval of
mistone the first pill of medication
abortion medication abortion is not
controversial for decades mffa prisone
has been a safe an effective means to
obtain an abortion early in
pregnancy since the fall of roie Wade
there are no longer Federal protections
assuring people that they will be able
to access abortion we have seen this
play out across the country with over 20
states banning
abortion this Supreme Court case however
is not about a specific State ban
instead it would impact all states even
here in New
Hampshire
where abortion is legal until 24
weeks medication abortion is critical
for patients in New Hampshire
particularly for constituents in rural
areas rural Access to Health Care
remains a challenge in all areas of
Health Care when it comes to sexual and
reproductive Health Care people should
be able to get their abortion care in
the way that works best for their lives
and for many patients medication
abortion including mha pistone is what
them since the court case came out of
Texas and has been taken up by the
Supreme Court I've been looking for a
way to stand up for our constituents
here in New
Hampshire I can't emphasize this enough
this case will impact the entire country
even in States like ours where abortion
is legal the people who brought this
case forward have one goal to ban
abortion outright and they're using the
courts to to try to accomplish this goal
just like we saw with the overturning of
Row versus
Wade and the newest case regarding
emergency abortion care when a woman's
life is at risk we cannot allow these
politically motivated attacks to go
unchecked supporting hcr1 is a concrete
action the state of New Hampshire can
take to show support for medication
abortion access mistone is exceptionally
safe highly effective and has has been
used by more than 5 million people in
the United States since the FDA approved
it more than 20 years
ago with this house concurrent
resolution we have a chance to return to
Our Roots we can act as our legislature
did in 1991 in a bipartisan vote and
assure our constituents that we will
fight against medically unnecessary
restrictions on medication
abortion let's do everything we can to
ensure that Granite Staters have access
to the best possible reprodu healthare
that they can receive no matter where
they live in the state I respectfully
ask for your vote of ought to pass on
hcr1 thank
you thank you representative Simpson
this today obviously is a hearing and
we're all going to get smarter about and
more knowledgeable about different
aspects of this I've had uh a couple
doctors uh uh sent contact me and send
me information and they're sending me
information and they'll share the
committee so we'll have this information
that's forthcoming to to evaluate before
we exact this yeah um and I I should say
that there are providers who will
testify today who will have answers to
any more technical questions that you
have um medical questions I'm I'm not a
medical doctor so
um just letting you know ahead of time
okay fine I did have one or two kind of
medical related questions um I'll throw
them out to you as the prime and you can
defer
absolutely um the the questions had the
two that I have at this point and there
may be others that you may may not be
able to answer ectopic pregnancies are
pregnancies that uh the 100% chance no
chance of uh of the uh embryo surviving
that that's correct or that's my
understanding that's that's my
understanding too and my understanding
is with ectopic
pregnancies uh the use you know me uh
medicinal terminations um are are
commonplace um that said of course we
have the the in New Hampshire we have
the 24 week uh La uh post 24 weeks uh I
don't know so I'm asking and you may
medicinal abortions uh post 24 weeks
um Can can a pregnancy be termin ated
after 24 weeks medically I do actually
know the answer to that question no so
medication abortion can only be used
early in pregnancy I I think up until 11
weeks you can confirm that number but I
don't think it can be used after 11
weeks okay that's an important question
and and uh that's was kind of my
understanding but you can thanks for
confirming that and I'm I'm sure others
will speak to that as well other
question questions for the prime
representative
filot thank you for taking my question
in the resolution it says that the state
will seek to protect and expand access
to medication abortion can you explain
what it means to expand access to
abortion sure thank you for the question
so um some of our rural areas have um
limited access to reproductive
Healthcare across the spectrum of
reproductive Healthcare
and so
um it's just a consistent thing that I I
believe that our um we should do as the
state is to make sure that everybody has
access to health care so I would say
access to reproductive health care of
which medication abortion is a piece is
is important for all of our Granite
Staters
yeah represent levit thank you chair I'm
off for taking my
question does no other states should
have any legislation like this um and
process I don't know how other states do
um resolutions okay I'm sorry I'm not
sure if someone behind me does know that
but I I'm unsure of how other states
deal with a resolution So currently are
there any states that have this law in
effect that people are able to take this
medication
currently oh so you're not speaking of
this so this piece of legislation pull
away from that just pull away from that
current ly are there and if there are
what states if any are
currently able to use this
medication um every state that allows
abortion access early in pregnancy is
able to use medication abortion as far
as I know I do think we should ask a
provider who may be in touch with folks
in other states but medication abortion
is a very regular way for um folks to
receive abortion early in pregnancy so
in any state that allows that they would
allow okay thank you for that answering
that are there any that do not followup
chair Moffett followup are there any
that do not offer it as far as you know
I'm afraid I don't know okay well thank
you
yeah other questions for the prime
sponsor representative
Rollins yes thank you Mr chairman do we
know what will happen to the mother's
health if she takes it after 11th week
like say in desperation she takes it on
the 15th 20th 25th week what do we know
medically will happen if in desperation
she takes that abortion pill will it
affect her so a medication a medication
abortion pill can only be dispensed um
by a medical provider it's a
prescription it's a prescription so it
can only be given under the um
under the guidance and care of a medical
provider so um any medical provider that
provides it would know how many weeks
questions okay okay uh uh representative
Prime sponsor Simpson thanks so much uh
we have a number of pink cards here and
um I'm going to go to thank you uh yes
there are no questions right represent P
your hand's not in the air correct
okay got it uh thank you uh
representative Harkin Phillips from
representative welcome I mean Hello I
should say thank you for the welcome
um so I'm honored to be with you as a
co-sponsor supporting
hcr1 and I apologize to those in the
room who have already heard my prepared
remarks um but I will be repeating it
again as often as it is needed so um I'm
here to limit my um discussion to two
overall points giving the compelling
testimony you will hear today from
Advocates before you first
I'm here to relay an important
constituent
story for your consideration so there is
an OBGYN and dhmc physician who is also
a professor at the geel school of
medicine who lives in my district
Grafton
12 this physician is licensed to
practice in both Vermont and New
Hampshire and has recently reported to
reported to me
directly that the attacks limitting his
medical practice in New Hampshire are
pushing him to stop offering his
Provider Services in New Hampshire and
move his clinical practice exclusively
to
Vermont he feels that laws regulating
abortion care are an unfair intrusion on
his medical decision-making which follow
national standards of
care and are an intrusion upon his
professional
experience this resolution if passed
would provide him an important signal of
support that New Hampshire trusts its
OBGYN Physicians and values their
difficult but meaningful
work protecting vital access to abortion
medication is an important part of his
clinical work and passing this
resolution will assure doctors like him
that New Hampshire is serious about
giving providers all the tools they need
to best serve their
patients an important moral Victory
after these reason attacks on his
profession and it will restore
confidence in New
Hampshire's um Physicians that their
legislators are putting people and their
health care before
politics for that reason I hope you will
support this resolution but secondly I'm
here personally to express my really
just deep disappointment that we even
need to expend this kind of collective
energy and these resources to ener Ain
resolutions like this protecting
reproductive health care for women
without acknowledging and without naming
the true discrimination that pregnant
individuals in New Hampshire are facing
due to these ongoing political
attacks the mere fact that we're not
discussing the efficacy and wisdom of
condemning medically unnecessary
restrictions on Mal's reproductive
Health Care decisions and
medications which for the record
are not nearly as safe or effective as
abortion medications demonstrates the
true discrimination against an injustice
thrust upon women and pregnant people
here in New
Hampshire this is the point that really
gets me
going attacks on access to women's
health care but not Men's Health Care is
blatant discrimination on
sex based upon sex and it's a
substantial government interference into
Medical
privacy even though I am obviously very
upset by this uh and and these recent
attacks on my constituent Physicians but
also on my body I am dedicated to
climbing every proverbial Mountain to
support bills like this resolution
hcr1 to ensure access to safe and
effective medication and
um for women's reproductive healthare or
you know continue into the future and i'
just like to say for those two reasons
I'm going to urge this committee to
please pass hcr1 thank
you thank you representative questions
oh would you take questions if there are
any Jen if I could just add one more
thing um certainly so I have a close
relationship with the chair of obst
obric and Gynecology at dhmc and I just
was recently speaking with her uh last
week and um I think that we need to
recognize that the current situation in
our Marketplace for New Hampshire's
women reproductive healthare is quite
desperate at the moment there are
several members of seniority from that
department who have recently retired or
left and they're in the middle of a
recruitment um wave of young Physicians
trying to study the field of practice
that
they are in and they're having
difficulty recruiting top quality
candidates to our state as well this is
not I'm sorry I'm making a third point I
just
realized it's not something that is
inconsequential and I you know we're
losing
Trusted Senior members of gynecological
services for our state which you know
you can count how many there are there's
not many departments in the state that
offer these
services and they're also having trouble
recruiting new members to these
departments so um I just want you to
recognize this is a real problem in real
time and that this resolution can go a
long way to helping resolve those
problems so please please heed the the
information I'm sharing with you today
and of course I'm happy to answer any
questions you mentioned dhmc that's
Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center yeah
okay sort of it's currently called um
Dartmouth Health now the larger Network
umbrella but dhmc is the specific
Lebanon tertiary care system that
handles most of these reproductive
procedures other
questions seeing none thank you
representative representative from
Hanover uh I have another representative
here um representative Katie ponel um
from um the wolfboro area repr pel
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
committee I'm Katie peternell
representative of wol BR in tooro Carrol
district 6 I am here in opposition to
this bill um this HCR to begin with um
I'm not sure when an abortion is truly
ever medically necessary it should
really only ever be used when a woman's
health is in danger and I am actually
one of those women and if you would ever
care to hear my story I was a patient at
Dartmouth Hitchcock and they did save my
life but I could tell you a lot about
the attitude of the Physicians there um
as I go through this HCR um when I get
to line six and um they're talking about
in 1991 New Hampshire was the first
state in the nation to adopt um a
resolution encouraging the use the
clinical trials of myth prisone but I
really don't see that that's anything
that the state of New Hampshire has to
be proud of um the next line line 10 or
down in line 10 there's a statement that
um accessing abortion is Central to
people's ability to participate equally
life I'm not sure what equally means in
this sentence because I'm pretty sure
men aren't able to have babies so if we
were truly equal then that would mean
that men would also be allowed to have
babies and then they would have to make
a decision about how they were going to
participate equally in economic and
social
life as we go down to line
27 um more than 4 million 4
million that's a pretty big number we
have uh commissioned to study um
genocide and the Holocaust in our
committee so I'll just let you stew on
that four million number but four
million women in the country have used
Mis for pry Stone to Ender pregnancy
since
200000 if you do some calculations based
on the population of New Hampshire that
means since 2000 about since the year
2000 about
12,000 women have had abortions in our
state maybe some are repeat whatever to
take the rough
figures
so now I fully realize that no one ever
wants to have an abortion they don't
make this decision lightly but I think
that we can do the women in our state a
much better job if you just think about
the statistics of the numbers of
abortions that have occurred in our
state and of course we don't have the
actual statistics so I have to
extrapolate that from National Data but
that that's a huge number and we talk
all the time about the increasing age of
our population declining School
enrollment decreasing Workforce across
various sectors of the state I think
that New Hampshire has a compelling
State interest to not pass this HCR and
instead encourage women to do the most
important job that only women can do
thank
you would you take
questions I'll try to answer whatever I
can
I see hand representative finny thank
you I just have one question um do you
believe it is the role of the state to
to legislate human uh
reproduction like like should the state
force people to give birth against their
will I actually
don't I think this is a slippery slope
quite honestly
because the more we encourage this
reproductive right which is really the
right to not reproduce I think the state
might take the opposite stance and start
telling people that they should not have
children that their babies aren't worth
it that their job is better
off in a f working in a factory or
something somewhere I think it's a
slippery
slope other
questions representative levit thank you
chair m
so these numbers are pretty big
numbers so this medication is being used
rather
frequently do you have an idea of some
of the states that are using this more
than others and a follow-up question do
you think that
um the bordering
states that have this is something that
could be
you first of all I don't know what other
states are doing in terms of mistone
prescriptions I guess my answer back
would
be do we want to be known as the live
for your die State or the come here to
die
state
other
questions seeing none thank you
much okay I have two names in this card
uh Caleb Montgomery and Liz Canada
um I interpret that as meaning you wish
to uh testify in tandem looks that way
okay and uh you have written testimony
has that been passed
submitted the opposite because it's red
confusing right um thank you H and yes
we're gonna be um testifying together if
if that works for everyone um my name is
Kayla Montgomery I'm the vice president
of public affairs for Planned Parenthood
of Northern New England and Planned
Parenthood New Hampshire action fund um
um so I'm just going to talk a little
bit about Healthcare and the way that um
medication abortion is delivered here in
New Hampshire um and then I'm going to
turn over to my colleague Liz who's
going to talk a little bit more about
the legal landscape in this country so
that is why we um are testifying
together um and I will just say as a
quick note I have been a lobbyist in the
state of New Hampshire for 14 years and
I have never once been before this
committee so this is very exciting for
me thank you for having us it's
wonderful to be here um okay so um we
are here in support of this um
resolution so medication
abortion also known as the abortion pill
it is a safe and effective way to end an
early pregnancy so when we say early
pregnancy that's up to 11 weeks or
another way to say that is 77 days after
the first date of your last Miss period
77 days if you are 78 days you are not
eligible for medication abortion at
Planned Parenthood so serious
complications they happen in less than
onethird of 1% of cases medication
abortion is in fact um safer than common
uh medicines like penicillin and
Viagra at plan parent of Northern New
England we provide medication abortion
at three out of four of our health
centers Manchester and keen and as of
last month in Dairy as well so it is
also an option for some patients via
tella Health with our trained and uh
licensed
clinicians now we say abortion pill but
it's actually a series of five pills
using two different drugs so the first
one is called myph aistone that is the
subject of today's uh resolution the
second one is called misoprostol so the
first one the patient will take one
mistone and that is the drug that blocks
progesterone and that is a hormone that
is needed for
pregnancy and then the patient after
that take the first pill they then take
four misool pills they can insert them
in their cheek and let them dissolve and
that is the drug that empties the
contents of the uterus so this
combination this five pill two drug uh
combination is standard medication
abortion
protocol and we treat medication
abortion the same way that we would
treat a procedural abortion so the
intake procedures the counseling
procedures those are all the same the
difference is that medic abortion the
actual abortion happens in a person's
home whereas in procedural abortion it
happens in our health
centers and this fact has been stated
but one um over five million people in
the United States have used mistone
which has been FDA approved for 20 years
now many patients will choose medication
abortion um nationally that number is
about 50% but here um at Planned
Parenthood of Northern New England that
numberers much higher about 70% of
patients who are seeking abortion choose
medication abortion and they choose
medication abortion over a procedural
abortion for a number of reasons uh most
commonly uh because patients want to be
in the comfort of their own home on
their own schedules some people feel
it's less invasive but it is not for
everyone it's a personal choice and that
is why of course we offer both uh
options at Planned
Parenthood and it is also important to
note that medication abortion and
emergency contraception are not the same
thing so medication abortion again the
subject of today's resolution is taken
to safely end a pregnancy whereas
emergency contraception is one pill and
it's available over the counter and it's
taken after unprotected sex occurs to
make sure that a pregnancy doesn't
happen not the same thing emergency
contraception will not end a
pregnancy and um it was mentioned by the
co-sponsor but I I think it's also worth
um bringing up again that New Hampshire
was indeed the first state in the nation
to adopt a resolution urging the FDA to
allow clinical trials of mea prone and
medication abortion back in 1991 so we
have a long proud history and um I'm
happy to take any questions if not I
Liz great that sounds wonderful so hi
everyone my name is Liz Canada I'm the
advocacy director at plan Parenthood New
Hampshire action fund and Planned
Parenthood of Northern New England so as
Kayla talked about um the subject of
this uh house concurrent resolution is
medication abortion but specifically
mtha prisone which is the first pill
because right now the US Supreme Court
has taken up a case related to myher
sued the FDA over its approval of myph
aistone now the case uses junk science
to allege that mistone was wrongly
approved by the FDA 22 years ago and
it's seeking to remove
mistone from the shelves entirely so
that would impact I've heard the
question come up of what states are able
to use it this case would impact every
state in the country including in New
Hampshire where abortion is legal until
weeks and not just in in New Hampshire
but also in states that have passed
Constitutional Amendments they've
amended their constitution to protect
abortion like our neighbors in Vermont
it would affect them as well the outcome
of this case so the purpose the reason
why these folks have brought this case
is to try to pass a deao um abortion ban
Nationwide they're using this as a
mechanism to take One Way um one method
of abortion Out Of Reach for patients
this is what they are trying to do
through this through this case
specifically so this is an outrageous
attack it's politically motivated it's
instigated and funded by extreme
anti-abortion actors because they are
trying to ban abortion they're trying to
restrict even birth control and so forth
and they're using the courts to do
so now that we are expecting this ruling
from the US Supreme Court to happen
probably in June similar to what we saw
when they overturned roie Wade in 2022
we saw that outcome uh at the end of
June and since that decision came out
over 20 states have banned abortion
outright so in those States and I heard
the prime sponsor say this but I want to
just reiterate in states where abortion
is banned patients cannot access mistone
that is not allowed because it is banned
in their states here in New Hampshire
abortion is safe and legal up to 24
weeks and then we know that there are
exceptions after 24 weeks as well but
mistone is only uh used up till the 11th
week and so this case would impact New
Hampshire where we have a law um that's
affecting abortion later in pregnancy
this is about abortion earlier in
pregnancy so we would really urge you to
pass this resolution and you know let
the uh Federal delegation know you know
send that message from New Hampshire
just as the legislature did in 1991 of
what your commit
to abortion earlier in pregnancy up to
11 weeks and so now I know that there
are questions but I'll I'll stop there
thank
you you know there were questions okay
uh yes you're right there's a question
right there from representative fin I
have two questions if that's okay my
first question is it is it the position
of Planned Parenthood to only offer
abortion or or you know do you ever
encourage a woman to to to carry a
pregnancy to term
so um plan Parenthood along with
um family planning providers um all have
a very uh serious uh intake procedure
that includes counseling it is um by law
but also it is medically accurate and so
all um patients who come in who do for
an abortion whether it's a medication
abortion or whether it is a procedural
abortion whether it is via tella health
or whether it is in the health center
there is a a counseling procedure that
is discussed and all options of what to
do with a pregnancy are discussed at
that counseling okay my other question
is I and I really need an answer to this
from from everybody who's going to
testify do do you believe it is the role
of the state to legislate human
you representative levit thank you chair
legislation by this
house would be subject to the
outcome of the let the litigation in the
Supreme Court I mean it's Common
that thank you for the question I think
I understand the question so the outcome
of this US Supreme Court case will
impact New Hampshire so uh the lower
court um has ruled that medication
abortion MTH aistone the the FDA
approval process should be rolled back
that myth aistone should be more
restricted so right now it's up to 11
weeks that it's available one of the
decisions from the lower court is that
it should only be available until the
sixth week so that would mean that
patients seeking abortion after 6 weeks
before our ban of 24 weeks would not
have myth ayone available to them so yes
it would impact but this is not changing
state law and the 1991 resolution was
also not a state law this is uh the FDA
approval process so it would impact uh
Nationwide um the availability of myth
of
priston
follow follow
up so
again any legislation that is passed by
this house is going to be subject to the
litigation that the Supreme Court passes
or does not pass is that
correct
so are you referring to this resolution
specifically or other perhaps upcoming
uh attempts to restrict
abortion any in all
legislation resolution the
FDA Supreme Court needs to make a
decision on this it seems mute to me
that we pass or do not pass something
that is in court being litigated right
now I mean we spend hours and hours of
committee in um house and subcommittee
and then
the um and I don't want to get into a
debate and then the Supreme Court comes
down and rules against it it's it's kind
of mute so the purpose of this
resolution is to send a message while
waiting for the Supreme Court like that
is the uh uh part of the resolution is
to say while these decisions are stayed
from the lower court waiting for the
Supreme Court to weigh in that this is
the message from New Hampshire of where
ahead I think
you're asking for a lot from
us
because this is something that is
already in an ongoing litigation that
regardless of the outcome
positive or not is going to be
decided by the court
system and I cannot see us going forward
with something that is not going to be
um what the outcome you prefer so I
think that's the value of a house
concurrent resolution that you as a
legislature can say what your position
is on this court case in the in the
first place and I think that's really uh
really fantastic about the New Hampshire
state house and options that you have in
terms of the types of bills and
resolutions that can be introduced is
that you can take that position as a
legislature without uh changing state
law in this
wayes philio thank you Mr chairman if I
may uh two unrelated questions the first
to your knowledge were the house to pass
this HCR would it commit the state or
the house to any action
whatsoever thank you for the question as
far as I know uh no it would be truly a
position and a message that is sent not
just to the federal delegation or to
Congress um but also to your
constituents to let them know where you
stand on abortion early in pregnancy I
feel like there's been a lot of debate
um from the you know recent abortion law
that was passed in 2021 but this is
truly about abortion earlier in
pregnancy so where you stand for your
constituents so as a followup to that
were the Supreme Court to rule against
access to M prone would the state be
involved in any litigation wor the uh
state to pass this
HCR thank you for the question so there
was another lawsuit um happening
simultaneously we sort of referenced it
as the Washington lawsuit New Hampshire
didn't sign on to that so New Hampshire
would be subject to whatever comes out
of the US Supreme Court this resolution
wouldn't impact that in any way thank
you it sounds as though it's fairly low
risk now the second question that I have
regards access to M pistone for Planned
Parenthood and other providers for
individuals who are underinsured or
uninsured how is is uh payment for M
prone
accessed uh thank you for the question I
will not speak for other providers of
course I only represent plant Parenthood
but we provide uh care for people uh
regardless of income we do not turn
people away so if someone needs an
abortion care needs abortion care and
they can't afford it um of course the
state we cannot um use State funds but
um there is some philanthropy available
for people who need um um who need some
extra funding in order to get the care
that they need and again we do not turn
people
away there so Sebert yeah this was kind
of touched on earlier but um I just
wanted to correct me if I'm wrong but
um sorry this bill sends a message to
providers who perform other OBG wein um
you know Services as well am I correct
on that such as you know screenings um
you know and the shortage of doctors
that we already have to perform that
sure so so mistone is used um in other
areas of of reproductive Health Care as
well mostly um miscarriage management so
that is another um situation where it is
um another way to attack reproductive
Health Care outside of the scope of
abortion care certainly I think that's
your question I'm I'm sorry if I didn't
yeah I guess I was just wondering how
many doctors would leave the state um
you know we already touched on that
earlier obviously that there was a
concern about that um in someone's
district and do you have statistics on
how bad that issue that problem is
currently in the state I certainly don't
have statistics in front of me but I
would say anytime that we are
criminalizing um Health Care Providers
it's creating an environment which is
more difficult for them to want to work
and so we you know there is a it is
difficult to recruit uh trained healthc
care providers who are providing
reproductive Health in a rural area and
so um the state being sort of you know
hostile towards Reproductive Rights
including criminalization of doctors who
perform abortion care is certainly not
helpful for um the environment here
okay represent gagy thank you Mr
chairman um if I heard you right you're
not getting any state funding is that
correct that's correct okay so followup
followup thank you uh how much money are
you getting from the federal
funding um so uh planed Parenthood of
Northern New England is a part of the
federal title 10
program and that is a program which was
reestablished under President Biden um
we were not in it during President
Trump's time uh we are now back in the
program it's a um small fund I don't
again I don't have the numbers exactly
in front of me but it is to help
reimburse the cost of seeing patients
who um who do not have access to care
otherwise because they can't afford it
so we are a provider who provides care
to everyone on a sliding scale so if
someone comes to us and they need birth
control we make sure that we're able to
see them and that we can pay for it
regardless of how much they can pay um
in that title T10 that fund has it does
not cover abortion care there is also a
state um pot of funds but we are not in
that because the executive Council
defunded planed Parenthood loping
inequality five times in the last three
years so you're still getting tax funded
from citizens U income tax and stuff
like that is that correct we have some
federal dollars that go to
certain um certain care that is not
included in in abortion funds are not
included in that thank
you and I just want to be clear that's
only Planned Parenthood I'm only
speaking for that that's not every um
Family Planning
provider re fny thank you one last
question I I forgot to mention this um I
don't remember what what we changed in
this state as far as how this gets
prescribed to minors but what is your
policy on on on that I really need to
know yeah so um the law in New Hampshire
is clear around parental notification
for miners so if um if a minor has
parental notification then they can
certainly have an abortion whether it's
um procedural or medication but uh the
notification other
questions thank you for your testim we
certainly U put you to work uh in your
first trip
here
for okay we have a card here from
representative Eric
Turner of
representative thank you chairman Muffet
thank you members of the committee um uh
uh my name is Eric turer from Brentwood
New Hampshire and um Rockingham district
6 and um I hadn't intended I'm a
co-sponsor of this piece of legislation
I hadn't intend to speak but I just kind
of wanted to round out a couple of the
points that had been made today um uh
I'll start off by acknowledging my
wife's an obstetrician gynecologist who
practiced in New Hampshire for 25 years
I'm not a physici uh I do work in public
health specifically around access to
health care for the state and and other
states Ross the country and federally um
so the intersection between my wife's
work and mine is is basically access to
to um Healthcare and specifically in her
case for women um
uh I wanted to make a couple of points
about this that I think sort of broaden
out the discussion um the bill as has
been stated is specifically focused on
the use of M Meer Prestone for
medication abortion that's the language
in the bill um I wanted to point out
that my a pyone is um not just used for
abortion Services it um is used in
combination with M proel as was cited
for uh the treatment of uh early loss of
a pregnancy as well it's not necessary
for that treatment um but it has been
found and I can read you a quote from
the American Academy of family
practitioners um research showing that
it increases the safety and
effectiveness of
um dealing with an uh early pregnancy
loss um and again the the what has taken
place at the federal level is not
specific to its use it was an across
theboard um challenge to whether or not
this drug was properly um uh authorized
by the FDA and I think that's a very
important point that I want to make sure
um comes across um I just also wanted to
correct someone had uh one of the other
Representatives here had mentioned that
there are no medically necessary
abortions I think the the hearing began
with a discussion of ectopic pregnancy
you know I would say there are
definitely medically necessary you know
abortions and ectopic pregnancy would be
one of the most obvious examples of of
that um and again this would be the type
of medication that would be used in in
circumstances like that to my
understanding as a
non-physician um you know and I think
it's important that um that when that
kind of care is provided that it's most
provided in the way that's most safe and
effective um both clinically and from a
cost-effective standpoint so again
another reason why I think uh access to
this medication is is worth us making a
statement and again I I do agree that
this is a an HCR so it is is not going
to be challenged in terms of its
Effectiveness as far as I understand um
it is a statement it is not a law that
can be in conflict with something that
that um that is done at the federal
level
um so just final thing to broaden out
the picture
um I think what's the bigger picture in
this um the reason to make a statement
like this as a state is this is an
example of the court
system stepping into an area that it has
never stepped into as far as I know in
this way before and basically over
ruling um uh an
Administration um agency the FDA in its
findings you know and it's not that they
see something wrong in the short term
this Drug's been available and used
safely for a long time um so it's a I
hate using the term slippery slope but I
will say it can be a slippery slope if
we do not make a statement at this point
um drugs are incredibly effective
they're also incredibly cost costly
they're a huge component of the cost of
our medical system if we go down the
road of blending you know the work of
the FDA to authorize drugs that are safe
and effective that's their standards you
know with
external um parameters that really are
not part of that equation um I don't
know where that ends but it's not in a
good place in my opinion and that's part
of the reason I I signed on co-sponsor
this legislation um and I have to re
respect representative finny's request
that everyone answer the question um no
I do not think um that the the state
should restrict people's Reproductive
Rights um I introduced uh cicr 2 last
year on the on the floor of the house um
which was a broad um uh guarantee of
reproductive Freedom um I do sort of
feel that this aspect of people's lives
and their relationship with their
medical advice that they get around it
is the most deeply held um personal
private expression of freedom and
liberty that we could give to someone
here in the state and so um hope that
question that question was asked earlier
uh thanks for remembering representative
finny's question say us for to call call
on him uh representative levit you mind
taking more questions oh no please
representative levit thank you chair
Mett as a sponsor of this bill were you
aware that there is ongoing litigation
in the Supreme Court yes that that was
actually a major component of why I
signed on to sponsor this bill um but
you know if if they rule against you
it's follow up follow up chair sorry if
they rule against you then there's no
standing there's no standing it's done
so this this litigation I mean this
legislation that we're about to vote on
could have no standing by June July
whatever it comes down that's that's the
fact would you agree with that well I
I'm not a legal expert um in terms of
what is or isn't standing I don't know
and I I tried to say this at the
beginning my impression is that as a
resolution it's more of a statement and
and couldn't be tested against any
particular Federal Regulation or or
decision that you know because it
doesn't carry any weight of Law and
again I'm speaking as though I'm a
lawyer when I'm not um this is our
ability as legislature to say that we
see a
problem um with what's going on at the
federal level and my interest in signing
on to this piece of legislation was to
um essentially make that statement you
know in real time such that um that can
be part of the record in terms of how uh
the federal system and the the Supreme
Court potentially comes down on this so
yeah it it was not an accident or an
overstep it was a purposeful decision I
think this is a very very
important obstacle that needs to be
that's not a question thank you thank
you that's
it representative Philly up would I be
accurate in saying that we do not
require standing to pass this bill
because it's not part of litigation and
even if we were to file an amicus brief
we would have standing because you don't
require standing to file an amicus brief
um again I'm not going to try and and
and weigh in on legal matters in terms
of what does or doesn't constitute
standing but my impression is that that
passing this resolution does not put us
in conflict with any um Federal
decisions that are current or could come
down in the
future we have at least one lawyer on
this committee and when these things
come up um sometimes people look to the
lawyer but I uh I'm going to try not to
do that this is a
hearing uh any other
questions seeing none uh thank you
representative thank you for your time
and thank you for considering this
bill and again this isn't it's it's not
a uh Bill P it's a HCR it's a con host
concurrent
resolution okay uh I have a card here
from Sandra
denor and she is in the house welcome
came all the way from New Market it says
here and you have uh some copies of uh
10 copies
of okay thank you thank you make sure
the clerk gets at least one of those and
I did submit it online as well I didn't
realize how large this committee was
it's my first time in front of this
committee as well um so I apologize for
not having enough copies for everybody
today redundancy is is is important
whenever we were on patrol we'd always
take an extra radio and there you go so
welcome thank you very much good
afternoon honorable committee members um
thank you for accepting my written
testimony both online and here today in
addition to hearing my oral testimony
today in support of a vote of ought to
pass on
hcr1 I'm Sandra denor I'm a registered
nurse in the state of New Hampshire and
the executive director of the lovering
health center in Greenland the lovering
health center is one one of only two
independent nonprofit Health Centers
providing abortion care in New Hampshire
the lovering has been providing abortion
care for New Hampshire citizens for over
40 years the second independent Clinic
is the equality Health Center here in
conquer where they've been providing
abortion care for 50 years we have a
collective 90 years of experience
providing safe evidence-based abortion
care to your
constituents even though we operate in a
perpetually stigmatized and litigated
environment we have managed to see
important advances in abortion care over
this time we now have Decades of
experience providing medically
supervised safe evidence-based
medication abortion including the use of
myth
aistone as it should be in all areas of
Medical Care abortion practice advances
and changes as science data and
experience change as we would expect in
any area of healthc care we can safely
and if we can safely effectively offer a
less invasive option for care we must
when we can avoid invasive procedures
and offer patients an option to manage
their care at home with the support of
their families we should when we can
expand care to Rural and underserved
areas keep costs uh affordable and make
access possible for our lowest income
neighbors and work toward true Equitable
access to Medical Care in New Hampshire
we should today over 50% of our patients
choose medication abortion it's hard to
overstate the importance of medication
abortion in our modern Healthcare
landscape for so many reasons we implore
you to recognize the importance of this
moment the Federal Protection backing up
New Hampshire's consistent bipartisan
commitment to legal abortion care has
ended because New Hampshire citizens and
our elected bipartisan leaders have
chosen to maintain legal abortion care
in New Hampshire we must actively resist
any medically unnecessary restrictions
on medication abortion the current
threats to medication abortion are not
based on best medical practice they're
steps toward undermining our state's
commitment to personal freedom in
medical decision-making our patients
your constituents and New Hampshire's
medical providers need your support and
affirming that we expect decisions for
New Hampshire to be made in New
Hampshire I urge Ur you to vote ought to
pass on hcr1 thank you thank you for
that uh would you take any questions if
there is a pen a floating question uh
from represent finny uh do you mind
answering that I do not mind that's a no
thank
you that's a wonderfully succinct answer
questions Sayan thank you so much thank
you I have two more cards here they both
ask for three minutes
um one is from Lynn Lin painter it might
say MD at the end of that I'm not sure
from conquered is Lynn here yeah is that
MD at the end yes it is Dr Dr Lynn
you good afternoon members of the
committee thank you chair Moffett um
first of all I was asked by my colleague
Dr Randy Hayes to bring you a written
copy of testimony that he was unable to
sub MIT online so please don't use this
as part of my three minutes I'm giving
Randy Hayes's testimony I'll give that
to the clerk at the end
um but thank you for hearing my
testimony today um as you said my name
is Lynn Lind paintner I'm a retired
doctor from conquered I'm strongly in
support of the
hcr1 and as I see it this resolution
really offers you an important
opportunity to continue we've heard
about this wise and even very bold
tradition of bipartisan support for
medication abortion early in pregnancy
and beyond that to send an important
message of support for the authority and
the mission of the federal of the Food
and Drug Administration which is my main
point to talk to you about today I'm not
an
obstetrician uh I am an internal
medicine doctor and before I was a
doctor I was a family planning nurse in
the
1970s so I've counseled lots of women
who had questions about pregnancy and
options related to their pregnancies
I've always included legal abortion as
part of the information that I've been
given my patients and in those
conversations I have learned so much
I've learned about the multitude of
personal circumstances which led some of
the women I counseled to choose
abortion I learned that abortion is an
absolutely necessary element of taking
care of women's
health and that it is
literally impossible and certainly
inappropriate to try to craft
legislation in this area in answer to
the anticipated question I do not
believe that legislation has any role in
reproductive Health Care this is far too
nuanced and far too personal a matter
matter um I do know a lot about the FDA
as an internist believe me I have
prescribed lots of
medicines that's what we do I've relied
on guidance from the Food and Drug
Administration so that I could be
confident my patient care conformed to
best medical practices you see the FDA
has a very rigorous process prior to
approving a medicine and after that
medicine is prove they continue to
collect reports about what happens to
people who take the medicine so safety
ongoing safety is very much their
mission they get reports and case
reports from doctors all over the
country um Nations around the world
emulate the standards of drug safety set
by the FDA making it a global Authority
and this case that we're talking about
today past uh that's coming to the
Supreme Court is really
threatening our access to safe medicines
in a in a much greater and broader sense
if one medicine can be denied um that is
safe effective and needed uh we could we
could lose access to more we shouldn't
lose track of that so as you consider
hcr1 please keep in mind the stature of
this important Federal agency whose
mission and Authority I consider very
important certainly to my practice and
have um I do want to take you back to
1991 for a moment when having a legal
abortion in the United States meant you
had to have a surgical procedure there
was no non-surgical option in general if
you ask a person would you rather have a
surgical procedure or take some pills
you're generally going to hear a lot of
people prefer the pill option not
everyone but it's an important option
and um at the time 1991 there were no
such options in the United States States
but in France and in China there were
there were medicines being used safely
to non-surgically induce abortion under
Reagan and Bush these were not allowed
in the states the FDA was barring
importation in of these drugs which
included meph Prestone the one we're
talking about today the majority of
Americans who have always supported
abortion access disagreed vehemently and
I do have more to say about this that
I'm going to give you in my written
testimony cuz I know that my time is
short but I'm going to summarize here
and say that the nation listened to New
Hampshire when the Republican dominated
New Hampshire General Court in a
bipartisan manner adopted the first
resolution specifically urging the FDA
to permit Research into medication
abortion um the nation listened and
today as we've heard these non-surgical
safe Alternatives offer privacy and
convenience
and are used widely and with confidence
we should never be in a position where
judges in Texas decide that Granite
Staters can't get safe effective drugs
please condemn in no uncertain terms all
politically motivated intrusion into the
valuable work of the FDA by voting ought
to pass on hcr1 thank you very much for
hearing my testimony and I would be
willing to answer questions if I'm
able
uh represent Finny the question that you
wanted again if you could repeat oh so
you you handled that up front Okay uh
anything else representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you
doctor for taking my question do they
still do the hypocritic oath when in the
in the medical you know I was reading up
about that because I thought this might
come up um there's several Hippocratic
Oaths they're used in some medical
schools not all and there's different
versions so sometimes isn't there one
that says first Do no harm there
certainly
is so full disclosure I'm in favor of
abortion to save the life of the
mother however for me my personal
opinion is that an abortion that is not
necessary to save the life of the mother
is the taking of an innocent human life
you can take that to the bank
well if that's a question I I would
respond that you said a very important
thing when you said in my personal
opinion and you and any woman who feels
the same should definitely not have to
have an
abortion absolutely this is a personal
questions thank you Dr Lynn Dr Ry Hayes
actually is one of my constituents I
spoke with him at linked on the phone
last night and uh he's also sent me some
information that yes if you could pass
that that would be
great okay I I have uh one final pink
card at this time uh Maya Wilson is Maya
here she is from conquered representing
herself in support of the bill and you
have did you distribute copies of
testimony as well uh yeah I have some
yeah it did it did say had 20 copies so
uh welcome
those good afternoon I am Morgan Wilson
I'm a resident of conquered speaking in
support of of HR
hcr1 everyone deserves access to the
care they need when they need it
everyone deserves control over their
life their body and their story and
today I'd like to share my story with
you I took my first pregnancy test
during a lunch break from
work I hadn't seriously confronted the
possibility that I might actually be
pregnant but then the accusatory double
lines on the first test and the same on
the second taken only minutes later as I
crouched on the tile floor in my
fluorescent lit dorm bathroom furiously
Googling false positive pregnancy tests
hoping Beyond hope that it was a
fluke it
wasn't I went back to work to finish out
the day with the irrevocable knowledge
that a process had begun Within Me
Gathering momentum
when I found out I was pregnant I was
making minimum wage living in oncampus
housing and still had no clue what my
next step would be after my fellowship
ended in nine months I did not know
where I would be living what I wanted to
do with my life what career I was
interested in but I did know that I
didn't want to be
pregnant this was one area of my life
where the path forward was absolutely
clear I made an appointment at Planned
Parenthood to confirm my pregnancy as
quickly as possible at this point I was
6 weeks along and then I made an
appointment for the abortion which had
to be two weeks
out every single day I had to exist as a
pregnant person was a struggle just the
physical experience of being pregnant
was
horrifying my body was not my own it was
sore tired and sick while a wanted
pregnancy can be a magical thing this
experience truly showed me that no one
should be pregnant if they do not want
to be it was a complete and total loss
of control my body felt like it was at
odds with me tormenting me the pregnancy
and its consequences were all consuming
I felt terrible I performed terribly at
work and I didn't see most if any of my
friends I had a medication abortion so I
took one pill at the health center and
then the next ones later that night at
home when I woke up the next morning a
great weight had been lifted and my body
was still
the sense of momentum had calmed and for
the first time in weeks time stretched
forward freely no looming and dreaded
deadline approaching with every second
that passed I felt at home in my body
and at home in my
life I am eternally grateful for my
abortion everything in my life now that
I have worked for a career I'm
passionate about the graduate degree I'm
in the process of earning wouldn't have
been possible without my abortion I want
every person to have the options I had
with when I needed them I don't want
anyone to be trapped in the suffocating
feeling of an unwanted
pregnancy I urge you to support hcr1
which is a concrete action the state can
do to show support for medication
abortion access in New
Hampshire pure and simple my abortion
gave me my life back I was able to write
my own story the way I wanted and that's
what we are fighting for for the right
of people everywhere to control the
trajectory of their very lives that's
what I want to protect
time thank you for your testimony thank
you very much um I know that uh Ronin is
kind of a standing question uh do you
remember what he was looking for
responses
to uh yeah you wanted to know if I
thought the uh state government had any
right to interfere in people's right to
reproduce I'll I'll phrase it for you do
you believe it is the role of the state
to to to legislate or to otherwise you
know you know to regulate human uh uh
reproduction
questions seeing none uh thank you again
you okay I see no more pink
and okay we do have one one more pink
card coming this way
um from a Committee Member
representative tol from Kee uh welcome
you were already here but uh welcome
anyway yeah um so thank you so much my
name is Amanda Elizabeth tol and I um
this is I've served on this committee
for three years and um I've testified at
many hearings before but this is
actually my first time testifying
without having a written statement and
thinking I was going to testify and
testifying on the spot and I just feel
it's so important to speak to this issue
um and to humanize this issue because
it's a one where people have very very
strong feelings and it's very easy to
judge I think until you've walked in
someone's shoes and so I was moved by
the last speaker and um Wanted to add to
that so um I grew up in Manchester New
Hampshire in a Jewish Family I went to
marac Valley Hebrew Elementary School um
my family played a critical role in the
founding of Temple Israel in Manchester
I went to Camp gone Israel with Rabbi
krinsky who's LED um the prayer here in
the past and um I consider myself a
woman of faith and when I was a teenager
I had an unplanned
pregnancy and it was a hard decision but
it was the right decision for me to
terminate that pregnancy I ended up
going on to college graduate school I
got a Masters in
Education um I was uh the Harold
grinspoon 2010 recipient of the Jewish
educator of the Year award which is a
very prestigious award in the Jewish
community Community um for my work
teaching social studies and um now I'm
expecting my third baby I brought my son
Jordy um who everyone on this committee
knows very well um to every um day of
session last year I didn't miss a single
day of um session he came with me from
when he was a week old and um I I so
some of my colleagues have asked like
does this matter and I would say it does
matter because it's standing in
solidarity with people who have needed
this care and I can't emphasize enough
how important that is with this Critical
Care being under
attack
and we know that Granite sters
regardless of political party and
persuasion are overwhelmingly pro-choice
and I think in large part that's because
everyone knows and loves someone who has
needed this care last week I was at a
different um hearing that related to
abortion and one of um my Republican
colleagues who she doesn't agree with me
on anything like guns and we have very
different opinions on political issues
but she got up and she shared her story
um and offered a republican pro-choice
perspective um recently in the Keen
Sentinel we saw um a letter to the
editor by John winter um who was the
former Vice chair of the Walpole
Republicans and um was the Republican
candidate for Walpole saying his
pro-choice stance and I
just think that this issue it trans
sends party lines because this is about
our private medical decisions this is
about our freedom our civil liberties
the sanctity of the patient provider
relationship and so um I am asking you
my colleagues to please support hcr1
much would you take any questions if
there are any sure are there any
questions represent Sebert I would just
like to thank you for getting up there
and telling your story it's very brave
and courageous and I'm in the same boat
as you when I was 21 I had an unan
pregnancy it's was with my boyfriend but
now he's my husband so um you know I I
in the same boat except for the three
kids Lov her heart she's here today so
but thank you for telling your story and
thank you for telling yours and helping
humanize this issue thank
you to representative finny's question
um do do you remember would you repeat
that for representative to to respond to
please do you believe it is the role of
the state to regulate human reproduction
no I do not thank you other
questions seeing none uh thank you
represent to thank you and with no more
pink cards I'm going to wield the gav
with this
time now uh we uh are going to take a
brief re recess for about 5 minutes uh
or so approximately 5 minutes I'd like
the uh folks on the red team the
Republicans to have a very quick caucus
in the committee office uh five minutes
and uh uh Madam ranking member uh you
have uh five minutes or so with your
folks if you need it and I'm going to
turn off my uh my microphone we'll we'll
five
for
minutes
okay looks like we have a full house
roll okay folks uh let's get this uh
started uh I think we can go through
most of these uh fairly quickly but you
never know all right uh first one that
we're going to take up on Executive
session today is cacr 20 that was the
succession measure measure to suceed if
the debts hit
trillion representative toll I'm heard
one wait I I'm so sorry I'm I'm lost oh
yeah yeah I I moved to itl would okay
the motion on the floor on cacr 20 is
itl from uh representative toll is there
a second uh representative Gagney uh
seconds that and uh
represent to would you care to speak to
your
motion sure um I think the vast majority
of us regardless of political party
thinks seceding from the union is bad
for the State of New Hampshire and it's
not what the majority of our
constituents would want and so that's
why I'm moving
this thank you representative
representative gagy you made the second
do you have uh would you like to speak
dit okay uh
other other uh comments or input on uh
20 um okay seeing none we will uh go
right to the clerk and we will call the
20 representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative bone yes representative
levit yes representative nter yes
representative gadney yes representative
ponti yes representative finny hi
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative carrye yes representative
tol yes representative rung yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal representative Sebert yes
representative F filio
yes well the
chairman chair votes yes okay
representative mfet votes yes it is
unanimous so that is a uh 20 to zero
vote for
itl uh representative toll typically as
you probably know being a veteran of
this committee um the person who makes a
a motion oftentimes does a report uh can
we look to you for that sure okay or we
can we'll figure that out but uh
speaking of reports uh be there is a a
recommendation from the U from
leadership that before anybody leaves
who has a report that they give it to
the chair that's not how I'm going to do
business especially on a Friday
afternoon I would ask that whoever is
doing reports I have several be doing
myself I suspect uh if you could get
them to me electronically by uh Sunday
evening say uh 1800 hours 6 o'clock okay
is
that representative toll gives a big
thumbs up and so that sounds like we got
a plan all right uh next uh consent on
that uh consent um is there any
objection to consent sometimes on
resolution this is not resolution it was
a cacr uh sometimes in resolutions they
have to go to the full body but um I
believe consent works on a cacr or it I
may have to check with the
parliamentarian on that cacr may have to
come to a floor vote I will check uh put
that on consent uh
representative okay representative bone
says let them worry about it for the
record all right so it's not consent
barring uh a uh
parliamentary
requirement okay HB 1130 that is the
measure to create a a commission to look
at uh Dynamics surrounding the the
secession uh concept for New Hampshire
representative massila uh do you have a
motion
here okay we're looking for a mo we're
looking for representative cbrt yeah I
would like to motion to itl okay we have
a motion from representative cert to I
Mr chairman Mr chairman which which one
11:30 should be shouldn't it be 10 I I
I'm I'm going through these in my own
order okay thank
you no uh I'm going through these in the
order that I want to
because he's the boss and and part of
the reason for that that is uh some of
these I I think you never know a little
easier than others i' like to get the
ones that that perhaps might be easier
done
earlier Mr chairman I think the member
withdraw through a motion uh which
member representative cber uh so
represent CRA you're not motioning itl
that I yeah you thought I think you
thought it was the bill onty okay this
is 11:30 is uh H it's a bill HB 1130 as
I said this is on the uh the measure to
to establish a commission to look at the
secession Dynamics for New Hampshire
massamilla i' like to itl okay
representative uh massam Miller motions
itl in expedient to Liber uh to to
liberate to uh legislate on hb130 and do
we have a
second represent philio thank you uh for
that second represent filio am I saying
that correctly representative yes thank
you uh so representative Mass do you
1130 and the second on that again was
representative philio uh would you like
to speak to your
second sure uh as I mentioned in the
hearings on this I think that the state
lacks the power to consider this anyhow
given uh previous Supreme Court
president and since the state likely
doesn't have the power to secede
regardless of what the study commission
anyhow thank
you okay other comments uh anything else
uh representative Manion go ahead yeah
uh so the one thing I would say is like
when this measure the secession has come
before the committee before a lot of
people was like there's a lot of
unanswered questions so I understand the
message behind the bill it's like well
if you have a lot of unanswered
questions form a committee and figure it
out but I'm that's just my input on
this thank you I saw their intent as
comments seeing none then uh Madame
clerk uh let us go to the role again on
the itl motion of uh on HB
1130 okay itl motion representative
Rollins yes representative lungren yes
representative bone yes representative
levit hi representative nter yes
representative gagy yes representative
ponti yes representative finny
representative Manion representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative car yes representative
tol yes representative rung yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal representative Sebert yes
representative Philo yes that is and oh
oh chair chair votes yes yes I so that's
know and that is that yes uh represent
P okay I was going to uh say without
objection this being an HB uh consent
calendar consent calendar it is madam
clerk okay y okay the next measure that
we will take up in exact session is HCR
house concurrent resolution 10 and that
has to do with u the resolution asking
calling calling for uh Washington to pay
the share of special ed cost that they
were expected to pay uh based on earlier
promises and legislation but be before
we look for a a motion I see
representative Pani hand up thank you Mr
chair I was listening to the recordings
for these if you don't use the
microphones you can't hear your vote
okay so just keep that in mind I would
think that might that would be helpful
so when you're making your motions or
when you're speaking if you could uh
because uh this is public we want people
to be able to hear your yay or nay thank
you representative
pman so back to hcr1 DC funding for
special ed that again uh we all have the
measure in front of us or in our folders
that was the resolution calling on uh
the feds F federal government to pay the
share of special ed funding that they
had indicated that they would long
ago uh representative Massa Miller uh I
have a note here that you may have a
motion yes I do I recommend a to
pass okay the motion from representative
Massa Miller is OTP ought to pass on
acr10 and looking for a second from
second second is from uh represent car
uh okay rip and Miller would you care to
speak to your OTP motion yes I would on
a personal note I was an elementary
teacher and a High School varsity
basketball coach for several years and
um I know what happens when you have a
family that moves in with five children
three of whom are and this is midy year
and three of them have a spe special ed
um itinerary and two of those were moved
out of state for their special ed
services and that absolutely devastates
a local school board budget so that's
why I'm voting on to pass because the
government had agreed years ago they
were going to contribute 40% to special
ed and they have not um fulfilled their
obligation I think it's time we put them
on notice thank
you representative K you were on a
school board uh is the person who made
the second do you want to uh speak to
your second oh ju just briefly I've
spent 18 years on a public school board
s years on a charter school board uh
roughly 25% of our population is special
ed the government funds roughly 16% of
the 40% they promised to provide so
there is a a gap and I hope they will
honor their agreement and fill that
Gap I'm thank you representative other
thoughts other comments on this HCR
representative bom sure yes thank you
I've been was on education committee for
14 of my six 12 of my 16 years anyway
yeah this has always been the issue and
like represent Carrie said they promised
they got the law passed saying they were
going to give
40% and and over the years I've been
here it's been 16 to 20 I mean they they
got law passed at 40 and they've
been neglect on their own law So yeah
thank
you thank you representative other
questions seeing none uh Madame clerk uh
let's uh have a roll call uh on the
motion of OTP with regard to HCR 10
representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative bone yes representative
levit
I representative nder yes representative
gagy yes representative
panti yes representative finny yes
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative carry yes representative
tol representative rung yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal yes representative Sebert yes
representative philio
yes and the chair chair votes yes so
nothing and on
consent yes if that's if if it's
allowable for HCR to be on consent um we
we'll uh submit it on
consent they'll correct us if if if
there needs to be a specific floor vote
we'll be they'll they'll let us
know okay uh great okay next up is hr20
that's the resolution in support of
Taiwan that happens to be the one that I
was the uh sponsor for or the sponsor of
I'm I'm going to make an OTP motion on
on my own
resolution I'll second
it thank you representative Rollins uh I
will speak to it
um uh those of you in committee uh heard
me or if you were not here you had the
chance to look at the uh the Youtube and
uh this resolution of support simply uh
listed the reasons why I felt or many of
us feel that Taiwan uh needs to know
that uh there are people that are
keeping an eye on what's happening in
East Asia uh Taiwan just is perhaps the
most vibrant freest democracy in East
East Asia they just had an election last
Saturday uh a free
election and uh besides the the the idea
or the notion that we want to support
democracy um there's also uh profound um
economic reasons with the the microchip
issue and the trade issue and I
mentioned uh we do a New Hampshire does
a quarter of a billion dollar uh trade
um business with Taiwan so anyway those
are some of the highlights from my
testimony uh and I I hope the committee
will join me in in uh supporting this
resolution of support for the Republic
of China
Taiwan uh representative Rollins you you
did second that uh would you care to
speak to your second no I think this is
pretty cut and dry thank
you uh other uh comments questions uh
okay representative bone yeah thank you
um right now the
Taiwanese consider them 80% of the
Taiwanese consider themselves Taiwanese
they don't consider themselves Chinese
anymore so I think why we should support
this thank you representative uh
representative Manion I I support the
democracy and I love the free trade I
just don't if they come under attack I
do not think we should be committing
defense okay other comments questions
representative
filio this is going to be a conf
statement but I agree with all of the
statements that have been previously
made and I will be voting no simply
because I don't believe that the state
should be involved uh in international
matters and should be expressing support
on International matters either way it
is simply an expression of what I think
the limits of state power is rather than
reg an opinion on Taiwan one way or the
another fully support actually the
statements have been made but I think we
need to be cognizant of what state power
is thank you representative uh
representative uh levit thank you chair
mord I think this is a small support
taiwan's thank you representative
representative
shiff thank you Mr chairman I've talked
to friends on my side of the aisle and I
know they're going to vote against it
but I've had the pleasure of being to
Taiwan twice in the last 10 years and
I've got tremendous respect for the
Taiwanese especially now with what the
confrontation they're having from the
People's Republic of China and uh be
voting for
it thank you representative other
comments uh representative fny uh thank
you um like we do with the guard with
the state partnership program I I don't
I don't like like we sponsor El Salvador
and I've been Del Salvador a couple
times to do some humanitarian uh you
know stuff when I was still in the
military um we already have a
partnership that has an economic impact
in the state I don't see anything wrong
with just affirming our friendship um as
long as we're not you know committing
arm in case of armed conflict
with you know with the mainland China I
don't see why we couldn't support it
so thank you reprentative
other
comments seeing none uh let us again go
to the role Madam uh clerk the motion is
OTP on
hr20 so representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes represent bom
yes representative lit i i i
representative
gagy oh nter representative n yes
representative gagy yes representative
puman yes representative finny yes
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative Carrie yes representative
tol representative rung yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal NE yes representative Sebert yes
representative
Philo not
okay and representative
mofet
yes
consent uh representative shli move
consent uh if there are no objections to
Zer Mr chair uh yes um I I asked the
house clerk if hcrs can go on consent if
it's unanimous and he confirmed that
they can oh thank you did you did you
just text them yeah thank you I I owe
you
one so that this that can go on consent
um that uh representative rang was at uh
HRS
no to 60% vote of the house yeah I said
do hcrs with a unanimous OTP OTP vote
have to go to the floor for a vote or
can they go on consent and he said they
can go on consent so I only asked
relative to hcrs but I can ask I think
that
that's what I thought and the speaker am
Meritus uh I'm going to trust him on
that
because boy you're bra you
are okay I will do the uh I will do the
report on on that one um it doesn't look
like there'll be a Minority Report and
uh rep so the first measure
representative toll um the next two
measures the reports will come to me
from uh representative Mela or uh
whoever as long as Somebody by 6:00 on
Sunday whether you are somebody sends me
the report by Sunday night um there are
no minority reports
yet okay moving ahead uh to HB 1179 Park
fees for veterans there's an amendment
for this that has been passed out the
amend excuse me the amendment uh was uh
submitted by representative levit it's
uh um
H uh representative L would you care to
speak to your proposed amendment yes
thank you chair so I would like the
committee to adopt the amendment to the
original Bill HB
11179 clearly states that any spouse or
unmarried surviving spouse of a retired
member of the Armed Forces will have
access access to um State um parks and
residency is there a is there do we have
a second for that okay so the amendment
was submitted by representative levit he
just spoke to it uh representative pman
seconded it uh I have a a question on
the C
uh the amendment doesn't address this
would involve an increased
cost or loss of revenue for the state
did did you get an estimate of what that
might add up to so after careful
consideration um in not being able to
estimate correctly the cost of having a
Massachusetts
resident use have access we decide to go
with strictly a New Hampshire resident
and that came up to
$5,600 thank thank you so the the C the
cost in terms of loss Revenue was
estimated you said 5600 5600 yes that's
correct okay thank thank you for for
providing that ref and Pimon uh
seconding motion do you have anything to
add or
thank you Mr Speaker I yeah I just think
it's a a good gesture to include the
spous I know if I didn't include my
spouse I would be somewhere
else like on that couch or something you
know but um I I just go for I think it's
a great idea thank you representative
representative shortliffe thank you Mr
chairman with all due respect to the
sponsor uh I'm going to vote against
this um I think it's similar to our New
Hampshire veterans license plates and
that's always been a bone of contention
because when the veteran dies the
surviving spouse has to give up that
plate and I think it's something of this
magnitude uh I'd rather have the member
bring it back as a bill in the next
session so it can be invited by the full
committee before we make a decision of I
support the bill but I think the
amendment um tic come back is a bill on
its own thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative question representative
rung yes thank you Mr chair um I I have
two questions actually one on the
amendment um are children included of
retired military or is it just
spouses no again the um estimated cost
um could not be correctly
formulated and in order to get this done
we figure the spouse is uh the most
accessible individual to the
retirement uh to the retired um
Personnel okay so children aren't
included then recovery no they're not
okay um and then um Mr chair one other
question um I serve on the resources
Recreation and development committee and
um we we have heard all the bills
regarding State Park fees I was
wondering is this going to that
committee question was would the second
committee for this be rrd
uh actually I I also wondered at one
point early on why this did not go to
rrd but I think it's because it's it's a
veteran related uh measure so it came to
the veterans committee um I do not
anticipate it going to
rrd uh leadership could make it could go
to finance uh because there is a small
Financial component so to the best of my
knowledge at this time uh I do not see
it going to ird um it may go to finance
uh but that's a call leadership would
make uh Mr Speaker amus do you have any
thoughts on that um it could go to a
second I think you'd know by now if it
was a second committee Bill and as far
as going to finance normally the
threshold is at least 10,000 uh cost to
the state so I think Finance would wave
it off if it should pass thank you for
that um so that kind of answers the
finance committee option not likely rrd
I I don't haven't heard don't anticipate
um that's a good question and uh if if
the does if leadership does want it to
go there they'll I'll I'll ask we'll
find that out thank you Mr chair one
other just a comment is the bills that
we've heard um and every year we have
bills where the state parks come in and
and testify and they're operating on a
shoestring right now I think actually
they're in the red and they're supposed
to be a self-sustaining division so um I
am concerned concerned about any even
though it seems like it's a low number
um that's money that's going to come
from somewhere else in their budget so I
just want members to be aware of that
when they're voting on this that it's
it's a really feel-good bill um I I am
the daughter of a man who uh spent his
career in the military so I I understand
the sacrifice that they make and their
spouses make and their kids make too but
um I think from a a finance perspective
I I would have preferred if this goes to
resources or or to a study where we
could really look at the cost of this in
relation to the entire Park's budget
thank you like to comment on that U yes
go ahead uh represent LE so this was
brought up when we had um discussed the
amendment and we were um able to squeeze
it as much as possible as far as costs
that's why there was no other
um residents other than New Hampshire
and also there were no children so I
don't see the advantage of this um being
um not OTP because it's always going to
come down to what is the
least effective and cost to get this
done and this is what we came up
with
representative sherff just to follow up
in our discussion on if this was going
to resources if it was going to
resources Mr chairman you'd have been
told already it was the second committee
Bill and to take it up early to get it
out of committee so I believe this will
be the one and only hearing on it
correct and I have not heard anything so
thank you for that uh other comments
discussion okay we have a an amendment
motion on the floor which is to amend
0192 uh so the motion is OTP on a to
pass on the amendment um Madame clerk
when you're ready representative Rollins
yes representative lungren yes
representative B yes representative Le
levit i i i representative ner yes
repres represenative gagy yes
representative puman yes representative
finny I representative Manion yes
Representative shirtliff no
representative Mass Miller no
representative Jack no representative
Carrie yes representative
tol representative rung no
representative Lloyd no representative
O'Neal no representative
okay so one two three four five oh the
chair chair votes yes they should put
your name down at the
[Laughter]
bottom on your behalf I would never want
passes okay the amendment hav't passed
uh I'm looking for a motion of uh it
would be OTP on the amended on the on
the bill as
amended and it is a bill it's HB
1179 yes I'd like to make that
motion motion is OTP is amended by
representative levit and a second second
second is from representative
schliff uh representative L would you
motion again this was well thought out
and we had uh taken into consideration
the cost but I think more importantly
okay um having
um someone with you being able to um
have access is probably the most
practical thing in this Bill thank
you sherff no only to say that I think
you know uh being a veteran myself and
respecting those who have served our
country whether in peace time and War I
think it's a good gesture and I just
want to show the solidarity of this
committee and support of
it thank you representative other
questions uh representative R yeah I
just want to reiterate U my concern that
we're cutting Revenue without any
explanation of where how that's going to
be made up are we going to increase fees
someplace else or what part in the
budget of the division of state parks is
going to be cut to make up for this but
like I said I am a military brat and um
I have a lot of respect for people
who've served in for our country um
whether they're active duty or retired
so I will be in solidarity but I I do
want that to be noted thank you thank
you representative
um f just added one other thing uh we're
getting this bill out early getting it
out in January if you wanted to talk to
Chairman Rulo there'd be still time to
make it a second committee Bill if his
committee would want to look at it as a
courtesy to him yeah thank you
representative actually the the
researcher who who has some knowledge
here indicated she just whispered in my
ear that this may be something that will
be required to uh Christina go ahead and
it's
okay thank you Christina that could you
could tell that we were wrestling with
that and now we've now the wrestling
match is over and we know we have an
answer thank
you okay uh so that that clarifies uh
representative r that kind of speaks to
your this is an early bill that would go
to a second committee and anything
else okay seeing no other hands uh
Madame MC clerk uh this would be the OTP
motion on OTP is amended for HB 1179
okay representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative bone yes representative
levit I representative nder yes
representative gagy yes representative
pimonte yes representative finny yeah
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative Carrie yes representative
tol yes represent representative rung
yes representative Lloyd yes
representative O'Neal yes representative
Sebert yes representative Philo
yes and the
chair chair votes yes that's 20 to
nothing
consent yes so any objection to consent
if uh there is a second committee thing
uh looming out there but uh we can ask
for consent for this I will do the
report on it unless representative l
wants to
um yes I'd like to do that chair okay uh
if you can do the get the report to me
uh by 1,800 hours on
Sunday wow what is time is that chair
that would be uh 6:00 pm Army
time
see you know I am Army so I I didn't get
you what about time uh Zulu time uh that
that's uh i'' have to work on that I
should know better we we'll get back to
that uh on that represent short
live okay uh all right moving right
along uh HB 1355 a bill uh not a
resolution New Hampshire National Guard
recruitment bonus uh I Look to
representative Massa Miller again for
possible motion um thank you Mr chair
and I recommend a to
pass second that so the
SEC second I will second that Mr
chairman thank you so the motion of uh
OTP on HB 1355 is from representative
mam Miller with a second from
representative gagy represent M Miller
would you speak to your OTP motion yes
um we heard from several different
military departments including the
department of milit military Affairs uh
and veteran services they are in favor
of this bill um like a lot of other
employers they are having a hard time
recruiting people and they felt the
incentive program would help to solve
that
problem thank you representative
represent
gagy sure very quickly back in I think
it was 1965 they started offering these
big bonuses and I and U I got out in 6
and I was seriously thinking of taking
the $66,000 bonus for reenlisting except
when I talked to the wife at the time
she says stay stay there if you want to
instead and history was changed thank
you thank you rep gagy anything else on
other comments on on this
measure okay uh seeing none on the OTP
motion on HB
1355 uh Madame Clark representative
Rollins yes representative Lungen yes
representative B yes representative
levit yes representative nder yes
representative gagy yes representative
ponti yes representative PNY yes
representative Manion yes representative
shirle yes representative Massa
representative Jack yes representative
carry yes representative tol yes
representative rung yes representative
Lloyd yes representative O'Neal yes
representative cber yes representative
philio yes that is the chairperson's
vote thank you Madam C the chair votes
yes okay that's 20 to nothing any
objection to consent on this house
bill okay no it's not an early bill or
it doesn't need a second committee so
that should be good to go uh on consent
thank you um NE in the uh report uh
representative Mass Mill having made the
motion if you or or someone um that if
you or someone can get me something by
18800 hours 6m on Sunday and I will take
it from
there okay next up is uh another HB HB
1338 this was the measure that had to do
with uh The Selective
Service and I'm looking for a motion um
uh rson Manion do you you looking to
make a motion on this yeah I'd like to
make a motion to OTP motion of ought to
pass on
1338 uh is there a second representative
finny seconds that um okay
representative me would you care to
speak to your OTP motion uh yes so this
is a one of my bills it's going against
the Selective Service Act it had three
components one was a simple
nullification saying that we wouldn't
help the federal government enforce The
Selective Service Act within our
boundaries uh I am fearful that the
federal government is moving us head
headlong into like many multif front
Wars potentially and I do not want to
see our the Next Generation get dragged
into conflicts that don't have anything
to do with the United States directly um
we've been lied into Iraq we spent 20
years in Afghanistan most veterans don't
from those conflicts don't think they
were worth it ultimately I don't think a
uh front a war against either uh China
or uh Russia potentially Iran if some
people win the presidential nomination
uh these would be beneficial to the
United States overall the second part of
this bill was a removal of a uh
restriction of if you want to apply to a
um state college you'd have to be first
registered with Selective Service I
don't think that should be a
prerequisite to go into education I
don't understand why that's even in RSA
it's been there since 99
uh and then the third part was simply uh
when you register for the draft as part
of the uh when you get your license as I
just added a check box that said uh I
register as a um conscientious objector
even though that's not the correct
process I think it's important to send
that's thank you representative
represent finny this you made the
seconding motion um I would just add
that uh we you know we don't want to
encourage Force conscription um you know
we do have an volunteer Force we should
keep it that
way thank you representative um I'm let
me weigh in just a little bit on this uh
I I I'm on a of a different mind on this
I I think this is a vot your conscience
measure uh as all measures should be um
I
uh I understand the message you you
mentioned sending a message I understand
that message I I'm somewhat supportive
of that message but um
the reason we've kept selective service
is just in case uh just in case there
there's a need for people if we
dismantle that system then uh I'm
concerned that if that need ever came up
that we uh would be stuck without a
mechanism or process to get people that
we might need I know there's a lot of
pieces to this you know males females
type uh so I I have uh I have questions
in a in a problem with the OTP motion
again that's me I know uh again this is
a vote your conscience uh I the draft
was eliminated in 1973 just as I turned
18 uh and at the time I was pleased and
who knew that uh nine years later I join
the Marines on my own and and get 25
years in as active in reserve uh also
not that this affects this bill in 1973
the New Hampshire legislature and its
wisdom Lo the drinking age to 18 on June
1st the day after I turned 18
so timing is everything they get rid of
the draft and they lower the drinking
age and uh and then uh anyway that's
that's where I am on that I I it's going
to be hard for me to support that other
thoughts or representative uh who's okay
represent M
Miller um my concern is that you have
the box of conscientious objector but
people don't understand that in order to
be exactly that there is a whole process
that you have to go through you have to
go to your local board you have to
present information either documentary
or with a a person attesting to your way
of life that supports that conscientious
obor and then if you want to appeal you
have another set and I think it it makes
it seem too simple that people don't
realize there is a process and that
process isn't in indicated on this so
that's why I'll be voting against it but
thank
you other representative
p uh thank you Mr chair and um I I have
some concerns about this myself but it's
almost like we're putting the horse in
the cart in front of the horse here if
we have a conflict you you want to be
able to rely on the system we have in
place now not something that the
conflict happens and we have to rely on
something new or not in existence so I I
just uh I have some real concerns with
that I think that that's that I I I will
not
support than thank you
representative other
comments oh uh representative tol so um
I I just want to say that like I I'm
leaning
towards supporting this because um I I'm
an anti I consider myself in general
whenever conflict can be avoided it
should be and um conscientious obors
should be supported but because Linda
brings up um rep mamillo some really
important concerns I I I would really
like to see this amended on the floor um
and so I I I'm are you willing to do
that great then I'm willing to vote for
it representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman if I understood the speaker
correctly there is a change to driver
licensing and if that's the case it
should come with funding to make the
change to the computer system that they
checkbox
okay
hands see seeing none uh the motion is
OTP um and Madame clerk will uh vote on
that motion okay representative Rollins
no Representative lungren no
representative bone no representative
levit I'm a go repres that yes yes it is
okay Representative nder no
Representative gagy no Representative
pimonte no representative finny yes
representative Manion yes Representative
shirtliff no representative Mass Miller
no representative Jack no
representative Kerry uh no
representative
tol yes representative rung no
representative Lloyd no representative
O'Neal yes representative
Sebert yes representative
philio
yes and the
chair chair votes
no two three four five six seven seven
in favor and 13
against so OTP fails uh 13 to7 do we
have another
motion representative
Massa motion itl motion is
second I'll second
that okay uh representative L seconds
that um do you wish to address speak to
your motion I already did
l i pass thank you okay uh
we need to vote on the uh motion of itl
[Music]
um and Madame clerk uh when you're ready
this should be a yes yes would mean uh
you're in favor of
itl okay representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative bone yes representative
levit yes representative na yes
representative gagy yes representative
pimonte yes representative finny no
representative Manion no representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative Carrie yes representative
tol no representative rung yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal no representative
Sebert no Representative philio
no and the
chair chair votes yes for itl
okay
15 six six six 14
six
so
how how do we want it to go on the
agenda um just just to clarify the uh
the first motion failed um OTP filled 13
to7 and then the motion for itl was
14-6 I just make someone changed was it
the rep
which is okay I just want to make sure
our numbers make and I second the motion
itl I was going to give representative
the benefit of the doubt but he was
short by four votes so I changed mine
okay so 14 to six it is uh represent
Mass having made the prevailing motion
if if you could uh make sure you or
someone gets a report to me okay uh rep
Manion I'm going to think you may want
to do a Minority Report yeah I'll do a
Minority Report
okay so that one uh will not be on
consent we'll have two reports coming to
uh U somebody have a question we good
representative over there had his hands
up I thought he was giving up
uh no I'm just gesturing across the
aisle okay
uh next up is uh hr21 house resolution
21 that has to do with the uh the
militia um the militia measure uh it's a
HR uh to support the militia uh R Manion
um do you have a motion on that one yeah
I motion OTP on this as well is there
and and again representative finny
second so representative Manion with a
motion representative finny with a
second representative Manion would you
here to speak to your motion uh yeah so
the
um the the militia is uh a separate
component so this would be the
unorganized militia that's inside of our
uh Constitution and the RSA also
provides for this uh unorganized mil
militia would be like any a able-body
individual over the age of 18 you're
responsible to train yourself you're
responsible in being well versed in
firearms and and things like that the
idea of this would be to repel
specifically The Invasion so like if the
National Guard is you know Tapped Out
sent overseas and God knows wherever and
we get invaded uh the militia would be
the last line of defense each and every
one of us is capable of being a part of
this militia and the reaffirming of the
militia this you know HR is just
basically saying we recognize that the
militia is a component of our our
current state law and it is something
uh just uh real quick I just want to add
that the militia is only made up of
citizens not made up of uniformed um you
know you know um like
armed body it's not you know like you
mentioned it's not part of the National
Guard it's not part of the the reserves
um is kind of related to the military um
I'm sorry the The Selective Service
component where if we're worried about
not having enough people who want to
join the military they still have the
option to be in a militia and to trade
and be proficient in firearms and and
you know that kind of training I think
it's important for all of us uh to be um
be willing to to do that for themselves
in their family we have a lot to to
uphold and protect here and I don't see
anything wrong with affirming
it thank you representative I have a
comment uh and it just has to do with uh
some confusion that is out there we all
I think we defend the guard bill this
came up uh time and again a lot of folks
don't understand that there different
levels of mil I I I think some of us do
in this committee um and that's what
this is about this is not about as I
understand it this is not about the
National Guard it's about uh raising
awareness and supporting the notion of
the the
militia um and I I have some mixed
feelings about that part partly because
uh I know there's there there will be
there is confusion we this contribute to
the confusion possibly is it our job to
educate people or maybe that's what will
come out of this is that that some
people will learn that there's different
levels of militia um again this is a v
your conscience thing as as an earlier
measure was uh I have some concerns
about it I understand the intent um it's
not an easy call for me I have some
concerns about it I I know that the our
friends in in
um
esac uh to include I I think the uh the
the adant in general had had some um con
questions and concern about out it too
so anyway I I uh I have problems with it
and that's that's where I'm at other
thoughts uh representative
levit uh we discussed this pretty well
in the public hearing and um I don't see
a needed law to have militia I mean I
understand it just probably
authenticates it but I mean on the fence
too I mean the you know the testimony
didn't sway me towards it but um I I
probably would be okay with it but I'm
not siding on the um positive side on
this
one thank you representative other
thoughts represent
Miller I'm one of those confused people
because I looked up information and it
said that in
1879 the New Hampshire militia was
designated as the New Hampshire National
Guard and that in
1916 the National Defense Act changed
that to the na New Hampshire National
Guard so can you give me some clarity
here yeah so the uh what had been the
militia for like the standing army the
state whatever it may be had eventually
been incorporated into the National
Guard but our RSA provides for a
separate organization and the agitant
general did specify that we do have
every single one of us an able-body
individual it could be in the militia
it's the unorganized militia the militia
before the as you were saying the 1800s
was cons has been rolled up into the
National Guard each and every one of us
is the militia like in the Second
Amendment or the United States it
mentions the well-regulated militia
that's all of us that's exactly what
this is describing you don't want me in
your a militia that's okay it's it's
voluntary it's not a cons I I oppose
you uh what else uh other thoughts
comments discussion questions Rosen
finny will you just make a motion I saw
your hand
okay uh car carry on all right seeing No
Hands uh the motion is
OTP on hr21 relative to the um status of
the Melissa militia supporting that uh
OTP motion Madame chair when you're
ready representative Rollins yes
Representative lungren no representative
bone yes representative levit nope
Representative nter no representative
gagy yes representative
pimonte yes representative finny oh yeah
representative Manion yes Representative
shirtliff no representative Mass Miller
no no representative Jack no
representative Carri no representative
tol representative rung no
representative Lloyd no representative
O'Neal no representative Sebert no
representative philio
yes and the chair chair votes
no two three four five six seven8 9 10
yes it does what was the count uh the
motion fails um
13 against and seven in
favor so the OTP motion failed 13 to7 uh
motion I repres represent Lloyd yes I'd
like to motion to itl um just under the
uh understanding oh wait I guess do I
need to wait for a second or I'll all
right you did get a second uh from
representa representative shlif soken
thank you just under the understanding
that there's a lot of confusion around
this and I think it needs to be uh
clarified I certainly understand that a
militia is recognized in the
Constitution but um just making sure
that uh everything's squared away repres
shiff I
think the motion speaks for itself the
member
said Thank you anything else any on this
okay if not the uh the latest motion is
itl on
hr21 Madame clerk when you are
ready okay representative Rollins no
representative lungren yes
representative bone no representative
levit
oh
yeah representative naer yes
Representative gagy no Representative
ponti no representative finny no
representative Manion no representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Jack yes
representative Carrie yes representative
tol yes representative rung yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
O'Neal yes representative Sebert yes
Representative
philio
no okay and the clerk and the uh
chair the clerk chair says uh Mo says
yes to the ilt motion okay thank you two
three four five six
seven 13 to seven again this time in
itl okay third there was 137 yes
representative Lloyd uh can I hear from
you or ENT by S evening yeah thank you
and uh Minority Report I'll take it
represent Manion stepping up thank you
representative okay uh moving right
along and thank you everyone for uh for
hanging in and working with us on
getting through all these consent
calendar on this no it's it's 13 to7
okay uh HB 1041 the US Li commission to
look into the US s Liberty incident uh
looking for a motion on that um I motion
OTP again thank you uh I'll
second okay the motion from
representative Manion on HB 1041 is OTP
a to pass seconded by representative
Rollins and uh okay repres Manion
uh yep so when these uh men came in uh I
when I first saw this bill filed I I was
vaguely aware of the USS Liberty
incident but I think what I understood
was only the official story which is
that that it was an accident and you
know no malfant and the government did
everything they could to investigate it
and then having all of those veterans
come in here and speak and tell their
story from their perspective I
understand how disconnected DC can be
from like combat operations like things
happen on the ground and the guys that
have been there they know better than
those guys sitting in the Pentagon they
don't the guys over there that are doing
their reports like they're just
disconnected from reality and I feel
like this goes back decades right this
is in the 60s and I feel like nothing's
changed in 50 years and they got like
brushed over by congress with like they
said what was it a five-day
investigation where some of these other
investigations have gone on for years
for next to nothing like how long did
the Clinton dress thing go on for right
and like these men like were attacked by
hours right it took hour like the the
combat like the the assault took hours
and hours it was a lot more than just a
mistaken identity if it was a mistaken
identity it would have been a single
shot and they would have flagged from my
understanding these men had the U the US
flag flying high and it was completely
ignored I don't want to you know assign
motivations or anything behind at all
and that's what I think this committee
should try to find we may not have
subpoena power against like classified
documents things that the government has
locked away but I think it would be
valuable to put these men in front of a
committee get all of their record their
testimony on record because all that
they have is they've been maligned by
the media they they're stuck like all
they do is like they're on podcast just
trying to get their truth out there and
all they want is like their day in court
so to speak and they never got it these
men never got it
thank you representative representive
Rollins you you seconded
it yes I'd like to also speak I'd like
to take a a moment uh everybody here on
this committee had I think well maybe
not some of the subs but knows I'm a
gold sta father I lost my son in Iraq
the night before his last night home on
leave um we went outside we were having
a couple beer together he asked me to
make him three promises if he didn't
make it home I made him the three
promises and I held to all three okay
then he made me a promise the promise
that made that he made me was not unique
to my son but it is unique to everyone
that has worn a uniform in this country
ever since the Revolutionary War and it
is unique to those men on the Liberty
that were shot up that day where we lost
over was 178 men I think it was and
others
wounded that's a that's a promise that
we need to make back to these people
people that understanding the sacrifice
that they make um they sign on the
dotted line when you sign up for the
service you sign on a dotted line up to
and including including my own life okay
that's understandable my son paid that
price many many like several million
people in history the United States has
made that sacrifice and paid that price
but for these men on this on that ship
they did not sign up to be sacri
official Lambs to a higher government
order and be left there to die and hope
that they were all the boat would sink
and they would all go to the bottom of
the
ocean that is wrong that is just dead
wrong I will stand by every veteran for
what my son serve for to my dying day
and I'll take a bullet for any any
veteran out there I cely hope that
everyone put some serious consideration
into voting ought to pass on this on
this belt I know some people say well
the timing is not good it's not about
timing this is a simple house resolution
bill just asking Washington to give them
where the these men have been ignored
for 56 years no state would ever take a
resolution up like that New Hampshire is
the first state that has actually said
we will do we will take this resolution
up and we will vote on it those men were
EST static they're finally being heard
these men
deserve closure just like I had closure
when my son's remains came home I hope
that you can find it in your heart
Overlook other things and to support
these men for what they have been
through for the last what they went
through that day and what they've been
through for the last 56 years where
nobody nobody would listen to them and I
am appalled that that's my saying Mr
chairman M Mr chairman uh representative
gagy thank you I share the
sentiments I share got to keep my
fingers to myself I share the sentiments
of these two gentlemen here now I served
in the 60s I served I got out just
before this
incident um I was on shipboard I never
was in combat never did any shooting no
no combat except a
Shore and
uh and I know in my
heart that unfortunately
this probably won't get any legs when it
gets to the higher hierarchy however
what I want for those Shipmates is
closure and that's what they're looking
it uh representative
n thank you and representative Rollins I
I um respect you more than I can ever
say and I have your son's picture
hanging in my
office I was not not here for the
hearing I didn't hear what was said what
I I I do understand it's to my
understanding that this um the USS
Liberty was fully investigated three
times and Israel already apologized
decades ago and with anti-Semitism On
The Rise I fear that voting for this
measure will get me labeled in the media
by as an anti-semite and I don't I I
don't want to do that so my vote does
here representative finny yeah we're not
talking about you know stuff that that's
happening now we're talking about
something that happened in the 60s and
if there was Bad actors in the
government on the American side they
should be called out for who they are if
they sent those men to die as a as a
political Pawn then they should be held
accountable and that's what that you
know that's what this bill is trying to
do but it's only established as a
commission we're not actually like going
to the investigative process into this
in it we're just establishing a
commission to gain information so that's
it representative Sheriff thank you Mr
chairman with all due respect from my
friend from Newport uh I'm going to join
my friend from meramac and vote against
this and I'd like to tell the committee
why
um first of all if I wish this had if
they wanted a study it was a house study
and not a commission um I looked through
the bill because I was really torn over
this and I was in the Army at the time
this happened and uh and it brings back
a lot of sad memories of that
time in this commission well first of
all both the American Legion and the VFW
are opposed to the bill and and I belong
to both organization and I respect what
they do my other concern looking through
this bill they listed that the um a
group uh known as the Council of
national interest will have a seat on
this
panel um the executive director of the
Council of national interest is a man by
the name of Phil
Gerard Phil Gera previously served on
the um campaign for Palestinian
rights uh he was kicked off that group
in 2017 because one of the bylaws of the
campaign for Palestinian rights as
you'll do no comments as anything
anti-semitic he wrote an article for a p
uh for a magazine uh un's review which
the Palestinians felt to be very
anti-semitic and kicked them off of that
board his group is going to be part of
those that are going to be investigating
this I wish I wish they had never made
this a commission I am troubled by the
fact that they have someone who had has
a Palestinian Rights group kicked off
their board for being anti-semitic I
think it brings uh dishonor to those
poor veterans who served on the liberty
and the fact that there are five
represent five members of the
legislature and eight people from
outside sources on this that means
outside sources will have a lot of
control over what the final outcome will
be and for that reason you know if there
was anything to honor those people that
served on this ship and to Ser honor my
friend son I would support it but having
found out about this one connection I
cannot vote for this bill and I thank
you Mr
chair thank you representative I'm not
sure who who's you you all okay uh
representa M Miller go ahead um I concur
I concur with what representative
schliff said and also I I'm afraid I
don't like the idea of a commission
that's for sure um and and I do
sympathize with the people that were on
the USS Liberty I have a constituent who
was on a ship that transported agent
orange during Vietnam War and yet the
government denied that that happened and
so many of the members have come down
with fatal cancers and things like that
and they can't get any recognition by
the US government for medical assistance
and stuff like that and it just concerns
me that if we do this and and you all
deserve to be recognized I I have no
problem with that in some way um that
will open up all of the wrongs that have
been done during that war where other
people will seek commission type status
to investigate and that's a big concern
of mine thank
you thank you representative uh
representative
filot thank you Mr chairman I was not
aware of this incident prior to the
testimony that we had last week and as I
was talking to other people about it who
were equally unaware and the the
following week the same word came up
over and over again which was
unconscionable and certainly what
happened in the response afterwards was
unconscionable and nothing that can be
done nothing that can ever be done can
take away the unconscionability of what
was done or the sacrifices that were
made not only by these men but all of
our veterans to whom we owe deck that
really can never be
repaid my only concern is that the
central sin of government and law is to
give false hope and having sat across
from clients and having to had the the
tough conversation of saying there's
nothing I can do for you I can file a
suit but it's going to go nowhere is a
tough conversation to have and my fear
here is giving false hope for a
commission that may go nowhere to lead
back to where we are now and not provide
the closure that is
sought that the commission may seem like
the way to go but state power is limited
and it may be that other outcomes can
provide the closure that state power
cannot and that is my concern here I
don't know how I'm going to vote yet and
welcome to be convinced but I fear
providing false hope that we end up in
the same position that we are now in a
couple
years thank you reprentative represent
seber yeah I Echo um the previous
comment um
wholeheartedly um about the false hope
um and how far we can actually go with
this and are we just going to get
another you know redacted version and
not be able to get an unredacted version
of of events and things like that that
are of National
Security and um you know but I just
wanted to say that I was extremely
honored to have been here last Friday to
hear everyone's stories I felt um
extremely touched and um it almost
brought tears to my eyes that um they
were just happy to be able to speak here
in front of an official committee about
what they went through and I have the
utmost respect for them their families
especially that are here today as well
um and that's all I wanted to say thank
you thank you representative represent
LE your lights on but
but your your lights on but you didn't
have your hand okay uh rep represent
Lloyd hi thank you um I was just kind of
curious um because I I I agree with the
sentiment sentiments that have just been
shared and then with um with
representative shirtliff over there as
well
um are there any other options for us
with this or or with something similar
to workaround uh that we could Pro
propose because again I just don't want
to um deny these individuals their
ability to um to uh try to apply for uh
another hearing of some sort and a
better investigation that satisfies what
they want thank you repres
representative Lloyd we have a motion on
the floor at the moment which we need to
tend to uh shortly um to your point
about uh what other options are out
there I think that that's something that
would need to be discussed or what
whatever uh after we tend to the motion
on the floor uh I will say uh let me say
this um this is a very unique measure um
it's very unusual when this came to this
committee when I first heard of it I I'm
old enough to remember the Six Day War
in this incident and uh I know there was
one or two Congressional Medals of Honor
um so when these gentlemen came from all
over the country they were calling me uh
for whatever reason asking how to get
here from Baltimore or from Missouri or
from Colorado so the fact that these
guys uh wanted to come here and testify
because this this Mo this measure was
put in um was very moving and um and I
told the prime sponsor ahead of time I
said we have limited time to tend to
this I want these guys to be taken care
of and I made sure that there was
something downstairs where they could
talk uh once they were
here uh I think um that we gave them a
gift um by giving them our ears and our
eyes uh I do not know how how this is
going to this is a very unique measure
uh I do not know it's a vulture
conscience measure I I do not know how
it's going to come out to your point uh
however it comes out uh there there will
be an option uh I can tell that it's
going to be a a split vote don't know
what it's going to be it will go to the
house and uh there may be something that
can be done there or not uh that's later
for now we need to U vote on the motion
on the floor uh this is uh presumably on
on YouTube uh and maybe the gentlemen
and their families and many others are
are watching and I think I hope that the
fact that we're paying attention to them
in this fashion in ways that uh others
have not for decades uh I hope is a gift
to them because uh whatever happens
people know many people know about this
incident who did not know about it uh
and yes there's some been some
wonderful uh comments and discussion
points uh on both sides that I think are
very fair uh commissions uh you
know represent Sher made some excellent
points about some issues with the makeup
of the commission and we want to be
careful about commissions and committing
time and resources and I think
representative philo's point was
excellent about the false hope thing um
but my my point is this is a vulture
conscious thing we'll run the role
momentarily um I want the survivors who
I know are watching or will watch to
know that uh we all heard them uh a lot
of people are going to get smarter about
this uh their stories need to be
remembered representative Rollin son um
out of this uh is on our minds and his
spirit and memory stays alive because of
this motion that that's something that
uh who
knew so uh it's a vure concious thing I
do not know how it's going to go um
those are my quick thoughts um does
anyone else uh representative Lev thank
you chair Mett so after the debate
everybody here would agree this I might
answered questions that's without a
doubt I think there should be an
appropriate motion made after the vote
thank
you uh representative
B thank you Mr chair yeah I have a
problem with the makeup of the
commission as representative Sherl
mentioned but
remember a floor amendment can be done
and also it's got to go to the Senate
where those changes could be made but
yeah I'm yeah it's up in the air to me
because yeah I don't like the commission
make up with somebody with an
anti-Semitism um conscience so yeah I'm
happens uh represent
Rollins yes you said you didn't know
whether anybody be watching I'm not sure
whether they are or not but I did
contact Reverend Bryce Lockwood
yesterday by email and told him that we
may ex this this afternoon if we had
time and I will follow through with a
phone call to him immediately after this
committee is done today so he'll know
where he stands and know what the count
is going into the going into onto the
house
floor and I'm sure he has shared it with
I thank you repon
Rollins uh any other comments uh
representative Manion this one's real
quick one thing I would say it's like
the the anti-Semitism and the Israel
thing to me the failure is from the
United States government here more than
anything like I I that's my take
here anything else so I have a quick
question only because of something
representative Rollin said he said it
was a resolution but it's in fact a bill
oh a house bill sorry yeah yeah correct
it's a bill to create a commission
correct okay yeah all right so I think
you know some folks may feel differently
if it was a resolution versus a
commission
yeah that that's a a good point an
interesting point if it were a
resolution that would be obviously a
different Dynamic than than a house bill
that would require a
commission anything
else okay we need to uh attend to the
motion on the floor the motion on the
floor is uh is
OT is
OTP and uh Madame clerk Let's uh run the
role on that okay representative Rollins
yes Representative lungren no
representative bom yes representative
levit yes Representative nter no
representative gagy yes representative
pimonte yes representative Finny yes
representative Manion yes Representative
Miller representative Jack no
representative Carrie no representative
tol representative rung no
representative Lloyd this is not the end
um but no representative O'Neal no
representative Sebert no representative
filio
regretful
no
against so
the so the OTP motion fails we need uh
alternate motion make
motion from uh representative L yes wait
oh I'm sorry you called me uh represent
affilate uh go ahead a a procedural
question do we have an alternative to
putting it given that this is the second
year of the term do we have an an option
other than itl for this bill at least at
this point terms uh representative
shirtliff uh please thank you uh Mr
chairman what I would recommend amend is
that we table any further action on this
bill for now we're going to be meeting I
believe in a week or so and I think in
the interim if we could come up with a
uh
uh um a resolution simply honoring the
men on the USS Liberty and their service
to our country not get into the politics
but just thank them for their service
what they went through and each and
every member of that ship was a hero
bring that up our next motion would be
we've already got the one
itl um uh move to REM uh retain the
other one the any the bill and then
bring forward this motion to uh
substitute it with a
resolution thank you representative so
the OTP motion failed uh we do not have
to as I understand the procedures we do
not have to immediately uh come up with
an alter alternate motion and just to
say if you wanted just to vote uh to
table it for the rest of the day and
talk to the clerk even and get his
Insight is the best way to go but not
take any further action today and not
take up the
itl uh thank you rep I'm sure if there
has been no subsequent motion made you
suggested uh that we com uh table I
don't know if table's the right word but
re recess discussion on this on this
measure and come back to it at the next
exec session
uh that and that's something I can just
do and uh before I do that uh I see a
hand up representative L like to make a
motion what's your motion to retain this
bill we cannot retain the the options uh
would be OTP having failed we could look
at an interim study option we could look
at a itl option uh but for now we're not
going to look at any option we're going
to come back to that that's uh that uh
somebody uh repr Jack uh thank you let
me ask the uh the U esteemed uh former
speaker if he thinks the appropriate
thing is to recess this executive
session at this time that was my
suggestion to recess the talk with the
clerk
but uh we we have one more measure that
we wanted to attend to uh can can we
attend to that measure and then you can
recess the hearing on
this to to our next meeting I think it's
February 2nd
yes that's uh my intent and that's what
I will do is that uh before I do that
representative Pani yeah yes if we do
that we're gonna have to uh Ren notice
this on oh it'll be in the calendar
calendar right and that would be it
would have to be February
2nd okay so my intent and my decision is
that we will do exactly that we will
come back to this measure on February
2nd it'll be noticed in the calendar and
we will uh complete our work
on uh HB 1041 on that at that time uh Mr
Speaker ameritus that sounds like it's
it's in order it is does me okay so that
is what we'll we'll do with that one and
then the last measure we have today is a
cacr 13 that is the motion that or that
is the uh CAC uh constit uh
Constitutional Amendment concurrent
resolution that had to do with slavery
involuntary servitude so let's uh
representative toll your hand is up yep
I'm going to I'm going to move for CAC
13 ought to pass um I think um
slavery it should be obvious to all of
us that like it's unacceptable it's a
stain on our nation's history and um
this is a racial justice issue it's an
economic justice issue and we should
absolutely 100% move forward with this
thank you so much much I'd like to
Second uh yes I think we uh you're you
jumped ahead of the second uh but I is
there a second uh we do have a second
representative cber second set
representative to has already spoken to
her motion representative
cber would you care to speak to your
second oh um ditto is what Amanda
said okay I concur so we have a motion
of uh
OTP on uh cacr
uh I want to
mention uh to the to the committee uh
one of my concerns on this had to do and
I mention this dur during the hearing uh
was with regard to
Corrections and would If This Were to
move forward if it were to become part
of the Constitution would that hamstring
or would it would it uh have a make it
difficult for the corrections people to
have uh incarcerated people do things
without being uh subject to lawsuits for
breaking the Constitution so
I reached out and I got and I think I
believe I sent this I shared this with
committee members I got an opinion from
the uh Commissioner of Department of
Corrections from do uh Helen Hanks and
uh she not only said that she uh had no
problem with the measure but she
actually uh enthusiastically supported
it so that made a big difference for me
were she have were were she had to were
she to have said that this with
hamstring Corrections and that's
something that I think I would have had
had wanted to spend more time on but
given what I heard what we heard from
Corrections commissioner uh that's not
an issue for me that was my issue and
this uh seeing no hands on this
Constitutional Amendment concurrent
resolution I guess Madame clerk we're
ready to go to a
rooll okay representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative bone yes representative
Lev yep representative n yes
Kim representative PNY representative
Manion yes representative shirtliff yes
representative M Miller yes
representative Jack yes representative
Carrie yes representative tol yes
representative rung yes representative
Lloyd yes representative O'Neal yes
representative Sebert yes representative
philio
yes and the chair chair votes yes that
is unanimous that is a cacr so that
cannot go on consent uh it will come to
the floor so before I swing my gavel to
uh wait uh thank you uh Christine has
her hand
up no we're not going to do that
today oh I'm sorry yes also uh on the
docket or was public thank you uh uh
hr28 which was the uh the measure having
to do with the the past situation in
Greater miramac um I've been in we've
been in touch with the uh the prime
sponsor who wanted some time to work on
the language and I think we have SE but
uh you've been in communication with her
on that as well yeah so uh yes so we're
we're going to recess that one until uh
a later date we'll schedule that the
same as we will with uh HB 1041 so
Christina that are we good that covers
again
okay uh okay before we close uh uh we
representative is it I I can make that
decision and I'll give you I'll give you
more than 20 seconds uh
okay
[Music]
the committee always LS to hear good
things we don't always hear good things
thank you
representative uh okay representative n
leading okay we're going to close uh
check your email those with you with
reports we'll we'll see you we'll be in
touch by Sunday night and thank you for
your time today it was a long day thank
thank you for your efforts your email is
working right chair
M say say again rep your email is
working again uh you got it yep it's up
it's
up